ALL RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE AND WELCOME TO OUR
FIRST HEARING THIS YEAR OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES.
TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL HEARING
WILL BE ON THE ANNUAL UPDATE ON
STATEWIDE TRENDS OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. AS WELL AS AN
OVERVIEW OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO SCOPING PLAN. A BEFORE WE
BEGAN I WANT TO. MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS AWARE THAT TO DO
THE- ONGOING PANDEMIC THAT WE
HAVE A MASK REQUIREMENT FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING ROOM.
WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THIS HEARING FROM
THOSE- HERE IN PERSON. THOSE
APPEARING REMOTELY ON THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL AND FROM
THOSE CALLING BY PHONE. THE
CALL IN BY PHONE AND THE PHONE
NUMBER IS. TOLL FREE.
877-692-8957 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN AGAIN
THAT IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. EACH PERSON-
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE- TO SPEAK. AND
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO BEGIN THE
HEARING. TODAY'S HEARING IS
INTENDED TO NOT ONLY MEET- OUR
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO PROVIDE THIS COMMITTEE WITH
AN ANNUAL UPDATE ON STATEWIDE
TRENDS OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. BUT AS THE AND JENNA
INDICATES- WE- WILL BE
DISCUSSING MUCH MORE. WE ALL
KNOW THAT- HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE. SEEING IMMEDIATELY VIA
FAX OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS WITH
THE WILD FIRES THE EXTREME
DROUGHT. THE EXTREME HEAT-
SEALEVEL RISE AND IN SO MANY
MORE REALITIES THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE FACING ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS. GIVEN THE
URGENCY OF THE MOMENT GIVEN THE
TIMING OF THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD'S SCOPING PLAN. THE
RECENT- INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL
ON CLIMATE CHANGE. REPORT AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S RECENT
LETTER ASKING THE A ARE BE TO
LOOK AT WHETHER- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY- EARLIER ON EARLIER
TIMELINE BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO HAVE A DEEPER
DISCUSSION WITH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ON ITS PLANS
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SCOPING PLAN. AS WELL AS THEIR
EVALUATION OF OUR PROGRESS
TOWARD THE NEAR TERM. TWENTY
THIRTY GOLD THE STATUTORY
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL- AS-
CODIFIED. THROUGH SENATE BILL
THIRTY TWO. AS WELL AS THEIR
WORK ON CHARTING A PATH TOWARD
CARBON NEUTRALITY. AS SUCH THE
ARB WILL REPEAT BE PRESENTING
ON EACH OF THESE ITEMS AS
INDICATED ON THE AGENDA. FOR IN
ADDITION TO THE A. R. BE ABLE
TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF OUR THE
REST OF OUR AGENDA WE WILL ALSO
BE HEARING- FROM. TO
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS MARKET
ADVISORY COMMITTEE- BE HEARING
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AS WELL AS A FROM A
DIVERSE GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS
ON THEIR VIEWS ON THESE TOPICS
THAT WILL BE ADDRESSING TODAY.
I WE WILL ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING THEIR SUGGESTIONS ON
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING AS WE DELIBERATE A
PATH TOWARD CARBON NEUTRALITY.
I WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE ALL
OF THE SPEAKERS TODAY TO-
SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS TO THIS
COMMITTEE- THIS COMMITTEE WILL
BE PUBLISHING. A FOLLOW UP
DOCUMENT- AFTER THIS HEARING
THAT WILL SUMMARIZE- THE VERBAL
AS WELL AS- WRITTEN COMMENTS.
SUBMITTED TODAY. THIS DOCUMENT-
WILL- NOT ONLY CAPTURE WHAT IS
DISCUSSED TODAY BUT- FORMULATE-
SUGGESTIONS FOR OUR NEXT STEPS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE- THESE
SUGGESTIONS WOULD BE IN THE
FORM OF ACTIONABLE ITEMS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER AND
PURSUE- SO WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO. NOW TURN OVER THE
FIRST TO THE VICE CHAIR THIS
COMMITTEE- CENTER BACKER AND TO
THE- OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
JOINT COMMITTEE. STE THANK YOU
OF A FEW I THANK THE CHAIR OKAY.
RIGHT GOT IT. THANK YOU I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND HIS
TEAM FOR THE WORK PREPARING FOR
AS A KID THE A HEARING TODAY
AND ALLOW US TO MAKE SOME
OPENING COMMENTS I ALSO WANT TO
THANK VERY MUCH ALL THE
PANELISTS THAT WE'LL HEAR FROM
TODAY. FOR SHARING THEIR
EXPERTISE AND KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCES WITH US- AS THE
CHAIR MENTION IT'S HARD TO
THINK OF A TOPIC MORE IMPORTANT
THAN THIS ONE- WITH LARGE PARTS
OF OUR STATE OUR OUR LITTLE ON
FIRE AND EXPERIENCE A HISTORIC
DROUGHT- BOTH EVIDENCE. OF THE-
IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
ALREADY. I THINK WE'RE AT A
CRUCIAL POINT. I WAS REMARKING
RESET MEMBER IN SCENA FIRST
PROTOTYPE ELECTRIC VEHICLE IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE WE WERE.
PREPARING FOR THE CLEANER
MARKET PLACE CONFERENCE AS
HELPING THE EPA LAUNCH AT THE
TIME. AND I REMEMBER THINKING
THIS WOULD BE ON THE ROAD IN NO
TIME WE'LL SEE DRAMATIC
PROGRESS- AND OBVIOUSLY. THE
PROGRESS WAS LIMITED BUT THAT
IT WAS REALLY LIMITED BY THE
TECHNOLOGY WE REALLY WEREN'T
QUITE READY AT THAT TIME. AND
NOW THINGS ARE DIFFERENT. BUT
THE TECHNOLOGY IS CLEARLY THERE
TO ACCOMPLISH OUR GOALS. AND SO
WITH THAT IT REALLY IS A POLICY.
QUESTION CALIFORNIA NEEDS
POLICIES TO SPEED UP THE
DEPLOYMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES WE
ALREADY HAVE. AND RIDE THE
RIGHT INCENTIVE SO ENGINEERS
ENTREPRENEURS CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK ON NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
REFINING AND SPEEDING UP THE
ONES WE HAVE WHETHER THAT BE A
SOLAR WIND GEOTHERMAL- LOW
CARBON CEMENT AND LOTS OF OTHER
AREAS. THE NEWS FROM THE I PCC
IS EXTREMELY ALARMING AND THE
SITUATION IS EVEN MUCH MORE
DIRE THAN WE THOUGHT SO AS
LEGISLATORS AND POLICY MAKERS
IT'S REALLY UP TO US
CALIFORNIA'S ALWAYS BEEN A
GLOBAL LEADER IN CLIMATE POLICY.
SO WHAT WE DO MATTERS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND ACROSS THE
WORLD. AND IF WE SUCCEED WE
PROVIDE A ROADMAP TO OTHERS IF
WE FAIL TO PROGRESSIVE PASSED
ENOUGH. THEN YOU KNOW HOW TO
EXPECT OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES TO DO SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL
MEMBERS. OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
WITH THE CHAIR TO MAKE SURE THE
CALIFORNIA DOES SUCCEED.
ASSESSING FOR THE REST OF WORLD
TO FOLLOW THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH CENTER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER BACKER. WOULD
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LIKE TO CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU CARE AND-
VICE CHAIR- APPRECIATE YOUR
COORDINATING AND SETTING THIS
HEARING UP AND THE PANELISTS
THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO HEAR FROM
AND THE COMMENTS THAT YOU BOTH
MADE- WE CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
VERY GOOD. AT SENDING VERY
STRONG MARKE SIGNALS THAT HAVE
HELPED US. ON THIS PROCESS OF
OR ARE TRANSITION TO
DECARBONIZE OUR ECONOMY AND WE
CAN LOOK AT THE SUCCESS OF
SOLAR WE CAN LOOK AT THE
SUCCESS AT MULTIPLE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES SO MUCH MORE- BUT
WE'RE AT A CROSSROADS ACROSS I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT. I'D EVERY
TERMINOLOGY AND I MIGHT CHOOSE
TO USE RIGHT NOW SEEMS TRIVIAL
CONSIDERING THE ENORMITY OF THE
CRISIS THAT WE ARE FACING RIGHT
NOW AND THE SCIENCE. THE
CLARITY OF THE SCIENCE THAT THE
I. P. P. C. REPORT JUST
REVEALED. AND SO WHAT I AM ALSO
INTERESTED IN CLEARLY I WANT US
TO CONTINUE TO SEND VERY STRONG
MARKET SIGNALS BUT I ONE OF US
TO ALSO MAKE SURE THAT WE LOOK
AT. THOSE WAYS THAT WE CAN
CAPTURE CARBON AND BY THAT I
DON'T MEAN ONLY THAT CAPTURING
CARBON SAY AT A FOSSIL FUEL
FACILITY BUT RATHER. IN ALL OF
THE NATURAL SYSTEMS BECAUSE
THERE IS THE I. P. P. REPORT
ALSO REVEALS THAT THERE IS
GREAT CAPACITY WITHIN OUR
NATURAL SYSTEMS SOILS.
GRASSLANDS OTHERS TO DO THAT
FOR US IN ADDITION TO VARIOUS
TECHNOLOGIES AND TECHNOLOGICAL
WAYS TO DO IT AND I- IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT WE MAY NOT
HAVE FOCUSED ON THAT BECAUSE
OUR- FOCUS TO DATE LEGITIMATELY
HAS BEEN AN EMISSIONS
REDUCTION. BUT I THINK WE ALSO
NEED TO GREATLY- FOCUS IN THAT
AREA AND I'M CURIOUS TO HEAR
FROM. OUR PANELISTS- THOUGHTS
ON THAT SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER SKINNER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I WASN'T
PLANNING ON SPEAKING- BUT OUT
OF THE HABIT IS TO SAY A FEW
WORDS. I DO THINK IT IN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE- I THINK I'M
THE ONE I NINE- A PARTISAN ON
THIS- ON THIS DAY IN THIS
COMMITTEE. BUT IT'S ALSO
CLIMATE CHANGE HAS BEEN ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT- AFTER
LOOKING AND STUDYING THE
SCIENCES SOMETHING I'VE I'VE
TAKEN UP- AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS- THAT
IS NOT JUST A REAL IT'S AND
IT'S WITH THOSE PURSING IT
EVERY SINGLE DAY. I THINK THE
ONE FRUSTRATION FOR ME IS WHEN
WE LOOK AT CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADER.
IN THIS SPACE ARE CERTAINLY NO
DOUBT ABOUT THAT GLOBALLY WE'VE
BEEN WE'VE BEEN A LEADER. I
STILL DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE A
VERY CLEAR ROADMAP ON WHAT IT
IS THAT WE'RE GOING. TO DO WAS
IT JUST. A REDUCING OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS IS NOT ENOUGH WE HAVE
TO GET TO A POINT. TO NOT ONLY
A CARBON NEUTRAL ABOR ALSO
CARBON NEGATIVE. THE QUESTION
IS HOW DO WE GET THERE AND WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE WHAT'S THE
ROAD MAP. FOR US TO FOLLOW AND
THAT'S NOT CLEAR I EVEN STATE
POLICY WE'VE DONE SOME AMAZING
STATE POLICY. IN THIS SPACE BUT
IT ISN'T VERY CLEAR VERY WELL
THOUGHT OUT POLICY WE PICKED A
LOT OF WINNERS AND LOSERS. AND
YET BUT WE HAVEN'T DONE IS JUST
DECIDED HERE'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO HERE IS THE ROADMAP FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO GET YOU SO
HOPEFULLY. WITH THIS COMMITTING
AS WE BEGIN TO WORK- WITHIN
BOTH HOUSES. AND NOT JUST THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION BUT NEXT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. WE CAN PUT
THAT TOGETHER. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUST AS AN ASIDE. I DO HAVE A
PLAN FOR THAT BUT WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THAT. AND THEN THE
LOCATION. I ALSO WANT TO
WELCOME CENTER ALLEN- BUT- LIKE
I JUST REPLY WITH IMMENSELY
IMPORTANT TOPIC- I WAS. ALREADY
PRETTY FIRED UP ABOUT THIS
ISSUE I'VE GOT ALL THE MORE SO
BY READING THAT IPCC REPORT
MA'AM I'M CERTAINLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THIS DISCUSSION
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR SO
WITH THAT. OF THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD LIANE RANDOLPH- MADAM
CHAIR WELCOME AND PLEASE BEGIN
YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME- I AM
GOING TO BE SHARING FOR THE
SLIGHTEST PART OF MY
PRESENTATION- THIS IS THE-
FIRST OPPORTUNITY I HAVE PRIDE
YOU APPEAR BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AND GIVE AN UPDATE ON
OUR AB ONE NINETY SEVEN WORK SO
I'M VERY PLEASED TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY. ALRIGHT. OKAY SO FIRST I
WANTED TO START- WITH AIR
QUALITY. THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
HAD REMARKABLE SUCCESSES IN
TERMS OF- DEALING WITH OUR AIR
QUALITY RESPONSIBILITIES BPA
THAT HEALTH BASED STANDARDS AND
IT'S REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW TO
REGULARLY REVIEW THOSE
STANDARDS TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
HEALTH PROTECTIVE BASED ON THE
LATEST SCIENCE AND INPUT FROM
CARD. NOT OXIDES OF NITROGEN
ARE ONE OF THE KEY SMOG FORMING
POLLUTANTS WE CONTROL TO
PREVENT OZONE. FORMATION AND
THE CHART ON THE SLIDE SHOWS
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS IN
REDUCING NOT COMMISSION SINCE
TWO THOUSAND. EMISSIONS HAVE
BEEN STEADILY DECREASING SINCE
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES DUE TO
MULTIPLE REGULATIONS OVER
ADOPTED OVER TIME. AND THAT'S
PROGRESS REALLY REFLECTS THE
BENEFITS OF CARBONI PA PROGRAMS
FOR MOBILE BIRTH IS AN AIR
DISTRICT PROGRAMS FOR
STATIONARY. MOBILE SEARCHES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE LARGEST
SHARE OF NOT EMISSIONS
REDUCTION DUE TO MORE STRINGENT
ENGINE STANDARDS CLEANER FUEL
AN INCENTIVE FUNDING. OUR GRAPH
REFLECTS THESE BENEFITS.
BECAUSE MOBILE SOURCES THEIR
RESPONSIBLE 480% OF ****
MISSION DANCE- STANDARDS.
WIENER FEELS AN INCENTIVE
FINDINGS HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE
FOR A LARGE PORTION OF THIS
PROGRESS. FOR EXAMPLE EMISSIONS
FROM A NEW CAR ARE 99% CLEANER
THAN A CAR FROM THE EARLY
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. AND AS YOU
KNOW THE STANDARD SET HERE IN
CALIFORNIA A COPY THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY AND THE WORLD. THAT
PEOPLE WELL BEYOND OUR BORDERS
BENEFIT FROM OUR LEADERSHIP.
HARPER AND THE AIR DISTRICTS
HAVE ALSO WORKED TO REDUCE RISK
OF EXPOSURE TO AIR TOXICS FROM
INDUSTRIAL SOURCES LIKE
REFINERY. SMALLER SOURCES LIKE
GAS STATIONS AND MOBILE SOURCES
LIKE DIESEL TRUCKS. CALIFORNIA
THEIR TACTICS PROGRAM BEGAN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE WITH THE
ADOPTION OF THE TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANT IDENTIFICATION AND
CONTROL ACT. AND THE STATE HAS
IDENTIFIED OVER TWO HUNDRED
SUBSTANCES THAT ARE HAZARDOUS
TO HEALTH. AND HAVE ADOPTED
NUMEROUS REGULATIONS TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND EXPOSURE TO THESE
POLLUTANTS INCLUDING LIMITING
THE LEVELS OF BENZENE IN
GASOLINE AND PHASING OUT THE
USE OF. CARCINOGENS FROM DRY
CLEANERS BY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THE STATE'S EFFORTS
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON REDUCING
EMISSIONS OF DIESEL PARTICULATE
WHICH ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT 70% OF
THE TOTAL KNOWN CANCER RISK
RELATED TO TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANT. THESE NUMBERS AND
TRENDS ARE IMPRESSIVE. THE AIR
IS CLEANER. THREE THIRTY
THOUSAND PREMATURE DEATHS ARE
AVOIDED EACH YEAR TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ASTHMA CASES
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED. ALL THE
WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS GROWN TO
BE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD. BUT LET ME BE CLEAR
THERE ISN'T MORE WORK AHEAD OF
US. ACTION AT LEAST ONE THIRD
OF CALIFORNIA'S THIRTY NINE
POINT FIVE MILLION RESIDENTS
STILL LIVE IN COMMUNITIES THAT
EXCEED FEDERAL HEALTH
PROTECTIVE STANDARD. EXPOSURE
TO DIESEL PARTICULATE IS TOO
HIGH ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES
NEAR FREIGHT FACILITIES AT THE
PORT RASHGUARDS DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS AND CLOSE TO FREEWAY.
GRAPHIC SHOWS SOME OF THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE SINCE
EIGHTEEN THIRTY TWO WEST SIDE
AND SINCE WE STARTED DISCUSSING
PLAN PROCESS. IN TWO THOUSAND
WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN REDUCING EMISSIONS
PER CAPITA THIRTY EIGHTY P. AND
IN TOTAL WHILE THE ECONOMY AND
POPULATION CONTINUE TO GROW.
THE PIE CHART SHOWS WHICH
SECTORS CONTRIBUTE THE MOST TO
OUR GHG EMISSIONS IN THE AB
THIRTY TWO GHG INVENTORY. SB
THAT 24% IS INDUSTRIAL AND
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF THAT
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR IS RELATED TO
OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION AND
REFINING. WHICH PUTS THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AT ABOUT
50% OF THE STATE'S EMISSIONS.
SO FOCUSING ON THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS
CRITICAL. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA'S GHG EMISSIONS WERE
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTEEN MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CO TWO
EQUIVALENT. TRANSPORTATION IS
THE LARGEST ANTHROPOGENIC
SOURCE OF CALIFORNIA GHG
EMISSIONS. THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IS ALSO THE DOMINANT
SOURCE OF NITROGEN OXIDES ARE
NOT EMISSIONS THAT CONTRIBUTE
TO OZONE AND OUR PARTICULAR AIR
QUALITY PROBLEMS AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. DOMINATED BY THE HEAVY
TRANSPORTATION SEGMENT
INCLUDING HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
BUSES READY TO QUIT MEANT
LOCOMOTIVES. MARINE VESSEL. AND
OTHER OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT
ACCOUNTING FOR OVER 60% OF THE
STATE'S NOT COMMISSION. IN
ADDITION DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER MAKES UP 30% OF ALL
PARTICULATE MATTER EMISSIONS
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
UNLIKE THE OTHER PARTICULATE
MATTER INCLUDED IN THE PIE
GRAPHS DIESEL PM IS NOT A
CRITERIA POLLUTANT BUT IT'S A
TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS. SO
LET'S PIVOT TO THE AB THIRTY
TWO STEPPING PLAN AND THE WORK
THAT LIES AHEAD. THE THIRTY
PLANT ARE ACTIONABLE PLANS TO
LAY OUT COST EFFECTIVE AND
TECHNOLOGY FEASIBLE
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE PATH
TO ENSURE THAT WE MEET THESE
GHG REDUCTION TARGET. EACH
CUTTING PLAN HAS INCLUDED A
SUITE OF POLICIES AND HAVE
NEVER RELIED ON JUST ONE
APPROACH TO REDUCING EMISSIONS.
THEY EACH HAVE A COMBINATION OF
INCENTIVES REGULATIONS AND
CARBON PRICING MECHANISMS.
IMPORTANTLY THE PLAN IS ECONOMY
WIDE AND SPANS MANY YEARS I
THOUGHT IT COULD NOT GO INTO
THE DESIGN DETAILS OF ANY
PARTICULAR PROGRAM A REGULATION
NORDIC AT THE PLANT OR CREATE
NEW STATUTES AND REGULATIONS.
THE FIRST STEPPING PLAN WAS
RELEASED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
SUBSEQUENT UPDATES HAVE BEEN
RELEASED AT LEAST ONCE EVERY
FIVE YEARS. EVERY PREVIOUS
SCOPING PLAN WAS DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE GHG AND AIR POLLUTION
EMISSIONS REDUCTION. WE ARE
REQUIRED TO IN A- MINIMIZE
LEAKAGE WHICH IS WHEN THE
PRODUCTION OF GOODS AND JOBS
LEAVES THE STATE. SO IT LOOKS
LIKE WE REDUCED EMISSIONS BUT
IN FACT THEY MERELY REMOVED
WERE MOVED OUT OF OUR INVENTORY
THAT WE NEED TO BE CAREFULLY
ANALYZING LEAKAGE. FINALLY AB
THIRTY TWO REQUIRES US TO
FACILITATE SUBNATIONAL AND
NATIONAL COLLABORATION. AND
THAT POLICIES BECAUSE DEFECTIVE
AND FLEXIBLE WITH COMPLIANCE.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A GLOBAL
ISSUE AND WITHOUT ACTION FROM
LIKE MINDED PARTNERS WE WILL
STILL FACE THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. OR GLOBAL
POLLUTANTS SUCH AS GREENHOUSE
GASES. A REDUCTION ANYWHERE IS
A BENEFIT EVERYWHERE. OUR GOAL
HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO DEVELOP
SCALABLE AND EXPORTABLE
PROGRAMS THAT OTHER
JURISDICTIONS CAN USE TO
IMPLEMENT AND REDUCE EMISSIONS
WITHIN THEIR BORDERS. THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE SCRAPPING
PLAN WILL AFFECT PROGRESS TO
ACHIEVING OUR TWENTY THIRTY
TARGET AND IT WILL IT WILL
EVALUATE HOW TO PUT OURSELVES
ON A PATH THAT ULTIMATELY
ACHIEVES CARBON NEUTRALITY.
ONYX GRAPHICS YOU CAN SEE THE
TWENTY THIRTY TARGET OF 40%
BELOW NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. IF WE ACHIEVE
THAT TARGET AND MAINTAIN THAT
RATE OF REDUCTION WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE 80% BELOW
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY
TWENTY FORTY. THAT PUTS US IN A
GOOD POSITION TO ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. TWENTY THIRTY IS A
MILESTONE ON THE WAY TO
ACHIEVING CARBON NEUTRALITY.
THE LEVEL OF TRANCE FORMATION
REQUIRED TO HIT CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY MIDCENTURY MEANS
THAT WE SHOULD PRIORITIZE
ACTIONS IN TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WILL NOT RESULT IN STRANDED
ASSETS AFTER TWENTY THIRTY. AND
THAT WE NEED TO BE THINKING
ABOUT LONGER POLICY SIGNAL. TO
ATTRACT PRIVATE CAPITAL FOR
ACTION AND INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY. I LAUGHED AT THE
PLAN ADOPTED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LAID OUT A PATH TO
ACHIEVE THE TWENTY THIRTY
TARGET A 40% BELOW NINETEEN
NINETY. BUT INCLUDE ACTION ON
EVERY SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY AND
IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR CLEAN
ENERGY AND TECHNOLOGY.
ALTERNATIVE MOBILITY OPTIONS.
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AND
SLASHING SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANT. IMPORTANTLY IT
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED TO
LEVERAGE OUR EXISTING AIR
QUALITY PROGRAMS TO ACHIEVE OUR
GHG TARGETS AND CONTINUE TO
DRIVE DOWN HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTION IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. IMPORTANTLY KEEP
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD AND CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM. HAVE DOUBLED IN
STRINGENCY AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS YEAR TO REFLECT A STEEPER
RATE REDUCTIONS NEEDED TO
ACHIEVE THE TWENTY THIRTY
PACKAGE. SO THE HISTORICAL
PERFORMANCE OF THESE PROGRAMS
DOES NOT NECESSARILY REFLECT
THE IMPACT THESE PROGRAMS WILL
HAVE HUNDRED INCREASED DJINDJIC
THE ESTABLISHED FOR THE SECOND.
MINISTRATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
AND STATE AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY TO SEND
STEADY POLICY SIGNALS THAT WE
WANT TO REDUCE GHGS AND ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE. WE ARE NOW IN
THE SECOND DECADE OF TACKLING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE ARE
SEEING OUTCOMES THAT WE HAD
HOPED FOR. WE KNOW CLIMATE
ACTION COULD CREATE AND KEEP
HIRING JOBS SUCH AS IN OUR
CLEAN TECH SECTORS. WE HAVE
SEEN SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT AND
INCREASED INVESTOR INTEREST IN
CLEAN ENERGY AND CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY. FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE
AT LEAST TWO REFINERIES
DEVASTATED THEY WILL STOP
PRODUCING CONVENTIONAL DIESEL
AND INSTEAD PRODUCE RENEWABLE
DIESEL. WHICH PRODUCES 30% LESS
DIESEL PM. THEY CANCER CAUSING
POLLUTANTS THAT CONCENTRATES
NEAR FREEWAYS. BENEFITING
HEAVILY BURDENED COMMUNITIES
WHICH ARE OFTEN ADJACENT. SO I
WANT TO DIGRESS FOR A MOMENT
AND TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANT
ROLE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
THIS WORK. MANY FACILITIES WE
NEED TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS
SUCH AS RENEWABLE ENERGY
FACILITIES IS NEARING MISSION
VEHICLE CHARGING STATIONS.
CONVERSIONS OF REFINERY CLEANER
FUEL THAT THEY MENTION.
COMPOSTING FACILITIES WHICH ARE
ESSENTIAL TO REDUCING EMISSIONS
FOR ORGANIC WASTE. ARE ALL
SUBJECT TO LOCAL PERMITTING AND
SITING REQUIREMENTS. IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TAKE THE URGENCY OF
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE INTO
ACCOUNT AS THEY ARE REVIEWING
THESE LAND USE ISSUES.
ACHIEVING SUCCESS ON CLIMATE
CHANGE MEANS THAT WE NEED TO
REMOVE OBSTACLES FOR THE CLEAN
TRANSITION OF EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. OR BUILD OUT OF
NEW CLEAN ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
AND RECOGNIZE THE EXECUTION OF
THE SCOPING PLAN. REALLY DOES
RELY ON A STORY AT BOTH THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL. WE
KICKED OFF THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
SCOPING PLAN WITH A SERIES OF
WORKSHOPS IN JUNE. AND THE PLAN
WILL BE CONSIDERED BY THE BOARD
IN LATE TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IT
DOES DIFFER FROM THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN STEPPING PLAN IN
CONTENT AND PURPOSE. ANY THIRTY
TARGETED IN STATUTE AND WE MUST
REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS BY AT
LEAST 40% FROM NINETEEN NINETY
LEVELS BY TWENTY THIRTY BY LAW.
BUT WE WILL BE ASSESSING
PROGRESS TOWARDS ACHIEVING THAT
TARGET. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT TWENTY
THIRTY IS A MILE DOWN ON WHERE
RECENT GIANT SAYS WE NEED TO BE
BY MID CENTURY. SO WE CAN'T
WAIT UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY ONE TO
START PLANNING FOR TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. BECAUSE THE LEVEL OF
TRANSFORMATION NEEDED ACROSS
THE ECONOMY IS UNPRECEDENTED SO
WE NEED TO START PLANNING FOR
THAT NOW. WHICH MEANS LOOKING
FOR ACTION TO DEPLOY CLEAN
ENERGY AND CLEAN TECH HIT THE
TWENTY THIRTY TARGET AND PUT US
ON THE PATH TO THE TWENTY FOUR
FORTY FIVE TARGET. CAN'T THE
COUPLE THE TWO. IT LOOKS OUT
OVER TWENTY YEARS THIS COPING
PLAN WILL HAVE THE LONGEST
PLANNING HORIZON OF ANY
PREVIOUS VERSION. BUT AS NOTED
EARLIER WE ARE ALSO WE VALUE IT
IN A PATH TO ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE HER DIRECTION FROM
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. MEANS THAT WE
WILL PLACE A LARGER FOCUS ON
OUTCOMES WE NEED TO ACHIEVE BY
THAT TIME. IN IDENTIFYING
OUTCOME THE MODELING WILL
PROVIDE PASSED FOR CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY AND ENERGY
DEPLOYMENT. FOR EXAMPLE THE
RATE OF SALES OF LIGHT DUTY
ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR ELECTRIC
APPLIANCES. METRICS IN ADDITION
TO THE ANNUAL GHG INVENTORY CAN
HELP US TRACK PROGRESS MOVING
FORWARD. IMPORTANTLY THESE
OUTCOMES MUST BE CONSIDERED
BOTH IN THE CONTEXT OF
ACHIEVING NEAR TERM AIR QUALITY
BENEFITS AND LONGER TERM
GREENHOUSE GAS BENEFITS. THE
COPING PLAN UPDATE WILL ALSO
REQUIRE US TO REDEFINE OUR
SCOPE OF SOURCES AND THINK IN
THE FRAMEWORK OF CARBON
NEUTRALITY. THAT PROTECTS
CONFIDENTIALITY IS ACHIEVED
REMISSION SOURCES EQUAL THANK.
UP UNTIL NOW EVERY SCOPING PLAN
AS MENTIONED EARLIER HAS
FOCUSED ON REDUCING EMISSIONS
FROM THE SOURCES DEFINED IN AB
THIRTY TWO INVENTORY WHICH
FOCUSES ON FOSSIL ENERGY AND
INDUSTRIAL FORCES. AND WE DO
HAVE A SEPARATE INVENTORY FOR
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS. BUT
AS WE SHIFTED A FRAMEWORK OF
CARBON NEUTRALITY WE WILL
EXPAND THE SCOPE TO INCLUDE ALL
SOURCES WHICH MEANS THE
EMISSIONS FROM NATURAL THE
WORKING LAND AT ALL THINK.
WHICH CAN BE NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS CARBON CAPTURE
AND SEQUESTRATION FOR LARGE
EMITTERS DIRECT AIR CAPTURE AND
PERMANENT STORAGE OF CO TWO
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE. THE
PATHWAY TO CARBON NEUTRALITY
STUDY DEVELOPED FOR CARP BY
ENERGY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ECONOMICS EXAMINES THREE BROAD
PATHWAYS. TO ACHIEVING CARBON
NEUTRALITY. EACH PATHWAY
CHARTED THE SAME PATH 280% OF
REDUCTIONS THEN CHARTED
DIFFERENT PATHWAYS AFTER. ONE
SCENARIO MADE USE OF EXPANDED
CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL
STRATEGIES ANOTHER ACHIEVED
ZERO FOSSIL FUEL EMISSIONS BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE AND THE THIRD
SCENARIO WOULD HAVE BEEN A
BLENDING OF THE TWO. WATER ZERO
CARBON ENERGY SCENARIO ACHIEVED
IN 92% REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE
GASES BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE. THE
IDEAL BALANCE OF REDUCTIONS
PURSUE COVERING NOUVEAU REMOVAL
STRATEGIES IS NOT YET NOW.
ENTER THIS PROCESS WITH AN OPEN
MIND ON EVALUATING STRATEGIES.
BUT AS THE SCALE OF THE CRISIS
BECOMES CLEARER IT IS BECOMING
VERY APPARENT THAT WE NEEDED
NOT ONLY THINK ABOUT REDUCING
EMISSIONS BUT ALSO WAYS THAT WE
CAN ACTIVELY REMOVE GREENHOUSE
GASES FROM THE ATMOSPHERE.
THERE WILL BE SOME CHANGES TO
THE DATA AND METRICS FOR THE
SCOPING PLAN. AS REQUIRED UNDER
EIGHTY ONE NINETY SEVEN WE WILL
BE INCLUDING THE COST PER TON
OF POLICY. THE SOCIAL COST OF
CARBON. AN ESTIMATED AIR
QUALITY BENEFITS. WE DO BELIEVE
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION WILL
HAVE UPDATED SOCIAL COST OF
CARBON VALUES THAT ARE
PROJECTED TO BE HIGHER THAN THE
OBAMA ERA VALUES THAT WE USED
IN THE LAST PLAN THAT WE WILL
INCORPORATE THAT INTO OUR WORK.
AND I WORK WITH THE C. E. C.
AND B. PC FOR THE F. B. ONE
HUNDRED REPORT. CARD INCLUDED
AN UPDATED APPROACH TO THE
HEALTH ANALYSIS. WE WILL BUILD
OFF WHAT WE DID IN ALASKA BEEN
PLAN AND THE SB ONE HUNDRED
REPORT TO INCLUDE NEW HEALTH
AND POINTS AND INCLUDE THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS NEW AND POINTS. AND
WILL BE HAVING WORKSHOPS ON
THAT LATER THIS YEAR. WE WILL
DO A PUBLIC HEALTH ANALYSIS.
AND OF COURSE WE WILL DO IS HE
QUITE ANALYSIS. UNDER LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS WE HAD TO
OFFICIALLY STATE THE START OF
THE SECRET ADMINISTRATIVE
RECORD AND WE CHOSE MID JANUARY
AS POSTED TO OUR WEBSITE. WHICH
IS WHEN WE GOT STARTED- WORKING
ON CONVENING KEY ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ADVISORY COMMITTEE. AND
NOTIFYING OUR LEGAL OFFICE THAT
WE WOULD NEED- CONTRACTOR HELP
YOU TO SEE WHAT WORK. IN
CLOSING AND THEY MENTIONED AB
THIRTY TWO REQUIRES THAT THE
CRAPPY PLAN BE UPDATED EVERY
FIVE YEARS SO WE WILL NEED TO
BRING THE PLAN BEFORE THE
CARDBOARD FOR ADOPTION BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY Q. THE
TIMELINE HERE DEPICTS MAJOR
MILESTONES WERE PLANNING TO
MEET THAT- DEADLINE. THERE WILL
BE AMPLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENGAGE THROUGH
UPCOMING WORKSHOPS. THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEETINGS AND FOR
COMMUNITY MEETINGS THAT WILL
OCCUR- IN THE FALL AND ON GOING
THROUGH NEXT YEAR. AT THE WHITE
SHOWS THAT WE PLAN TO READ
RELEASED THE DRAFT CAPPING
PLAN- AND PRESENT TO THE BOARD
AND SPRING- AND THEY'LL BE
ADDITIONAL ENGAGEMENT BETWEEN
THE DRAFT AND THE FINAL LATER
IN THE YEAR. WELL I JUST
DETAILS THE REPORTING AND
OVERSIGHT THAT EXIST FOR CARDS
PROGRAM IN THE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING OUR ANNUAL UPDATES TO
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS INVENTORY
AND MANDATORY REPORTING. STATUS
UPDATES ETCETERA. AND I WILL BE
PROVIDING THIS TO THE COMMITTEE.
HOWEVER OUTSIDE OF OFFICIAL
REPORTS AND OUR ROBUST PUBLIC
PROCESS I WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH EACH
OF YOU IN THE COMING YEARS AS
WE STRIVE TO ACHIEVE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS.
AND TO REDUCE THE BURDEN OF AIR
POLLUTION ON ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE PARTICULARLY THOSE MOST
IMPACTED. AS WAS DISCUSSED AT
THE OUTSET OF THE HEARING WE
CANNOT UNDERSTATE HOW
SIGNIFICANT THE CHALLENGES
AHEAD ARE. ACHIEVING CARBON
NEUTRALITY REQUIRES A NEARLY
COMPLETE TRANSFORMATION OF
CALIFORNIA FROM A STATE STILL
HEAVILY DEPENDENT ON FOSSIL
FUELS. WE DO EVERYTHING FROM
GET TO WORK THE LIGHTER HOME.
IT WAS STATE WHERE ALMOST
EVERYTHNG WE CAN DO IF POWERED
BY RENEWABLE ENERGY. WE NEED A
MASSIVE EXPANSION OF CLEAN
PUBLIC TRANSIT WE NEED CHANGES
IN HOW WE DESIGN OUR BUILT
ENVIRONMENT. WE NEED COULD UNDO
POLICIES AND INCENTIVES THAT
FAVOUR SPRAWL. WILL NEED TO
EXPAND OUR REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS. COORDINATE WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND
COLLABORATE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ACHIEVE NATIONAL
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS THAT BUILD ON
OUR PIONEERING WORK HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WITH THE NEW
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO NOT ONLY
EXPORT. OUR POLICIES NATIONALLY
BUT ALSO WORK TO ACHIEVE
REDUCTIONS PROTECTORS WE
CURRENTLY CAN'T REGULATE SUCH
AS AVIATION AND THE RAIL SECTOR.
I THANK GOD THE IPCC JUST
RELEASED A STUDY SHOWING THAT
RECENT CHANGES IN OUR CLIMATE-
WIDESPREAD RAPID AND
INTENSIFYING. ACHIEVING NET
ZERO IF NECESSARY. YET THIS IS
AN ALL HANDS ON DECK MOMENT
THAT REQUIRES OLD COMMITTED
LEADERSHIP. THE TIME FOR
QUIBBLING OVER DEFINITELY
MANISHA OR AGONIZING OVER
DEMAND IN A SPENDING CHANGES AS
LONG PASSED. BUT AFTER THAT
FIRE NO ONE WORRIES THAT THERE
ARE TOO MANY FIRE TRUCKS. ALL
THAT MATTERS IS PUTTING OUT THE
FIRE. IT'S TIME FOR US TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THE CLIMATE
CRISIS THE SAME WAY AND TO
FOCUS ON BOTH PLANS AND ACTION
AT ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
THE TASK IS DAUNTING BUT I HAVE
FAITH WITH THE HEART IN THE
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION OF OUR
STAFF WITH THE AMBITION OF
GREEN ENTREPRENEURS AND THE
VISION OF THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE WE CAN MEET THE
CHALLENGE AND CREATE A
HEALTHIER AND MORE EQUITABLE
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO ANSWERING
YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE CHAIR RANDOLPH I LIKE.
TO SEE IF- ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WOULD LIKE TO START
WITH QUESTIONS FOR THE CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THE MANAGER
THAT WAS A FANTASTIC
PRESENTATION ON A THANK YOU FOR
THAT- BECAUSE YOU ARE BEING-
VERY REAL- IN YOUR IN YOUR
ANALYSIS SO- AGAIN WANNA I
DON'T WANT TO THANK YOU- IT
JUST THAT THE QUESTION THAT
REALLY THAT I HAVE IS KNOWING
WHERE WE'RE AT TODAY EVEN WITH
THE RECENT- IPCC REPORT- AND
HOW DIRE SITUATION IS. CAN YOU
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHETHER
CURRENT STATE POLICY. NOT A
WEATHER WE'VE MAXIMIZED.
EFFICIENCY WITH MAXIMIZED
DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING
COLLECTED WHETHER WE'VE
MAXIMIZE THE THAT THE POLICIES
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE TODAY
HAVE WE USED THOSE POLICIES IN
THOSE DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
TO. THE GREATEST EXTENT. WE
HAVE A LOT MORE TO DO- I THINK
IT MET WE HAVE BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE IN- IN REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES UP TO THIS
POINT- AND WE HAVE ACHIEVED
SOME SUCCESSES BUT THE REALITY
IS IT'S NOT ENOUGH AND IT'S NOT
FAST ENOUGH- AS I MENTIONED
THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT
IMPLEMENTATION- STRATEGIES THAT
WE NEED TO LEAN INTO- AND WE
NEED TO DEPLOY ALL OF THE-
INCENTIVES THAT. THE REGULAR
START REGULATORY STAT- AND THE
MARKET MECHANISMS THAT WE CAN
TO GET WHERE WE NEED TO GO- I
THANK YOU. YOU KNOW I'LL GIVE A
SMALL EXAMPLE- ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES AROUND- INCENTIVE
PROGRAM IS SORT OF THIS KIND OF
THE STOP AND START NATURE OF
THEM YOU KNOW WE'LL HAVE
FUNDING AND THEN IT'LL RUN OUT
AND THEN WE'LL GET MORE
SPENDING OR- WILL RECONSTRUCT
THE PROGRAM. AND I THINK IT'S
IT CAN BE CHALLENGING- AND SO-
THAT'S JUST ONE SMALL EXAMPLE
OF. AREAS WHERE WE CAN REALLY
LEAN AND- ANOTHER EXAMPLE AS I
MENTIONED WAS- THINKING ABOUT
THE ROLE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
AND- THEIR STRATEGIES AROUND.
LAND USE AND REDUCING VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED AND INCITING-
RENEWABLE ENERGY FACILITIES
THINGS LIKE THAT SO WE REALLY
ALL NEED TO BE WORKING TOGETHER
AT THE STATE- AS HARD AND AS
FAST AS WE POSSIBLY CAN. WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT-
AND I GUESS PART OF THIS AND
YOU BROUGHT UP VEHICLES MOUNT
THE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
WHICH IS A SORE SUBJECT FOR
AREAS LIKE MINE IN THE INLAND
BUILDING A MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OR HOUSING THAT'S MORE
AFFORDABLE THAN IT IS IN. IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND LA AND YET
WE'VE GOT POLICIES LIKE V. M.
T. THAT HAVE SAID ALWAYS WE'RE
NOT GONNA WE'RE NOT GONNA LIE
TO BE ABLE TO BUILD ANYMORE
ROAD SO THERE'S MORE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES I WANT TO
GET GO DOWN THAT ROAD. THE
REASON PART OF THE REASON I'M
ASKING THIS QUESTION IS THAT I
THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE SPENDING
MONEY WITH THEM WITHIN THE G.
G. R. F. FUND- AND I CAN TELL
YOU. A FOR ME A FEW YEARS AGO I
WE SPENT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE ON WATER- WHICH
BY THE WAY IS. SUPER NEEDED WE
KNOW NOW WE'RE IN A IN A
DROUGHT. AND YET I THOUGHT THAT
THE REASON THAT WE USED TO THE
G. R. F. DOLLARS WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE USED TOWARD REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
SO. IT SEEMS AS THOUGH ON ONE
SIDE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
POLICIES. THAT THAT WERE SAYING
THAT WERE TALK ABOUT THIS
OVERALL. PLAN THAT WE'VE GOT TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AT THE WORLD IS. AS FUN AS THIS
ACCESS TO THREAT BEFORE A- BUT
TO BE VERY REAL- OUR POLICIES
AND OUR EXPENDITURES. DON'T
ALIGN WITH THAT AND SO AGAIN I
WANT TO GO BACK TO THANKING YOU
FOR. YOUR PRESENTATION BECAUSE
I THINK YOU MADE THAT YOU MADE
THAT VERY CLEAR IN YOUR
COMMENTS- BY THE WAY ARE. ARE
VERY DIPLOMATIC IN RESPONSE
VERY DIPLOMATIC AS WELL SO
THANK YOU WHAT. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SET OF EYES
CHAU BAKER. THANK YOU I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AND THAT SUPER INFORMATIVE
PRESENTATION REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT. I'M JUST SORT OF WHAT I
GUESS SIR ONE COMMENT AND WHEN
ONE QUESTION YOU YOU DID
MENTION CAP AND TRADE AND KNOW
THAT THAT DOES PLAN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN ME THE TWENTY THIRTY
TARGETS AND I'VE APPROVAL
EXPRESSED MY- INTEREST BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED A STRONG. MARKET A
SIGNAL THERE- SO IF YOU ANY ANY
ANY COMMENTS ON THAT- BUT- THE
IMMEDIATE QUESTION IS. HAVE YOU
RUN A BUSINESS YOU KNOW WE PUT
TOGETHER FINANCIAL TARGETS WE
USUALLY DON'T IF I SET UP
ACTIONS WE BELIEVE CAN OVER
ACHIEVE THE TARGETS KNOWING
THAT EVERYTHING IS NOT GOING TO
GO ACCORDING TO PLAN. SO YOU
WANT TO KNOW THAT WE CAN HIT
THE TARGET WITH CONSERVATIVES
OPTIONS. I'M AND THERE FOR HAVE
A GOOD CHANCE EXCEEDING THE
TARGETS ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
A CLIMATE PLAN THIS WAY IN THE
SCOPING PLAN AND- PRINTED PLANT.
TO GET A PLANTS WILL
CONSERVATIVELY HIT THE TARGETS
THAT WILL POTENTIALLY
OVERACHIEVE. IF THINGS GO WELL
OR WE RISK THAT IF ANY OF THESE
POLICIES DON'T GO AS PREDICTED
THAT WE WILL MISS OUR- OUR
TARGETS. NAY ALLEN. I GUESS I
WOULD SAY A COUPLE THINGS- DEAN
THE PURPOSE OF THE SCOPING PLAN
IS. REALLY TO KIND OF LAY OUT
THAT STRATEGY AND LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT- TIME FRAMES LIKE.
LOOKING AND TO TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE FOR CARBON NEUTRALITY AS
WELL AS TWENTY FORTY FIVE. WILL
REALLY GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO THINK ABOUT. WAYS THAT WE
CAN MOVE FASTER IN IN DIFFERENT
AREAS- AND FULLY ANALYZING HOW
MUCH. EACH OF OUR PROGRAMS WE
ANTICIPATE TO ACHIEVE THE
REDUCTIONS THAT WE NEED- WE
WERE FORTUNATE WE REACHED OUR
TWENTY TWENTY GOALS A SENIOR
THAN WE THOUGHT- SO I THINK WE
HAVE- EFFECTIVELY LAID OUT
STRATEGIES THAT HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO- CAN MOVE. MORE
QUICKLY- AND THAT'LL BE
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL BE-
ANALYZING IN THE SKIPPING
PLANET. THANK YOU. I DON'T
SKINNER I'M CHAIR AND OFF YOU
MENTIONED THAT THE- SCENARIO
THE- REPORT THAT YOU RECEIVED
THE SCENARIOS THAT GAVE THE SAY
IT WELL IN FACT HAD THE SAME
MEASURES FOR REACHING 80% BUT
THEN THE 20% WERE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS- AND IT I THINK IF I
HEARD IT RIGHT BUT I MAY HAVE
NOT HEARD CORRECTLY THE ONLY
ONE OF THE THREE OPTIONS WAS A
MORE FOCUSED ON THE CAPTURING
AND SEQUESTERING OF CARBON. IS
THAT ACCURATE. RIGHT RIGHT SO
ONE LEANED INTO AND THAT HE
NEEDED TO THAT OF THE STRATEGY
I'M ALONE I'M JUST DOUBLE
CHECKING MY NOTES I WANT TO
MAKE SURE I'M NOT GIVING YOU
THEIR- INFORMATION- AND THEN
THE- AT ONES THAT ARE YELLOW.
AT LEANED HEAVILY INTO THAT
REMOVAL STRATEGIES WHILE THE
OTHER SCENARIO- LEANED INTO AT
JERRY WE MISSION SO OKAY OKAY
THING MORE ON REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND THEN THE THIRD
SCENARIO DID A COMBINATION OF
COMBO OKAY. SO OF THE 80% HOW
MUCH WAS REMOVAL FACTORED IN IN
JUST GETTING TO THE 80% WAS IT.
OR WAS IT PRIMARILY ARMS
REDUCTION IT WAS PRIMARILY IN
THIS INTRODUCTION OKAY- AND
THERE ARE THESE THE ONLY
SCENARIOS THE BOARD IS GOING TO
LOOK AT THE REASON I RAISE IT-
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW. OKAY GO
AHEAD. YEAH I THOUGHT SORRY TO
INTERRUPT BUT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU KNOW THE DANCE
THAT WAS THE CARBON NEUTRALITY
STUDY THAT WAS DONE BY E
THREE- AND WE WILL BE LOOKING
AT A MUCH BROADER SUITE OF
POSSIBLE SCENARIOS. IN THE
SCOPING PLAN OKAY- AND THE
REASON I REASON AND I DON'T I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY I. I DO WANT TO
ASK QUESTIONS AND HAVE THE
ANSWERS BUT I'LL AND I DON'T
WANT TO JUST BE SETTING UP
QUESTIONS FOR LEADING LEADING
YOU TO I'M- GOING TO EXPRESS
THE OPINION THAT I THINK THAT.
WE- THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
REMOVAL EVEN IN OUR 80% AND
THAT AND I DON'T MEAN I IN NO
WAY WANT TO DIMINISH. THE
EMISSIONS REDUCTION SO I AM NOT
ADVOCATING THAT WE MOVE AWAY
FROM THAT EMPHASIS I'M ONLY
ALSO ADVOCATING. THAT WE AT WE
CONCURRENTLY PUT AS MUCH
EMPHASIS ON THE REMOVAL GIVEN
WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW.
ABSOLUTELY I COMPLETELY AGREE I
MEAN I THINK ONE OF THE KEY
STRATEGIES FOR THIS ROUND OF
THE SCOPING PLAN IS REALLY- IT
DIVING INTO WHAT ARE THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND NATURALLY
WORKING LAND AND THEN WHAT OUR
TECHNOLOGICAL OPPORTUNITIES-
BUT BY NO MEANS ARE WE GOING TO
I'M NOT ALSO CONSIDER- THE
EMISSIONS REDUCTION SO. I THINK
WE ARE IN COMPLETE ALIGNMENT ON
AND REALLY MAKE REALLY
UNDERSTANDING WAYS THAT WE CAN
REMOVE CARBON- AS WE TRY TO YOU
KNOW. ADDRESS THAT CRISIS.
THANK YOU. FOLLOWING CENTER
SCANNERS- QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE IMPORTANCE OF CARBON
REMOVAL- TECHNOLOGIES I- I'M
REFERRING CHAIR AROUND OFF- TO.
A COPY OF THE- THE PATHWAYS
STUDY THAT I BELIEVE YOU'RE
REFERRING TO THAT THE- WE'RE
EXPLORING THAT THE THREE-
POTENTIAL. BROAD PATHWAYS IN
ACHIEVING CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE ARM. AND IN
THE EXECUTIVE SUMMARY OF THE R.
PATHWAY STUDY- IT TALKS ABOUT
HOW. WHILE THE- THIS IS
ANDERSON ERROR RESULTS IN THE
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY UNDER THE
HIGH. CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL
SCENARIO THAT- THAT THIS
SCENARIO RELIES ON QUOTE
RELATIVELY UNTESTED CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL STRATEGIES-
WHICH ARE NOT WIDELY
COMMERCIALIZED. COULD YOU-
ASCHE SHARE YOUR OPINION IN
TERMS OF. YOU KNOW WHAT IS.
THE- WHAT WHAT WHERE WE ADD IN
TERMS OF THE- THE- THE
RELIABILITY AND THE- THE TESTED
THE NATURE OF THE OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES I MEAN I MY
QUESTION IS REALLY TRYING TO
GET A GET OUT WHETHER WE ARE
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PUT OUR EGGS IN THE
BASKET OF REAL TECHNOLOGY THAT
ACHIEVE REAL. REDUCTIONS.
WHETHER IN- CAPTURING CARBON
BEFORE RELEASED OR WHETHER AND
REMOVING. CARBON THROUGH THE
SINKS CAN CAN YOU GIVE US. A
SENSE OF- SOME OF THE STATE OF
THE CARBON- REMOVAL A
TECHNOLOGY AS IT CURRENTLY
STANDS. YES ABSOLUTELY- WE
RECENTLY HAD A- WORKSHOP ON
THIS TOPIC WHERE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS SOME OF
THE KEY POLICY ISSUES AROUND-
CARBON CAPTURE AND REMOVAL AND
THEN ALSO HAD. SOME
PRESENTATIONS ABOUT DIFFERENT-
PROJECTS THAT EXIST- AND I
GUESS I WOULD SORT OF JAM IT UP
BY SAYING IT'S EARLY DAYS-
THERE ARE AND THERE ARE
STRATEGIES THAT ARE- THAT HAVE
BEEN DEPLOYED- BUT THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF. QUESTIONS ABOUT
AND F WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOW EXACTLY
AT THESE PROJECTS TO BE
DEPLOYED WHAT TYPES OF- WHAT
THE DIFFERENT. OPTIONS ARE AND
WHAT SOME OF THE CONCERNS ARE
I'M THINKING ABOUT- AIR QUALITY
ISSUES ARE THINKING ABOUT-
PERMANENCY AS RUDE AS IT
RELATES TO SEE FRUSTRATION AND
NEITHER ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
KEY THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
DISCUSSED- AS PART OF THE
SCOPING PLAN PROCESS- SO THAT
WE CAN UNDERSTAND- HOW WE
CHARACTERIZE IT AND HOW WE
THINK ABOUT IT AND IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE SUITE OF
STRATEGIES- AS I'VE AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER AND I SAY ALL
THE TIME- THIS IS REALLY THIS
IS NOT AN EITHER OR KIND OF.
MOMENT DIFFER THEY LET'S SEE
BUT- HE WAS MUCH AS WE CAN AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING TO BE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE- AND SO
THAT'S A LOT OF WHAT THE.
WORKING THE SKIPPING PLAN IS
GOING TO BE ABOUT. YES I AND I
CERTAINLY. YOUR CALL FOR BOLD
ACTION WERE. AND THIS IS NOT A
TIME TO BE QUIBBLING ABOUT TO.
ABOUT YOU KNOW- SMALL
DIFFERENCES- IN THAT THAT WE
MAY HAVE FIGHT I HEAR THERE BUT
I THINK THE POINT THAT TO ALL
OF US- YOU KNOW WANT TO MAKE
AT. WHAT WHAT WANT TO GET ADDED
WE IS. YOU KNOW WE SEE WE SEE
THE- THE END OF THE GRASS THAT
YOU PRESENTED- AND YEAH WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ACHIEVING. IN A REAL PROGRESS
TOWARD- GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS AS WELL AS- REAL
PROGRESS TOWARD ACHIEVING
CARBON NEUTRALITY WORLD THE
SCIENTISTS ALL AROUND THE
WORLD- THAT- YOU KNOW HAVE
CLEARLY STATED THAT WE NEED TO.
OUR REACH- YOU KNOW IF NOT BY
MID CENTURY- MUCH MUCH SOONER
AS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO
GOING GOING BACK TO THAT THAT
THE BIGGER POINT YOU KNOW THE
ONE OF YOUR- CHARTS WAS.HAD
THAT THAT MAPPED OUT- THE R. R.
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS TOWARD
OUR TWENTY THIRTY GOAL I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE. YOU KNOW
HOW YOU ARE. YOU KNOW FOCUSED
ON THE IMMEDIATE STATUTORY GOAL
OF S. SB THIRTY TWO- THE 40%
REDUCTION OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS COMPARED TO NINETEEN
NINETY LEVELS BY TWENTY THIRTY.
ARE WE ON TRACK TO ACHIEVE- THE
TWENTY THIRTY GO UNDER SB
THIRTY TWO- YES I BELIEVE WE
ARE- I MEAN. HELPING PLAN IS
GOING TO BE AFFECTING THAT- BUT
WE HAVE BEEN ACHIEVING
REDUCTIONS WE'VE ACHIEVED
REDUCTIONS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE
AND IMPORTANTLY OUR PROGRAMS
ARE GETTING MORE STRINGENT- YOU
KNOW STARTING THIS YEAR WE HAD.
WE HAD- MODIFICATION TO THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM TO MAKE IT
MORE STRINGENT- WE ALSO HAVE
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
WHICH WE ARE IMPLEMENTING IN
THE TRANSPORTATION- AS HEARING
MISSION SPACE THAT WE HAVE-
REGULATORY WORK AROUND THAT.
AND ALL OF THOSE MORE
STRINGENT- STRATEGIES- I THINK
WE'LL SHOW AS WE GOT TO
DISCUSSING PLAN PROCESS THAT WE
CAN MAKE IT TO OUR TWENTY
THIRTY CALL. AND AND I AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY YOUR-
DIRECTION AND GUIDANCE IS GOING
TO BE SO IMPORTANT IN THIS
WORK- THINKING ABOUT HOW THE
LEGISLATURE VIEWS- THE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES THE
INCENTIVES- AND HOW ALL THAT
PLAYS TOGETHER. IT'S GOING TO
BE REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU ARE. ON THE POINT OF
YOU KNOW V. D. THE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS VERSES THE- RELIANCE
ON. CARBON CAPTURE AND
SEQUESTRATION TECHNOLOGIES AS
WELL AS NATURAL- SOLUTIONS- IF
EFFORT FIRST FALL EVERITT WHICH
WHICH YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THAT-
THAT THERE ARE CO BENEFITS TO
THE EMPHASIS ON THE DIRECT
EMISSION REDUCTIONS NAMELY THE
ODD AND NOT JUST IT SHAVING THE
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOALS NOT
JUST IN ITS EVEN THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GOALS BUT ALSO
THE- ACHIEVING THE AIR
POLLUTION REDUCTIONS IN. THE
AND OUR FRONT LINE COMMUNITIES
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON THE DIRECT
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. YES I MEAN
I THINK THAT I THINK WE KNOW
THAT- AB ONE NINETY SEVEN YOU
KNOW REQUIRES US TO BE- MEANING
INTO THOSE DIRECT- EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND- AND WE HAVE
MANY STRATEGIES THAT CAN
ACHIEVE BOTH AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT A LOT OF
THE WORK- REGARDING DIRECT
EMISSIONS HAVE NOT STOPPED AT
THE AIR DISTRICT LEVEL- A
COUPLE OF RECENT EXAMPLES WHERE
THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S INDIRECT
SOURCE ROLE- AROUND THEIR
HOUSES AND THEN THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. RECENTLY ADOPTED A
NEW ROLE REGARDING REFINERY
OPERATIONS SO THAT WORK
CONTINUES- AND- AND AS YOU
MENTIONED THERE ARE THEY GHG
STRATEGIES HAVE BENEFITS AS
RELATES TO AIR QUALITY IN THE
AIR QUALITY STRETCH IDEAS HAVE
BENEFITS. AS RELATE QGA GMS AND-
ALL RIGHT. YOU TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT- SOME OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS THEY THAT THE
PLANS THAT- ARE TAKING PLACE AS
PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
SCOPING PLAN FOR PLANNING FOR
THESE THESE THESE ESSENTIALLY-
YOU KNOW. AND DO ALL- EXECUTIVE
ORDERS- YOU GOVERNOR BROWN'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER- TO ACHIEVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE- AND MORE RECENTLY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER- CALLING UPON THE AIR B.
TO EXPLORE. AFTER WAYS FOR
ACHIEVING CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE- IT ARE ARE
ARE ARE THERE ANY. TRADEOFFS
ARE ARE THERE ANY DOWNSIDES. TO
EXPLORING- A- A SHORTER
TIMELINE TO TWENTY THIRTY FIVE-
TIMELINE. I GUESS THE WAY I
WOULD ARTICULATED IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT A TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE GOAL YOU'RE REALLY
THINKING ABOUT- IN RELATIVELY
SHORT TIME FRAME INTO YOU'RE
REALLY THINKING ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE THAT ARE EITHER. YOU KNOW
IN THE MARKET OR ARE ABOUT TO-
REACH MARKET- AND REACH MORE
WIDESPREAD ADOPTION. IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT TWENTY FORTY
FIVE- YOU YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME
FLEXIBILITY AND THINKING ABOUT
OKAY WHAT WHAT MIGHT THE FUTURE
HOLD- WHAT MIGHT WE SEE IN
TERMS OF- NEW TYPES OF
BATTERIES FOR INSTANCE YOU KNOW
WILL THERE BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MOVE BEYOND LITHIUM ION YOU
KNOW. HOW ARE WE THINKING ABOUT
ARE THERE GOING TO BE ANY- AT.
ANY ENERGY STRATEGIES THAT WE
DON'T YET HAVE RIGHT NOW THAT
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO DEPLOY- SO
I THINK AS AS YOU LOOK AT THE-
THE DIFFERENT TIME FRAMES- WHEN
YOU CAN GET ABOUT TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE YOU'RE REALLY THINKING
ABOUT OKAY WHAT HERE IN FRONT
OF US- IN EITHER. SITUATION YOU
KNOW YOU'RE GONNA NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT ARE THE
AND- THE RIGHT COST EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES AND HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO BE- INCENTIVIZING THEM
AND ROLLING THEM OUT AND
DEPLOYING THEM IN AN EFFECTIVE
WAY AND THAT'S TRUE- AT WHICH
EITHER A TIME FRAME THAT YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT. ALL RIGHT
UNLIKE MY LAST QUESTION FOR NOW
IS. AGAIN GOING TO THAT- THAT
THE BALANCING ACT BETWEEN THE
DIRECT EMISSION REDUCTIONS
VERSUS- THE RELIANCE ON CARBON
CAPTURE AND SEQUESTRATION. IN
YOUR OPINION SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE- REQUIRE A MINIMUM
LEVEL OF EMISSION RDUCTIONS-
THAT MUST BE ACHIEVED IN
CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
OUR CARBON NEUTRALITY GOAL. I
THINK HE- THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
SCOPING PLAN PROCESS IS THAT
EVERY FIVE YEARS WE GET TO LOOK
AT WHERE WE ARE. AND WHAT WE'VE
ACHIEVED WHAT WE HAVEN'T
ACHIEVED AND WHERE WE NEED TO
GO NOW. AND I THINK THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT CAREFUL
DETAILED ANALYSIS THAT
ACCOMPANIED BY PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT- YOU THAT THE
SCIENCE AND THAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE REAL WORLD. I
THINK THAT PROCESS IS THE RIGHT
PROCESS YOU THINK ABOUT.
MAINTAINING THAT NEEDED THE
FLEXIBILITY TO GET TO THE GOAL
THAT WE NEED TO ACHIEVE. THANK
YOU SIR ALAN BUDD'S THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
ALL YOUR WORK. I'M I JUST LOVE
TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON ON- THE
CHANGING. RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THE
ISSUES YOUR CON AND HOW YOUR-
SEEING THEIR WORK MOVING
FORWARD HI GIVEN SOME OF THE
THINGS WE'RE HEARING KIND OF
THE WHITE HOUSE. AND ALSO OTHER
STATES. SURE WE AT CARP HAVE
ENGAGED- WITH THE FEDERAL
EMIGRATE FOR MANY YEARS AND-
AND WHEN I STARTED MY POSITION
I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE-
YOU KNOW A NEW ADMINISTRATION
THAT WAS- INTERESTED IN THE
SAME GOALS WE WERE- AND SO- WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO. ENGAGE WITH
THEM AND REALLY ADVOCATE ON
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
THINK ARE REALLY CRITICAL NEXT
STEPS- THE NEW- EMISSION
STANDARDS- IN LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES BUT ALSO- THINKING
ABOUT WHERE- THE FEDERAL
LEADERSHIP CAN BE IN FEDERALLY
REGULATED SOURCES- SO THAT.
ASKING THEM TO CONSIDER
ADOPTING SOMETHING SIMILAR TO
OUR LOW NOT OMNIBUS RULE TO
CLEAN UP- TRACKING NATIONWIDE-
THE THINKING ABOUT ACTORS LAKE
LOCOMOTIVES AND AVIATION- AND
SO WE HAVE REALLY BEEN
ADVOCATING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL-
THAT. THAT MAY INTO THE STRAW
THAT WILL HAVE NATIONWIDE- AND
WORLDWIDE BENEFITS- BUT AS WE
MENTIONED EARLIER- YOU KNOW WE
NEED THE WHOLE COUNTRY TO BE
MOVING IN THE SAME DIRECTION-
SO AND THEN OF COURSE THE BIG
DISCUSSION AROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE- IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THE- INVESTMENTS THAT
WE NEED TO BE. IN AT VERY
MISSION TECHNOLOGIES AND- AND
THAT THE HEALING INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THAT- THOSE ARE ALL ALL
IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS- THAT
WE HAVE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL-
AND SO I THINK I AM VERY
OPTIMISTIC- THAT WE CAN MAKE IT
PROGRESS. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. IF NOT I
I'D LIKE TO. PERHAPS WELL THE
LAWYER I KNOW I SHOULD NEVER
SAID THIS IS MY LAST QUESTION
BUT- GOING FOLLOWING UP ON YOUR
YOUR YOUR LAST RESPONSE IN
TERMS OF THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
SCOPING PLAN HAVING THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ASSESS IN REAL
TIME THE- THE REALITIES NOT
ONLY OF. THE EMISSIONS THE
TOXIC POLLUTANTS BUT ALSO THE
STATE OF THE ECONOMY THE STATE
OF. YOU KNOW ANY ANY LEAKAGE
MEANT THAT MAYBE TAKEN PLACE-
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO. SEE WHAT
YOU THOUGHT OF- THAT THE FACT
THAT IT TO MY UNDERSTANDING-
THE STATE'S OF WASHINGTON AND
THE STATE OF THAT THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON IN THE STATE OF.
MASSACHUSETTS HAVE IN THE PAST
YEAR ADOPTED- CARBON
NEUTRALITY- LAWS THAT- THAT
SPECIFY- AT LEAST A NINETY
PERCENT- YOU KNOW EIGHT SHAVING
CARBON NEUTRALITY THROUGH AT
LEAST A NINETY PERCENT- CARBON
EMISSIONS- REDUCTION- I MEAN
NAG I DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS- COULD COULD COULD
YOU WELL. COMMENT ON YOUR
OPINION ON ON YOU KNOW. THE
WISDOM OR ARE YOU KNOW WHETHER
CALIFORNIA SHOULD IT SHOULD BE
OF A FOLLOWING. A SIMILAR PATH
IN TERMS OF HAVING GONE. A
REALISTIC- ROADMAP TO ACHIEVING
CARBON NEUTRALITY- INTERSTATE.
I AM I WAS REALLY PLEASED WITH
THE- WASHINGTON MASSACHUSETTS
YOU KNOW- IMPLEMENT THE- THEIR
NEW LEGISLATION AND- AND I
THINK IT'S I THINK IT'S AN
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY- I HAVE TO
SAY I FEEL THAT- YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS AND- AND CONTINUES TO
MAKE PROGRESS AND SO- I LEAVE
IT TO THE WISDOM OF THE
LEGISLATURE AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANT TO DO SOMETHING.
DIFFERENT SO I GUESS I'LL JUST
LEAVE IT AT THAT. VERY
DIPLOMATICALLY STATED THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ARE A LOT
LIKE TO- WELCOME ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BURKE- MEMBER THEY THAT THE
COMMITTEE- ASSEMBLY WOMAN ON
AND DID YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
OR ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY ARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT CHEN
AROUND OFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT TO A NEXT- I'D LIKE
TO PROCEED TO OUR SECOND PANEL.
WHICH IS- A PRESENTATION FROM
OUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE ROSS BROWN- PRINCIPLE
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST ON
CLIMATE CHANGE- AS WELL AS- TWO
MEMBERS OF THE INDEPENDENT. AND
LET'S GET THAT LONG ACRONYM-
MIXED UP ARE YOU MAC- DOCTOR
DAN CULLEN WARD. AND PROFESSOR
MEREDITH VALLEY SO LIKE TO ASK-
MISTER BROWN WITH THE L. A. L.
TO- START OF STARTS OFF ON THE
SECOND PANEL OF OUR HEARING
TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS ROSS BROWN WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- I'VE BEEN ASKED TO.
REALLY KIND OF FOCUS ON THREE
QUESTIONS AS PART OF OUR
PRESENTATION HERE ONE WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE STATE'S PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW- TO ARE WE ON
TRACK TO MEET THE STATE'S SB
THIRTY TWO GOALS IN TWENTY
THIRTY. AND THREE WHAT ARE THE
IMPLICATIONS OF CAN ANSWER
STUDENTS QUESTIOS FOR A LONG
TERM CARBON NEUTRALITY GOALS.
ARE SO BEFORE I KIND OF GET
INTO THOSE QUESTIONS I DID JUST
WANT TO REITERATE A COUPLE
THINGS AND PROVIDE JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE CONTEXT AT SOME
OF THIS DISCUSSION- AS CHAIR
RANDOLPH MENTIONS AND AS I'M
SURE ALL OF YOU KNOW WE'VE MET
OUR- TWENTY TWENTY GOAL EARLY
BUT THE TWENTY THIRTY GOAL- WE
HAVE AS MUCH MORE AMBITIOUS AND
JUSTIN. QUANTITATIVE TERMS THE
ANNUAL REDUCTIONS NEEDED TO
MEET OUR THE TWENTY TWENTY GOAL
IS ABOUT ONE PERSON PER YEAR-
WHEREAS THE REDUCTIONS NEEDED
TO MEET THE TWENTY THIRTY GOALS
ABOUT 4% PER YEAR SO THAT'S A-
BIG DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF. THE
LEVEL OF AMBITION- AND AS FAR
AS CERTAIN MEETING OUR GOALS SO
FAR- AGAIN COMPANIES YOUR
PROBABLY ALL WELL WELL AWARE OF
BUT THE ELECTRICITY SECTOR
EMISSIONS HAVE REALLY BEEN THE
LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
REDUCTION SO FAR- BUT IN ORDER
TO MAKE THAT MORE AMBITIOUS
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL IT'S GONNA
REQUIRE REDUCTIONS FROM OTHER
AREAS BESIDES JUST. THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR- THEY ARE
THING I JUST WANTED TO ON THIS
HAS. AS I DO KNOW BRIAN OF
POWER I'M NOT TO WALK ALL OF
THEM. AROUND OFF ON A LOT OF
THEM INCLUDING RIGHT. AND SEND.
CAP AND TRADE- I THINK FROM OUR
OFFICES PERSPECTIVE WHAT KIND
OF SOME OF THE FRAMING THAT WE
USED TO THINK ABOUT- YOU KNOW
CONSIDERATIONS FOR MERIT TO THE
DIFFERENT POLICIES. INCLUDE THE
COST EFFECTIVENESS IS ALWAYS
KIND OF- AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION FOR OUR OFFICE
AND SOMETHING THAT WE LOOK
INTO- BUT ALSO- COMPENSATES
WHICH APARTMENT DISCUSSED ABOUT
THINGS LIKE ARTICLE POLLUTION
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION. EQUITY
CONSIDERATIONS AND DISTRIBUTION
OF COSTS AND BENEFITS. AND
FINALLY THE AFFECTS OF THE
STATE'S POLICIES- BUT HAPPENS
IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS- AND
THAT COULD MEAN. THINGS LIKE
THAT RICH WHICH CALIFORNIA'S
POLICIES. PROMOTE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ARE OR REDUCE THE
COST OF DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES
THAT CAN GET UP IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. OR WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S A POLICY IS SERVICES
AND EFFECTIVE DEMONSTRATION FOR
OTHER JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
LOOKING TO ADOPT. MORE
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE POLICIES AND
SO- THESE ARE ALL KIND OF
THINGS TO THINK ABOUT OF COURSE
I'M THINKING ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'VE ACHIEVED SO FAR IN
TERMS OF POLICIES BUT ALSO.
CONSIDERATIONS GOING FORWARD.
SO WITH THAT I WANT JUST
OUTLINED INTO AN- MY- ON A OF
THE BY. THAT I'M- MISTER MY
TIME ON THIS FOR QUESTION ABOUT
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE EFFECTS
OF. OTHER PROGRAMS AND POLICIES
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE-
FOR CONTEXT OUR OFFICE DOES
HAVE AN ANNUAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENT AND STATUTE RIGHT
NOW. TO REPORT ANNUALLY ON THE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS AND COSTS OF
THE STATE'S. CLIMATE PROGRAMS
AND SO RICHARD A COUPLE REPORTS
ONE OF THEM I FOCUSED ON THE
STATE'S MAJOR TRANSPORTATION
POLICIES. ANOTHER FOCUS ON
ELECTRIC ELECTRICITY GENERATION
SO SOME OF MY COMMENTS ARE
REALLY BASED ON. FINDING AND
FINDING THEM THOSE RECORDS. I
THINK REALLY THE KEY FINDING
FROM- ONE OF THE KEY FINDINGS
FROM BOTH OF THOSE REPORTS IS
THAT WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
GREAT. PROGRAM ABOUT ASIAN
INFORMATION- ABOUT KIND OF THE
OVERALL COSTS AND BENEFITS OF
SPECIFIC POLICIES AND SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS- THERE'S A MAKING OF
LIMITED INFORMATION IN MANY
CASES- NOW BASED ON THAT
INFORMATION THAT IS AVAILABLE-
BUT SOME OF THAT THE FINDINGS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE OR THAT- YOU
KNOW THAT THINGS LIKE THE
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO. LIKELY HAD
THE BIGGEST EFFECT ON A MISSION
REDUCTIONS OF THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. AND A RELATIVELY MODEST
OR MODERATE COSTS ARE BASED ON
OUR SOME OF OUR BACK OF THE
ENVELOPE CALCULATIONS IS ABOUT
SIXTY TO SEVENTY DOLLARS. PER
TON WHICH IS NO MORE THAN THAT
ARE THE PRICE OF A CAP AND
TRADE ALLOWANCE BUT LESS THAN.
SOME OF THE OTHER POLICIES
WHICH- THE AVAILABLE
INFORMATION SUGGESTS THE COST
PER TON ARE. YOU KNOW NOT TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER TIME
ROUGHLY IN THE CASE OF THE LCS
US FOR EXAMPLE OR IN THE CASE
OF SOME OF OUR- INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THAT'S OVER A- THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER TIME- AND SO I
DON'T BUT IN MOST CASES THERE'S
REALLY LIMITED KIND OF RELIABLE
INFORMATION ON THE COSTS. AND
BENEFITS OF SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT POLICIES- AND SO I
MEAN I DO IT IN THAT VEIN I
THINK I DO WANT TO ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT. IN MANY CASES.
IT'S VERY HARD TO KIND OF
MEASURE THESE THINGS REALLY
WELL- IT'S NOT JUST A MATTER OF
COLLECTING DATA AND TRACKING
EMISSIONS INTERPRET. SO I WE
WANT TO KNOW EFFECT OF THE
PARTICULAR POWER. THERE'S A LOT
OF OTHER. FACTORS CHANGING.
CONDITIONS CHANGES IN MY PRICE
THAT MIGHT HAVE OCCURRED
OTHERWISE FEDERAL AND LOCAL
POLICIES. AS WELL AS JUST
OVERLAP BETWEEN KIND OF THE
DIFFERENT STATE POLICIES THAT
WE HAVE BEEN SO WONDERFUL THIS
IS OUR- ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
WE HAVE. REGULATION ENCOURAGING
I'M MORE PRODUCTION OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. AS WELL AS
INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE
CONSUMERS TO PURCHASE VEHICLES
AN ANSWER AS TO. ENCOURAGE
ADDITIONAL CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO- TRYING
TO THIRTIES OUT. WOULD BE
AFFECTED AFFECTED NURSING
AFFECTS ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT
POLICIES THAT EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING SO THAT. WE SAY
THANK ARE ARE RELATED MAIN
RECOMMENDATION FROM SOME OF
THESE RECORDS- IF YOU KIND OF
THE IT'S MY TESTIMONY WITH ONE
THING I THINK THIS IS REALLY AT
AS- WE DO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY KIND OF
THINK ABOUT CONSIDER PROCESS
FOR GETTING BETTER INFORMATION
ABOUT PROGRAM AFFECTS. A POLICY
THAT WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED SO
FAR. AND THIS COULD INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE- PLANNING
BEFOREHAND BEFORE POLICY IS
IMPLEMENTED A NEW POLICIES
IMPLEMENTED OR PROGRAM IS
EXPANDED. ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO EVALUATE THE EFFECTS. AND I
CAN INCLUDE THINGS LIKE WORKING
WITH EXPERTS OUR OUTSIDE
APPETITE ECONOMICS ON WHAT DATA
WOULD BE NEEDED. YOU KNOW WHAT
METHODS MIGHT BE USED WHAT ARE
NOT THERE'S A. FINALLY IT GOOD
COULD LIKELY MANY CASES REQUIRE
A LITTLE BIT A BIT MORE FUNDING
TO. SUPPORT THESE TYPES OF
EFFORTS BUT IN OUR DELUXE ARE.
RELATIVELY IT WOULD BE A
RELATIVELY MODEST AMOUNT
PROBABLY COMPARED TO JUST THE
OVERALL SIZE AND SCOPE OF THESE
PROGRAMS. I REALLY THAT. YOU
HAVE THAT REASON FOR- IN
FOCUSING ON EVALUATING PROGRAMS
WE HAD I THINK ARE ARE KIND OF
TWO FOLD ONE. JUST YOU KNOW
HAVING THAT INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT'S NOT-
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
INFORMING LONG TERM POLICY
DECISIONS IN CALIFORNIA ON THE
EFFECTS THAT. OCCUR IN
CALIFORNIA. TRYING TO ADOPT THE
MOST AFFECTED PROGRAMS. BUT
ALSO IN THE SPACE AND THE
CLIMATE CHANGE SPACE. ARE AT
STAKE I HAVE THE POTENTIALLY
HELP SERVICE. I'M NOT SORT OF
DEMONSTRATION ROLE TO THE REST
OF THE WORLD TO THE DEGREE WE
HAVE. BETTER INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT'S WORKED WHAT WORKS WHAT
DOESN'T QUITE WORK WHAT TE
DIFFERENT TRADE OFFS OF ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH DIFFERENT
OPTIONS. I CAN REALLY CAN HELP
INFORM SOME OF THOSE DECISIONS
IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS AND
PERHAPS GOING TO PROMOTE. MORE
AMBITIOUS ACTION THERE. SO THAT
WAS MAIN THOSE ARE OF THE MAIN.
I WANTED TO MAKE A KIND OF TALK
ON A COUPLE OTHER. ARE OTHER
ONE I WE ON. TO THE TWENTY
THIRTY GOAL. ARE B. MOST RECENT
SCOPING PLAN TWENTY SEVENTEEN-
RELIES PRETTY HEAVILY ON CAP
AND TRADE TO MEET THE- TWENTY
THIRTY GOALS AND IN GENERAL OUR
OFFICE IS ARE SUPPORTED BY OF
CARBON PRICING. INCLUDING CAP
AND TRADE IS REALLY A- A CORE
STRATEGY FOR ACHIEVING
REMISSION REDUCTIONS WE DO
THINK. THERE'S A LOT OF
EVIDENCE SUGGESTING THAT THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH TO
REDUCING EMISSIONS- BUT IT'S
NOT CLEAR THAT THE PROGRAM HAS
STRUCTURED TODAY. TODAY IN
DESIGNS AND IMPLEMENTED TODAY
IT'S REALLY SET OUT TO
ACCOMPLISH THE TASK PASCO
COUNTY. ALLOWING THE STATE TO
ME THAT'S TWENTY THIRTY GOALS
ARE HAPPY TO KIND OF DISCUSS
THOSE CAP AND TRADE ISSUES AND
DESIGN ISSUES. ARE FURTHER- BUT
IT IT JUST KIND OF WANT TO FLAG
THAT IS SORT OF ONE OF THE KEY
KIND OF UP TO DRAW CONCERNED
AREAS OF CONCERN WE HAVE ABOUT
WHETHER NOT THE CURRENCY TO
POLICIES. IS SET UP TO CHEAT
THE LEGISLATORS. TWENTY THIRTY
GOALS- FINALLY. OUT WHAT IS.
ALL FIVE CARBON. BY THEY'RE
THEY'RE STILL I THINK A LOT
WORK TO- TO MEET THOSE TWENTY
THIRD. OUR GOALS THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE IN STATUTE AND I
SOME UNCERTAINTY RIGHT NOW
ABOUT EXACTLY HOW THOSE GOALS
WILL BE MET- AND OF COURSE
THERE. WILL BE CAN'T EVEN MORE
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT. SOME OF THE
LONGER TERM GOALS AND HOW
THEY'RE NOT. OUT WE DO THINK
LONGER TERM GOALS CAN BE
HELPFUL TO REALLY GUIDE
PLANNING- AND HELP. OUT FOR
EXAMPLE- AVOID THINGS LIKE
STRANDED ASSETS AND INVESTING
IN THINGS THAT WON'T BE USED
ANYMORE. AS WELL AS PROVIDE-
LONG TERM MARKET SIGNALS- BUT
AGAIN CIRCLING BACK TO KIND OF
ONE OF OUR MAIN POINTS OUT WE
THINK NOT GOOD EVALUATION IS
REALLY KEY TO UNDERSTANDING.
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF TRADEOFFS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE POLICY
CHOICES WE HAVE AND INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT. I WISH
POLICIES TO ADOPT A REALLY KIND
OF THE HOW HOW WE GET THERE WE
THINK IS A REALLY. IMPORTANT- I.
GONNA MARC MARKS POWER. COME
ALLEGED TO ME ITS GOAL OF THE
MOST. COME FOR POTENTIAL
TREATED MORE AMBITIOUS. AT AT
SIMILAR. JUST OTHER SWEET OF.
POLICIES THAT MIGHT BE ABLE BIT
MARC. SO ARE THOSE ARE ARE MAIN.
OF COURSE HAPPY TO- CONTINUE
DISCUSSION AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTION THAT YOU HAVE. STATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
BROWN- QUESTIONS. SENATE
SKINNER THAN CENTER BACKER.
WHAT THE MOVE IN THE GLASS ALL
OVER SORRY- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND- NO OF THE L. A.
O. IS ISSUED NUMEROUS REPORTS
OVER THE YEARS ON CAP AND TRADE
THE ON YOU KNOW ON THE
EXPENDITURE PLAN LAST YEAR BACK
WHEN WE WERE AND- RENEWING ITS
THE- THE WHOLE. THE PROPOSAL IS
YOU DID EVALUATION OF THOSE.
WHAT I'M WONDERING IS IF THE L.
A. ALWAYS PLANNING ON YOU MADE
A REFERENCE TO THAT THE L. A.
O. SUPPORTS MARKET MEASURES AS
BEING ONE OF THE MORE EFFECTIVE
WAYS FOR US TO MEET OUR GOALS
AND CAP AND TRADE BEING ONE. HI
HAS THE L. A. O. CONSIDERED
PRODUCING REPORT ON WHAT OTHER
MARKET MEASURES WE MIGHT BE
CONSIDERING AND- ADDITIONALLY
HOW THE L. A. O. WOOD. REVISE
RESTRUCTURE OR WHATEVER- OR
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR. REVISIONS
TO OUR CURRENT CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM HAS L. A. O. CONSIDERED.
USING THAT. YEAH SENATORS GONNA
THEIR- BOTH KIND OF ISSUES THAT
WE THOUGHT QUITE A BIT ABOUT I
DON'T KNOW I CAN'T SAY THAT WE
HAVE- HAVE A PRODUCT IN THE
WORKS RIGHT NOW- I THINK THOSE
ARE BOTH VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES
AND- I THINK JUST GOING BACK
TO. WELL ACTUALLY BOTH OF THEM
I THINK WE HAVE OFFERED SOME OF
OUR COMMENTS. REGARDING
ALTERNATIVE MARKET MEASURES
LIKE A CARBON TAX I THINK THERE
ARE. THE TRADE OFFS BETWEEN
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND CAP AND
TRADE- AND OF COURSE HAPPY TO
EXPLORE THOSE WERE SOME TIME
AGO AND CLEARLY THINGS. THAT
WAS THEN THIS IS NOW. SURE SO
WHAT WE ARE OF COURSE ALWAYS-
OPEN TO- KIND OF DIVING INTO
SOME OF THESE ISSUES FOR IT
PARTICULARLY IF YOU HAVE AN
INTEREST OR THE INTERESTS OF
THE COMMITTEE. THAT KIND OF
LOOKING INTO SOME OF THOSE
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS IN MORE
DETAIL I IN TERMS OF KIND OF
REVISIONS TO THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM- AGAIN AT IT YOU KNOW
ITS- IT'S NOW KIND OF A COUPLE
YEARS OLD BUT I THINK. SOME OF
THE OPTIONS THAT WE HAVE LOOKED
AT IN THE PAST WAS JUST KIND OF
YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY OPTIONS TO
DEAL WITH. WHAT WE DO AS- A
LARGE AMOUNT OF BANKED
ALLOWANCES THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT- HAVE EFFECTIVE KIND OF
REDUCING MARKET PRICES OUT
THERE AND START SETTING UP THE-
PROGRAM IN A WAY THAT ISN'T
REALLY CONSISTENT WITH THE
AMBITION OF THE LEGISLATURE
SCHOOLS AND- ARABI SORT OF
CLEAREST WAY TO ADDRESS THAT
COULD BE SOMETHING LIKE.
ADJUSTING SORT OF THE- NUMBER
OF ALLOWANCES THAT ARE ISSUED
IN THE FUTURE AND THERE'S A
RIGHT OF WAYS YOU COULD DO
THAT. AB RIGHT IT KIND OF
CONSIDERATIONS AROUND THAT BUT
I THINK THAT'S ONE THING THAT
IMMEDIATELY COMES TO MIND BUT
AGAIN THAT'S ANOTHER. ISSUE
WHERE- WE'RE HAPPY TO KIND OF
CONTINUE TO KEEP EXPLORE FOR
THEIR WITH WITH YOU AND THAT
THE REST OF THE LEGISLATURE
EFFECTS OF INTEREST. SIR SO ARE
YOU IS THAT ARE YOU MORE OR
LESS. INDICATING THAT WE WOULD
NEED TO PROMPT. UP L. ROSE
PRODUCTION OF SUCH THREE. I
MEAN I THINK IT'S- IT'S ALWAYS
HELPFUL TO FOR US TO KNOW- YOU
KNOW WHICH QUESTIONS YOU ALL
HAVE A COMMON MOST RELEVANT TO
YOUR- POLICY DECISIONS AND SO-
YEAH I CAN GET IT BUT IT'S
ALWAYS HELPFUL TO KIND OF GET A
SENSE. FROM YOU ALL- AROUND
KIND OF WHAT WHAT THE KEY
QUESTIONS ARE THAT YOU ARE MOST
INTERESTED IN AND THEN- WE'RE
ALWAYS HAPPY TO- KIND OF
CONDUCT OUR ANALYSIS IN A WAY
THAT THAT THAT THAT IT KIND OF
HELPS ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
OKAY SO WE WILL DEFINITELY
FOLLOW UP ON A- PERHAPS
EMITTING A REQUEST TO THE- L.
A- CENTER BECKER AND THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU
THANKS FOR COMMENTS. IT YOU
MENTIONING A CAP AND TRADE AND-
RESPONSE CENTER SCANNERS
QUESTION AND THE OVER
ALLOCATION OF BANK ALLOWANCES
IS SOMETHING SO A STRONG A
CONCERN TO ME AS WELL
ESPECIALLY AS OUR- A CARBON
PRICE HAS HAS BUMPED ALONG AT
THE BOTTOM OF THE MARKET. RIGHT
EIGHTEEN DOLLARS A TIME WHERE
YOU'RE BRIGHT HOUSE AT SIXTY
DOLLARS A TON SO I THINK WE DO
HAVE TO. LOOK AT THAT AND WHAT
WE CAN DO TO SEND A STRONGER
MARKET SIGNAL THERE'S
APPRECIATE YOU. RAISING THAT.
BUT I GUESS THE QUESTION WE
TALK ABOUT COST EFFECTIVENESS-
REPORT FROM A NONPROFIT CALLED
TOUR JUST CAME OUT NOW LOOKING
AT SUPER USERS- OF
TRANSPORTATION WE LOOK AT
TRANSPORTATION AS A- AS ONE OF
THE AREAS OF REDUCING.
EMISSIONS INTO TERMS OF COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR- OUR
INCENTIVES OF PEOPLE
TRANSITIONING SAY TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES THAT HE THOUGHT AT ALL
ABOUT THAT AND HOW DO WE TARGET
PEOPLE WHO ARE DRIVING THE MOST
AND OFTEN HAVE. THE CARS THAT
HAVE THE LEAST FUEL EFFICIENCY
AND HOW CAN WE TARGET OUR
CENTERS THAT WAY FROM A COST.
BENEFIT ANALYSIS. YEAH I MEAN I
THINK- THERE'S A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS YOU HAVE I MEAN I THINK
JUST THE FIRST THING THAT
IMMEDIATELY COMES TO MIND AS
AND THIS TIES BACK TO THE KIND
OF CARBON PRICING CONVERSATION-
WHICH IS THAT NO CARBON PRICE
KIND OF. DOES THAT- TO A LARGE
EXTENT ON THE NATURAL- SO YOU
KNOW- INDIVIDUALS OR HOUSEHOLDS
WHO ARE ARE BURNING A LOT OF
FUEL EMITTING A LOT OF- CARBON
FROM OTHER FUEL CONSUMPTION-
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT KIND OF-
TEND TO KIND OF HAVE TO- YOU
KNOW THEY THEY SEE MORE OF KIND
OF THE CARBON PRICING- SIGNAL
AND SO IT KIND OF NATURALLY. I
PROVIDES A LITTLE BIT OF THAT-
IN TERMS OF. THE TARGET- SAY
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES FOR- YOU
KNOW VEHICLE NEW VEHICLE
PURCHASES FROM HEAVY USERS I
DON'T I'M NOT SOMETHING I GUESS
WE HAVEN'T REALLY. LOOKED INTO
AN A GREAT AMOUNT OF DEBT YEAH
BUT AGAIN KIND OF HAPPY TO- TO.
CIRCLE BACK AROUND WITH YOU AND
YOUR STAFF TO THINK ABOUT THE
ISSUE A LITTLE BIT MORE. THANKS
TO THESE IMPORTANT SHOULD LOOK
AT GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES THAN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE- THANK YOU
ROSS JUST- WANTED OF A TO ASK
YOU THE SAME REALLY THE SAME
QUESTION LAST OF THE OF THE
CHAIR. OF CARVE- IN REGARDS TO
THE EXPENDITURES THE DOLLARS
THAT WE'VE COLLECTED- FOR- FROM
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM THE
G. G. R. F. HOW WE SPENT THOSE
DOLLARS AND THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO MAXIMIZE REDUCTIONS IN
GREENHOUSE GASES. ARE THERE
OTHER ALTERNATIVES- THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE DONE AND SHOULD
LOOK AT THE TOWARD REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. YEAH
I MEAN I THINK IN TERMS OF JUST
THE INFORMATION WE HAVE
AVAILABLE AND THE ABSTINENCE OF
WHAT EACH PROGRAM IS
ACCOMPLISHING IN TERMS OF COST
PER TIME REDUCED- AT LEAST IN
TERMS OF DIRECT REDUCTIONS I
THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT
YOU KNOW WE ARE NOT NECESSARILY
FOCUSING OUR SPENDING ON. THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE- APPROACHES
I MEAN IF YOU LOOK AT EVEN JUST
THE REPORTING FROM THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ON A COST PER
TIME YOU'LL SEE A RANGE FROM
YOU KNOW ROUGHLY TEN DOLLARS
PER TIME OUT TO A FEW THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER TIME- NOW I THINK
YOU KNOW OUR PERSPECTIVE IS
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO KIND OF.
NOTE THAT YOU KNOW THAT'S KIND
OF LOOKING AT IT FROM A TERROR
SORT OF DIRECT CARBON EMISSION
REDUCTIONS AND THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT I THINK A LOT OF
OTHER CONSIDERATIONS GO INTO
SPENDING DECISIONS OF COURSE AS
YOU KNOW- AROUND KIND OF OTHER
TYPES OF COAL POLLUTANTS AND CO
BENEFITS THAT MIGHT SORT OF
PLAY INTO SOME OF THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS- I THINK ANOTHER
BIG PIECE. IS THE SORT OF
TECHNOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT AND
QUESTION A LOT OF THE PROGRAMS
WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON PILOTS AND
DEMONSTRATIONS ARE WITH KIND OF
THE IDEA THAT THERE WILL BE A
LONG TERM BENEFITS ASSOCIATED
WITH. PROMOTING A- KIND OF
NEWER TECHNOLOGY AND SO THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE BENEFITS THAT ARE
A LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT TO
QUANTIFY AND DON'T REALLY SHOW
UP IN SOME OF THOSE JUST CARE
COST PER TIME CONSIDERATIONS
BUT WE ARE WE DO WE DO THINK
THAT'S KIND OF ONE IMPORTANT
THING TO THINK ABOUT AS WELL.
RIGHT RIGHT AND DID YOU THINK
IT BE DIFFERENT IF THERE ARE
SOME OTHER MECHANISM OF REVENUE
LIKE A CARBON TAX THAT THERE'S
A DIRECT CARBON TAX DO YOU
THINK THAT WE WOULD BE BETTER-
WITH COLLECTING THAT REVENUE
AND SPENDING. IT TOWARD
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THAT'S SOMETHING I
CAN'T- I CAN'T REALLY SAY I
MEAN THOSE- APPROPRIATION
DECISIONS ARE ARE UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE- AND MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. SO I CAN'T SAY
SORT OF HOW ON A SPENDING WITH
THIS. CHANGE AT ALL IF THEY
WERE JUST A DIFFERENT KIND OF
MECHANISM FOR COLLECTING. FOR
COLLECTING THE REVENUE I WHAT I
CAN SAY ON THE REVENUE SIDE AS
THE- YOU KNOW THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVE OPPORTUNITIES
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES- LIKE A
CARBON TAX- THEY DO HAVE
DIFFERENT CHARACTERISTICS IN
TERMS OF THE VOLATILITY OF THE
REVENUE SO THERE'S- POTENTIALLY
WAYS TO KIND OF STRUCTURE THOSE
THAT- REDUCE SOME OF THE
REVENUE VOLATILITY THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN PAST YEARS SO- I THINK
A LOT OF A DIFFERENT SORT OF
SHOW UP ON THAT SIDE OF THINGS-
BETTER KIND OF DECISIONS ABOUT
HOW THE MONEY IS ALLOCATED.
REALLY SORT OF DEPENDS ON
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AND
ALLOCATIONS. OKAY THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN- BURKE. SO MIKE
A GROUP BECAUSE BY TO THIS.
COMING ABOUT THOSE WHO TRY
FURTHER- AND A CARBON TAX AND
THE COST AFFECTS I WAS
WONDERING WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THOSE THINGS ESPECIALLY FOR
PEOPLE OF MY DISTRICT THEY
DRIVE FURTHER BECAUSE- THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE. WHERE
THEY WORK- ARE THOSE EQUITY
CONVERSATIONS GOING TO BE
INCLUDED IN ANY REPORT YOU'RE
DOING ARE ARE THEY INCLUDED IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS- AND
REPORTS AS YOU'RE HAVING THEM-
DIRECT EFFECT WE DON'T HAVE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN OUR
DISTRICT BECAUSE WE CAN'T.
AFFORD THEM NOR DO OUR HOUSING
STRUCTURES ALLOW- HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY OR THE ABILITY TO
HAVE THEM SELL- I'M JUST
WONDERING WHERE EQUITY FALLS IN
THAT CONVERSATION. YEAH I MEAN
IT THREE EQUITIES
CONSIDERATIONS- AND ARGUE
SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE PART OF
THE- CONVERSATION- AND I THINK
THAT'S PART OF WHAT SORT OF
MAKES A LOT OF THE DECISIONS SO
DIFFICULT AND ONE. POLICY
MIGHT- MIGHT WORK WELL I'M KIND
OF ONE METRIC WHETHER IT COST-EFFECTIVENESS- AND MAYBE NOT AS
WELL ON SOME OTHER METRIC- LIKE
EQUITY I MEAN I THINK IN THE
CASE OF. A CAP AND TRADE OR A
CARBON PRICING IN GENERAL
THERE'S- IT HAS THE BENEFIT OF
HAVING A LOT OF OPTIONS FOR
TRYING TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE%
EQUITY CONSIDERATIONS THE FACT
THAT. THE STATE DOES COLLECT
REVENUE AS A RESULT IN CAN USE
THAT REVENUE IN A WAY THAT. IS
TARGETED TO OFFSET
SOME OF THOSE EFFECTS- IS SORT
OF A BENEFIT OF CARBON PRICING
IN GENERAL BUT I THINK OVERALL.
WE THINK ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
POLICY OPTIONS WE HAVE THINKING
ABOUT NOT JUST COST
EFFECTIVENESS BUT HOW THOSE
COSTS AND BENEFITS ARE
DISTRIBUTED IS REALLY.
IMPORTANT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION OF SOMETHING THAT
WE- WILL CONTINUE TO TRY TO-
CONSIDER AND ACTIVISTS ACTORS
GET INFORMATION KIND OF
HIGHLIGHT I WAS SORT OF ONE OF
THE TRADE ALSO CONSIDERATIONS.
AND THE DIFFERENT POLICY
OPTIONS WE HAVE. THANK YOU. FOR
I GUESS I'D LIKE TO- RUN OUT
OUR- REQUEST FOR YOU MISTER
BROWN WITH THE- YOU BRING IT
BACK TO. ONE OF MY MAIN
QUESTIONS- GLENN ONE OF MY MAIN
GOALS FOR THIS HEARING TODAY IS
TO TRY TO GET. YOU KNOW. AS
CLOSER DEFINITIVE ANSWER IN IN
IN TERMS OF WHETHER WE'RE ON
TRACK TO MEET OUR TWENTY THIRTY
GOAL- I HEARD YOU SAY THAT. THE
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL IS MUCH MORE
AMBITIOUS I HEARD YOU SAY THAT
THE TWENTY THIRTY- SCOPING PLAN
THE LAST CUP INCLINED- THE PLAN
RELIES HEAVILY. ON CAP AND
TRADE THAT WHILE- IT IT- IS
APPEARS TO BE THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE THAT IT'S- WHAT I
HEARD YOU SAYING WAS ADDED
RAISES CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER
WE ARE IN FACT ON TRACK TO
MEETING OR TWENTY THIRTY GOAL.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK- BASED ON
KIND OF THE INFORMATION WE HAVE
NOW IN THE PLAN THAT THE STATE
ADOPTED SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT- THE ROLE
CAP AND TRADE PLAYED AND SO
KIND OF HOW IT'S ACTUALLY-
DESIGNED AND IMPLEMENTED RIGHT
NOW I THINK WE HAVE WE DON'T I
FRANKLY HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE THAT KIND OF THE
CURRENT- POLICY FRAMEWORK AND
KIND OF SET OF POLICIES AND
DESIGN OF POLICIES IT'S GONNA-
IS GONNA HELP US MEET THAT
TWENTY THIRTY BALK NOW THERE'S
A LOT OF. A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
OF COURSE BETWEEN NOW AND
TWENTY THIRTY THERE ARE A LOT
OF THINGS THAT COULD CHANGE-
EVEN OUTSIDE OF SORT OF THE
STATE POLICY WORLD LIKE
CHANGING ECONOMIC CONDITIONS WE
OBVIOUSLY ARE STILL NOT A
PANDEMIC WHICH AS YOU KNOW HUGE
EFFECTS THERE COULD BE CHANGES
IN FEDERAL POLICY THAT HAVE. A
SIGNIFICANT AFFECTS ON ON STATE
EMISSIONS AND SO ALL THOSE
THINGS- YOU KNOW COULD SORT OF
REALLY CHANGE CHANGE THE WORLD
GOING FORWARD OUT OF TWENTY
THIRTY BUT AS FAR AS- WHERE WE
SIT NOW AND WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
KIND BUT IT'S NOT A PLAN THAT
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW. WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE THAT
WERE. OUR CURRENT SORT OF. IS
GOING TO HELP US MEET THOSE.
ARE I THINK WE DON'T. A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT- THAT THEY- NEW
MODELING DONE BY A RP. THAT'S
OF ITS TWENTY SCOPING PLAN WILL
REALLY- HELP ANSWER THIS
QUESTION OF RIGHT A LITTLE BIT
MORE INSIGHTS INTO. WHERE WE
ARE RIGHT NOW- GIVEN THAT THE
LAST GOVERNMENT PLAN WAS
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. IN TERMS OF
WHAT OUR CURRENT POLICY
SCENARIO IS AND WHAT WE SORT OF
INVASION. OUR CURRENT POLICIES
ARE GOING TO ACHIEVE AND THEN-
AND THEN HELP SPREAD THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT IF
ANYTHING- IN TERMS OF
ADDITIONAL POLICIES ARE NEEDED
TO MEET UP TWENTY THIRTY GOAL.
SO YOU WITH YOUR. CONCERN ABOUT
WHETHER. ARE YOUR YOUR YOUR
LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE AND WHETHER
WE ARE ON TRACK TO MEETING OUR
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL- I KNOW THAT
FOR EXAMPLE ASSEMBLY BILL ON
ONE NINETY SEVEN. REQUIRED DATE
THE A R. B. TO PRIORITIZE
DIRECT EMISSION REDUCTIONS- AND
YET- THE AND THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLAN- HAS
INCREASED IN THE- BED THE
EXPECTED ROLE OF REDUCTIONS TO
NEARLY HALF OF ALL REQUIRED-
THROUGH CAP AND TRADE- SHOULD
WE BE. PASSING POLICIES THAT
PLACE GREATER EMPHASIS ON
PRIORITIZING DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS OVER CAP AND TRADE.
I THINK THE ANSWER THAT COMIC
COMES DOWN TO SOMEBODY'S THE
QUESTIONS WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
DISCUSSING AROUND- YOU KNOW HOW
THE LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZES-
DIFFERENT CRITERIA ON HONEST
POLICIES ON TERMS OF COST
EFFECTIVENESS THINK AGAIN KIND
OF YOU KNOW CONCENTRATE OR SOME
SORT OF CARBON PRICING POLICY.
IF THAT'S YOUR OVER PRIMARY
METRIC FOR ACHIEVING THOSE
GOALS WE THINK KIND OF ANGEL
CHANGES THEY ARE FOCUSING ON
MAKING SURE THAT THAT THE
PRICING POLICIES ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATE'S GOALS THAT IS
REALLY WHERE YOU SHOULD FOCUS
YOUR EFFORTS. I'M NOT
NECESSARILY KIND OF OTHER-
DIRECT EMISSION REDUCTION
POLICIES HOWEVER THERE ARE
pCONSIDERATIONS- AROUNDS- YOU
KNOW- DEVELOPING NEWER
TECHNOLOGIES OR- OTHER CO
POLLUTANT ISSUES THAT THERE ARE
ARE JUST KIND OF THERE'S A
PROFIT OTHER POLICIES WILL
REDUCE COPELAND'S MORE THAN CAP
AND TRADE FOR EXAMPLE. AND THAT
COULD BE A CONSIDERATION ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WAYS THOSE OF THE OTHER THINGS-
I BELIEVE AND- THERE CAN
CERTAINLY BE AN ARGUMENT. FOR
FOCUSING ON SOME OF THOSE OTHER
POLICIES. IF OUR PRIMARY IF THE-
PRIMER. IS TO TUNE IN MATE V.
STATUTORY- GOAL OF- SB THIRTY
TWO THAT THE TWENTY THIRTY GOAL.
SHOULD A GREATER EMPHASIS BE
PLACED ON DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. I THINK NOT
NECESSARILY AND I THINK- I
THINK YOU YOU HAVE THE OPTION
OF LOOKING AT DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIN POLICIES OR CARBON
PRICING IN CAP AND TRADE AND I
THINK- IF IT'S IF IT'S STRICTLY
ON KIND OF A- COST
EFFECTIVENESS CARBON
REDUCTIONS. OUT WE THINK KIND
OF FOCUSING ON- MODIFYING THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM TO KIND
OF PROVIDE GREATER INCENTIVES
FOR THAT PROGRAM IT'S REALLY
SORT OF THE WAY TO GO- WELL I
THINK IT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THAT THAT REALLY
MEANS EFFECTIVELY THAT YOU WERE
HAVING. QUITE A BIT HIGHER
CARBON PRICES LIKELY AND SO YOU
KNOW THERE ARE THINGS THAT YOU
NEED TO THINK THROUGH
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT BUT- I
DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARILY I
HAVE THAT DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS- ARE ARE NEEDED- OR
KIND OF A- NON CAP AND TRADE
RELATED POLICIES ARE
NECESSARILY NEEDED TO MEET THE
TWENTY THIRTY BILLS THERE'S
ALSO THE OPTION OF. A CHANGES
TO THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEN ON THANK YOU
MISTER BROWN. I LIKE TO MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT BIGGER- DANI COLIN
WARD HE IS THE POLICY DIRECTOR
AT CARBON PLAN A NONPROFIT
CLIMATE RESEARCH ORGANIZATION.
AND ALSO THE VICE CHAIR OF THE-
I IMAC. DR THANK YOU LORD.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN RICHARD THE
PLEASURE TO BE HERE THANK YOU
TO SENATOR BACKER AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AS WELL- I'M
GONNA TOUCH ON A COUPLE OF
ISSUES FOR THE AGENDA RELATED
TO CARBON REMOVAL AND THE
CONSTRUCTS OF CARBON
NEUTRALITY- BEFORE I TOUCH ON
THOSE MATTERS I WANT TO AFFIRM
EVERYTHING I HEARD FROM DOCTOR
BROWN- IN THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION- THE FACT THAT. I
THINK LET ME ACTUALLY EMPHASIZE
WHAT HE SAID AND GO A STEP
FURTHER IN IN MY PROFESSIONAL
OPINION I'M VERY CONFIDENT WE
ARE NOT ON TRACK TO THE TWENTY
THIRTY TARGET THEM YOU NEED TO
MAKE SUBSTANTIAL INCREASES IN
OUR POLICY AMBITION TO BRING
THAT ONLINE I THINK THAT'S
ENTIRELY TECHNICALLY FEASIBLE
IT ON THE COULD ANY CONCERNS
ABOUT OUR ABILITY TO DO THAT AT
THE CURRENT PACE OF PROGRESS
IT'S NOT IN LINE WITH WHERE WE
NEED TO GO. WE HAD A VERY GOOD
YEAR IN THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS
FROM THE CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN
WHICH IS THE MOST RECENT YEAR
COMMISSIONS WE CUT ABOUT SEVEN
MILLION TIMES THE MISSIONS WE
NEED TO ABOUT DOUBLE THAT RATE-
INSISTING THAT RATE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR FROM- INCLUDING
TWENTY TWENTY FORWARD IF WE'RE
GONNA HIT R. TWENTY THIRTY
TARGET. AND AS DR BROWN-
MENTIONED AND CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MENTIONED THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SCOPING PLAN CALLS ON CAPITATE
TO DELIVER ABOUT AFTER THE
RESULTS- BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY TO GET THAT JOB DONE IF
YOU LOOK AT THE CUMULATIVE
EFFORTS CARB FORECASTED IN ITS
LAST OPEN PLAN THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM IN THE SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANT
PROGRAMS ARE MEANT TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT THREE QUARTERS
OF A CUMULATIVE PRODUCTIONS- I
DON'T THINK WE'RE ON TRACK FOR
THAT AND AS DR BROWN TOLD YOU.
ALMOST ALL OF THE REDUCTIONS WE
OBSERVE TODAY HAVE BEEN IN THE
LECTURES THE SECTOR WHERE OTHER
REGULATORY AGENCIES AND
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN DRIVING
THOSE OUTCOMES WE CANNOT RELY
ON THOSE OUTCOMES AND OUR
CONTINUED POLICY GOALS TO
DECARBONIZE THE ELECTRICITY
GRID TO GET TO TWENTY THIRTY
LET ALONE. DEEPER TARGETS
AROUND CARBON NEUTRALITY. WITH
THAT- PRACTICE OF THE WAY I
WANTED TO A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
CARBON NEUTRALITY AND CONCEPT
OF CARBON NEUTRALITY- AND IT'S-
TO BE HONEST IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO TALK ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE IT INVOLVES. OFTEN A
LOT OF MAGICAL THINKING AND
MAGICAL THINKING AROUND ISSUES
THAT I THINK ARE HURTING.
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW AND I JUST
WANT TO TAKE NOTE OF THE FACT
THAT. YOU KNOW. PEOPLE JUST
EAST OF WHERE YOU ARE IN
ELDORADO COUNTY HER BY PULLING
FROM THEIR HOMES IS A MASSIVE
WILDFIRE HAS ERUPTED YET
ANOTHER. AND WE'RE HEADED INTO
RED FLAG CONDITIONS- THIS IS A
HUGE DEAL FOR. COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE IMPACTED BY FAR IT'S A HUGE
DEAL I'M PREPARING TO ROLL OUT
MY AIR PURIFIERS BECAUSE THE
ENTIRETY OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
IS ABOUT TO BE INUNDATED WITH
PARTICULAR MATTER AS THE WIND
SHIFTS- THIS IS A LIFE. RIGHT
NOW. AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO AND
TO THINK ABOUT TO GET TO CARBON
NEUTRALITY WHICH IS HOW WE STOP
ADDING PRESSURE TO MAKE THE
CLIMATE PROBLEM WORSE. INVOLVES
A LOT OF HARD WORK. AND OFTEN
INVOLVES PEOPLE MAKING HER
WROTE AND I'M JUSTIFIABLE
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO GET THE JOB DONE.
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
CARBON REMOVAL- I SAID THIS IS
SOMEBODY THINKS. REMOVED IS
GOING TO PLAY AN IMPORTANT.
PART OF OUR OVERALL STRATEGY IN
CALIFORNIA AND FRANKLY
EVERYWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD IF
WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM. BUT WE CANNOT INDULGE.
IN MAGICAL THINKING TO GET THE
JOB DONE. IT'S GOING TO TAKE
DIFFICULT WORK TO GET TO THE
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOAL
PARTICULARLY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE- I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
TECHNICAL WORK THAT SHOWS. HOW
TO MAKE THE KINDS OF
TRANSITIONS THAT ARE NEEDED.
HOW YOU WOULD DO THAT HOW YOU
WOULD IMPLEMENT THAT- I'M
ENCOURAGED THE CARD IS PLANNING
AND THINKING ABOUT THAT. AND
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT TALKING
ABOUT CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE WHEN WE ARE
NOT ON TRACK FOR A 40% CUT AND
REDUCTIONS LET ALONE SOMETHING
CLOSER TO A 100% NOT CUT. I'M
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE EXTENT
TO WHICH- PROMISES ABOUT THE
FUTURE ROLE OF CARBON REMOVAL
HAVE BEEN USED. IN CLIMATE
POLICY CONVERSATIONS. INCLUDING
THE PRIVATESECTOR TO DEFRAY
THE NEEDED ACTION THAT IS
NEEDED RIGHT NOW. AND I WANT TO
BE VERY VERY CLEAR AND RAISING
THESE CONCERNS I'M NOT SOMEBODY
WHO SAYS CARBON REMOVAL SHOULD
BE PART OF THE CONSIDERATION- I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART.
OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO. BUT IF
ONE WANTS TO BANK ON EXTENSIVE
CARBON REMOVAL AS A GET OUT OF
JAIL FREE CARD FOR REDUCING OUR
EMISSIONS. WE'RE SETTING
OURSELVES UP FOR SERIOUS
PROBLEMS- I THINK. IT'S REALLY
PART IN THESE CONVERSATIONS TO
TALK ABOUT CARBON REMOVAL
BECAUSE- IT MEANS SO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS TO DIFFERENT
PEOPLE- THE TYPICAL CATEGORIES
WE SEE BROKEN DOWN WHEN PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT CARBON REMOVAL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT ARE
CALLED. ENGINEERED SOLUTIONS
FOR YOU THINK ABOUT. CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE UNDERGROUND
GEOLOGIC INJECTION MAYBE YOU'RE
GONNA MINERALIZED CO TWO OUT OF
THE ATMOSPHERE THROUGH
CHEMISTRY- PEOPLE ALSO TALK
ABOUT NATURAL CLIMATE SOLUTIONS
ARE NATURAL CARBON REMOVAL-
WHERE WE TALK ABOUT FORESTS AND
SOILS SEQUESTER MORE CARBON.
THESE ARE VERY DIFFERENT
APPROACHES- AND THEY ALL HAVE
MAJOR RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH%
THEM THE RISKS ARE OFTEN
COMPLETELY DISTINCT. AND
REQUIRE VERY CAREFUL THOUGHT TO
NOT. TOO HARD ON THE WRONG
STRATEGY OR COMBINATION OF
STRATEGIES. ENGINEER CARNIVAL
IS VERY EASY TO MEASURE IT'S
VERY EASY TO BE CONFIDENT IN
THE OUTCOMES WHEN YOU BUILD A
FACILITY TO- CARBON DIOXIDE
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE THERE ARE
SOME DEMONSTRATION FACILITIES
THE DIFFERENCE. IT IS NOT HARD
TO MEASURE IT IS VERY HARD TO
GET COMFORTABLE WITH
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THESE TECHNOLOGIES. AND THE
INCUMBENT FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRIES- WHICH COULD
POTENTIALLY BE SUPPORTED AND
HAVE THEIR LIVES EXTENDED BY
THESE APPROACHES DEPLOYED IN A
CERTAIN WAY. AND WHICH COULD
ALSO SEE THESE TECHNOLOGIES
BECOME A SUSTAINABLE AND
EQUITABLE PATHWAY FOR HIGH
QUALITY JOBS TO BE MAINTAINED
IN THE LOCATIONS IN COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY ARE CURRENTLY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE FOSSIL
ENERGY SYSTEM. NATURAL CARBON
SOLUTIONS- ARE VERY EASY TO GET
COMFORTABLE WITH PEOPLE LOVE
FORESTS AND SOILS- IT'S
EXTREMELY HARD TO MEASURE
CARBON IN THE SYSTEMS IN FACT
IT'S NOT REALLY BEING DONE WELL
AT ALL WHEN IT COMES TO
AGRICULTURAL OR SOIL CARBON.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO FOREST
CARBON WE ARE MUCH BETTER AT
MEASURING IT WILL BE A VERY
VERY CHALLENGED BY OUR ABILITY
TO MAKE IT STAY PUT. AND ANYONE
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA KNOWS WHAT
THAT MEANS RIGHT NOW WITH THE
FIRE SEASONS WE HAVE THIS YEAR
AND LAST YEAR. THE WAY THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD HAS
MANAGE THESE ISSUES IN RELATED
FOREST CLIMATE POLICIES
INCLUDING A VERY PROMINENT ROLE
FOR EXPORT CARBON FOREST CARBON
OFFSETS. IS NOT AT ALL IN
KEEPING WITH THE SCIENTIFIC
UNDERSTANDING. OF THE THREAT OF
FIRE OR ECOLOGICAL SYSTEM
CHANGE TO FIRES FOR STARRING IN
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES. I
THINK IT'S GONNA BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET OUR HEADS
AROUND THESE THINGS EEN THOUGH
IT'S VERY EASY TO SAY. WE LIKE
TREES AND WE LIKE SOILS. AND
LIKE HEALTHY FARMING PRACTICES.
AND I ALL THE THINGS WE THESE
TWO DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO
CARBON REMOVAL HAVE THEIR OWN
UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND IF WE-
ASSUME WE ARE GOING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM. BY ANYONE OF THOSE
WORKING OUT AT A VERY LARGE
SCALE AND WE CHOOSE NOT TO TAKE
SIGNIFICANT ACTION TO INCREASE
OUR CLIMATE POLICY AMBITIONS.
WE WILL GET NOW CLOSE. TO
CARBON NEUTRALITY AND WE WILL
WASTE OPPORTUNITIES TO
MEANINGFULLY IMPROVE
CALIFORNIANS LIVES IN THE
INTERIM. I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TONE OF MY REMARKS BUT IT IS A
VERY DIFFICULT THING TO LOOK
FOR CLIMB THE PROBLEM SQUARE IN
THE EYE AND TO. ACKNOWLEDGE THE
GRAVITY OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
AND WHAT IS REQUIRED TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEMS BEFORE US. AND IT
IS DEEPLY FRUSTRATING AND-
PAINFUL TO. PARTICIPATE IN
CONVERSATIONS WHERE WE DO NOT
SPEAK HONESTLY ABOUT WHAT IS
REQUIRED. TO BEGIN TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS THAT ARE BEFORE US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND LOOK FOR THE ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THAT THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CALLING WORD. CENTER
SKINNER. SO DOCTOR CONGER YOU
APOLOGIZE FOR YOUR TOTAL BUT
YOU KNOW I DON'T I APPRECIATE
SOMEONE BEING FRANK HOWEVER.
WHAT I. THE ENORMITY THE
GRAVITY OF THE CRISIS YOU ARE
BEING VERY FRANK ABOUT THE
THEIR REALITY IN THE NECESSITY
FOR THE TRANSITION OFF FOSSIL
FUELS AS FAST AS WE CAN. FRANK
HOWEVER I FEEL LIKE THE
DISCUSSION AROUND THE CAPTURE
OR THE SEQUESTRATION WITHIN.
THE NATURAL SYSTEMS. YOU KNOW I
GUESS I FEEL IT'S. I FELT YOUR
VET CAVALIER BECAUSE I IN NO
WAY WANT TO DIMINISH. THE
ESSENTIAL OF THE OTHER AND DO
NOT WANT A DIRECTION OR
INACTION TOWARDS ANYTHING
WITHIN OUR NATURAL ECOSYSTEMS
TO BY ANY MEANS REPLACE OR TO
BE THE DOMINANT STRATEGY.
HOWEVER I. EIGHT I. D. I GUESS
I QUESTION YOUR DESCRIPTION
THAT THE SCIENCE AROUND THE
CAPACITY OF BIOLOGICAL.
PROSTHESES TO IT HAS THAT'S
INEFFECTIVE WE LOOK AT THE
CARBON CYCLE THAT'S WHAT THE
CARBON CYCLE IS AND WHILE WE
MAY NOT HAVE GOOD MEASURING
TOOLS AND I AGREE WITH THAT AND
CLEARLY AS OUR FORESTS BURNED
OBVIOUSLY RELYING ON OUR
FORESTS TO BE OUR CARBON
CAPTURE IS INADEQUATE BUT THE
CAPACITY OF. MICROORGANISMS
WITHIN A VARIETY OF ECOSYSTEMS
IS STRONG AND THERE ARE OTHER
BENEFICIAL. OF BENEFITS TO THAT
SO I GUESS. I WONDER IF YOUR
ARE YOU BEING ASKED IN MY WORDS
CAVALIER BECAUSE YOU'RE AFRAID
THAT THAT THAT WE WOULD GO IN
THAT DIRECTION AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE FOSTER REDUCTIONS OR
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME SIGNS
THAT I'M NOT SEEN. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK FRANKLY- I THINK THE
NATURE OF MY CONCERN IS
PRIMARILY ONE THAT DEPENDING ON
HOW WE SET UP OUR POLICY
TARGETS WE COULD SUBSTITUTE.
AWAY FROM DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS BY ASSUMING WE WILL
DELIVER LARGE VOLUMES OF CARBON
REMOVAL THAT TURNS OUT NOT TO
BE POSSIBLE IN THE WAYS WE HAD
HOPED AN ANTICIPATED SO I DO
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT CONCERN
AND I HEAR YOU SAYING THAT IT'S
NOT FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU ARE
ADVOCATING FOR- AND I DIDN'T
MEAN TO SUGGEST OTHERWISE. HOW
WE DEFINE CARBON NEUTRALITY AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE REQUIRE A
MINIMUM DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTION SPEAKS DIRECTLY TO
THAT QUESTION AND ON THAT ISSUE
I THINK. THE SCIENCE STRONGLY
COUNSELS BEING RISK AVERSE ON
THESE ISSUES AND BEING
THOUGHTFUL AND CONSIDERATE
ABOUT PUSHING FIRST AND
FOREMOST ON DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS AND I SAID THIS IS
SOMEBODY WHO THINKS CARBON
REMOVAL HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE
TO PLAY AND I DON'T WANT TO
DIMINISH- THE MOTIVATIONS THAT-
THAT HAD EVEN OTHERS BRING TO
THAT CONVERSATION. YOU
UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE SIDE
ACTUALLY THE SCIENCE IS
INCREASINGLY CLEAR THAT THE
RISKS FROM FIRE AND DROUGHT TO
THE PROMINENCE OF FOREST NOT
THE ABILITY OF TREES THE UPTAKE
CARBON BUT THE ABILITY OF
ECOSYSTEMS TO SUSTAIN IN THE
FACE OF THE ECOLOGICAL CHANGE
WE ARE OBSERVING WHICH IS
ACCELERATING RAPIDLY. IT'S
INCREASINGLY CLEAR THERE ARE
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
NOT GOING TO HAVE FOREST BY THE
END OF THE CENTURY THAT
HISTORICALLY THROUGHOUT ALL OF
OUR LIVES TO THE MEMORIES OF
THE FAMILIES WHO MOVED HERE
BEFORE. I'M OUT FOR US I THINK
THAT'S ACTUALLY INCREASINGLY
CLEAR AS A SCIENTIFIC FACT THAT
IT'S VERY LIKELY TO HAPPEN SOME
AREAS THE PRESSURES FROM THE
CLIMATE SYSTEM ON THE
FUNDAMENTAL DRIVERS OF FIRE
RISK ARE INCREASING RAPIDLY AS
THE CONCERN HERE IS NOT WHETHER
NOT TREES UP TO CARMEN. IT'S
HOW STABLE ARE OUR CURRENT
LANDSCAPE PATTERNS AND THE WAY
WE MANAGE THOSE LANDS ARE THE
TRADE OFFS BETWEEN TRYING TO
MANAGE FOR CARBON AND MANAGING
FOR FIRE. AND IF WE PUT ALL OUR
EGGS IN THE FOREST CARBON
BASKET AND WE DO SO IN A WAY
THAT SUBSTITUTES. AWAY FROM
DIRECT EMISSION REDUCTIONS THAT
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING AVOID.
EVEN THOUGH I WHICH- AND WHO.
WANTS TO CAREFULLY LOOK AT
POTENTIAL INCLUDING THE CURRENT
RISKS. WITH NATURAL CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS I'M LOOKING AT WHAT
WE CAN DO ON THAT FRONT.
WITHOUT CLOSING OUR EYES TO. BE
CLIMATE RISKS THAT ARE VERY
MUCH IN FRONT OF US. FREESHEET
CLARIFICATION THOUGH I DON'T
THINK IT NECESSARILY ANSWER THE
QUESTION IT REINFORCED THAT YOU
DON'T WANT US WHICH I AGREE
WITH TO RELY. NOT ONLY DOMINANT
LEAD BUT EVEN WHATEVER TO HAVE
ANY ILLUSION ABOUT. THE
NECESSITY FOR THE ACTUAL
REDUCTIONS- MEANING DIRECT
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS NOW
HOWEVER I THINK THAT THE
SCIENCE ON. THE CAPACITY OF THE
CARBON CYCLE TO IF WE WERE-
RESPECTING IT. GREATER THE
CAPACITY FOR IT TO KEEP TO
STORE CARBON IS STILL HIGH.
THANKING CENTER BACKER. THANK
YOU I GUESS. I'M MOVE AWAY FROM
EITHER OR FROM AN EXTERNAL
DON'T AS TO CENTER SKITTISH
POINTED DIMINISH THE ABILITY OF
AN ACTUAL WORKING LANDS TO
SEQUESTER CARBON BUT- THIS CALL
WOULD YOU BEEN OUTSPOKEN ABOUT
THE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
OFFSETS WE'RE GRANTING. THAT
REALLY HAVE A CLIMATE BENEFIT
EQUIVALENT TO ALLOWING. POWER
PLANT OR FACTORY TO MEET AN
EXTRA. TEN OF CO TWO RIGHT
OTHERWISE WERE ALLOWING. EXTRA
POLLUTION WITHOUT TRULY GETTING
OFFSETTING. THE BENEFITS SO CAN
YOU ELABORATE ON SOME
SITUATIONS IN WHICH- YOU ARE
CONCERNED THESE OFFSETS ARE
NOT. MEETING THAT STANDARD
WE'RE GETTING A OFFSETTING
BENEFITS. SURE I'LL BE HAPPY TO
AND I WANT TO- BEFORE I DO THAT
JUST MENTIONED THAT THE FRAMING
OF CARBON OFFSETS FOR YOU ALLOW
A POLLUTER TO CONTINUE
POLLUTING IN RETURN FOR A
PROMISE OF A REDUCTION ST IN A
FOREST SYSTEM. IS THE OPPOSITE
OF WHAT I HEARD SENATOR SKINNER
ADVOCATE FOR WHAT WE'RE YOU'RE
PURSUING IDEALLY BOTH
STRATEGIES AT THE SAME TIME
THIS IS AN EITHER OR SITUATION
AND I THINK THAT'S THE CRUX OF
THE PROBLEM. WITH THE OFFSETS
PROGRAM TODAY THERE ARE A
COUPLE DIFFERENT PROBLEMS IN
THE OFFSETS PROGRAM I THINK
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF- I THINK
VERY IMPORTANT INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISM THAT IS DOCUMENTED
SCENARIOS WHERE PEOPLE ARE
CLAIMING CREDIT FOR BUSINESS AS
USUAL ACTIVITIES. SO THEY'RE
DOING THE SAME THINGS THEY WERE
PLANNING TO DO THEY'RE NOW
CLAIMING THAT THE THING THAT
THEY WERE ALWAYS DOING IS A NEW
CHANGE AND THEREFORE JUSTIFIES
CREDITS THAT ALLOW FOR EXAMPLE
A STATIONARY SOURCE REFINERY OF
POWER PLANT TO INCREASE OR
MAINTAIN ITS EMISSIONS. SO THIS
PROBLEM OF NONTRADITIONAL
CREDITING I THINK WHEN WE LOOK
REALLY CAREFULLY THE SYSTEM TO
FIND A LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT
THAT PEOPLE ARE DOING BUSINESS
AS USUAL ACTIVITIES AND
CLAIMING THAT SOMETHING NEW- I
WAS INVOLVED IN ON A LARGE
SCALE STUDY THAT LOOKED AT
ANOTHER QUESTION WHERE THE
FUNDAMENTAL ACCOUNTING
MECHANISMS BY WHICH- THE
CREDITS ARE AWARDED IT
CALIFORNIA'S CARBON OFFSETS
SYSTEM. HI MY COLLEAGUES AND I
THINK ARE INFLATING THE STATED
CLIMATE REDUCTIONS BY ABOUT 30%
FROM WHAT WE COULD SEE WITH
WHETHER IT TO THE BEST OF MY
KNOWLEDGE AS THE FIRST
INDEPENDENT AUDIT OF THE ENTIRE
PROGRAM- WE ARE ALSO SEEING
RIGHT NOW I THINK A CRISIS-
STARTED IN A MOST VISIBLY LAST
YEAR BUT IT'S BEEN AN ISSUE IN
THE PROGRAM FOR SOME TIME
WHERE. THE PREVALENCE OF FOREST
FIRES IS RENDERING THAT
PROMINENCE CLAIMS THAT THESE
OFFSET PROJECTS ARE MAKING THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO PROTECT AND
STORE THE CARBON IN THE TREES.
FOR AT LEAST A HUNDRED YEARS.
I'M THAT IS NOT LOOKING LIKE A
VERY SAFE THAT. I'M WE HAD A
COUPLE OF FIRE IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. THE LIKE FIRE IN
SOUTHERN OREGON VERY
PROMINENTLY HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTING A LARGE
PROJECT- CALLED PLYMOUTH EAST
AND WE HAVE RIGHT NOW AN
UNCONTROLLED FIRE BURNING IN
ONE OF THE LARGEST PROJECTS.
THE OFFSETS PROGRAM UP EASTERN
WASHINGTON THE COCOA PROJECT-
THE SCALE OF THE CARBON LOSSES
THAT WE EXPECT FROM THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY ON
FIRE AND IT RECENTLY BEEN ON
FIRE ARE NOT AT ALL CONSISTENT.
WITH THE PROTECTIONS THAT THE
PROGRAM IS ANTICIPATED- FOR
MAKING SURE THAT THE OVERALL
INTEGRITY THE PROGRAM DELIVERS
THOSE REAL CLIMATE BENEFITS.
AND IT'S ALSO PRETTY CLEAR AT
THIS POINT THAT THE PROGRAM IS
NOT DESIGNED WITH EITHER
CLIMATE RISKS IN MIND OR EVEN
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE FACT
THAT. WESTERN FORESTS ARE MUCH
MORE FIRE PRONE EASTERN FORESTS
EVERYBODY FACES THE SAME SORT
OF INSURANCE RISK PREMIUM.
WHETHER THEY'RE LOCATED IN AN
AREA THE PARENTS REGULARLY AND
WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY KERN- AS
AREAS OF EASTERN WASHINGTON
SOUTHERN OREGON AND PARTS OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WILL IN OUR
LIFETIMES. OR WHETHER THEY'RE
LOCATED IN A IN A FAIRLY FIRE
SAFE PLACE LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
UPSTATE NEW YORK. OR VERMONT SO
MR JUST THREE WISHES I COULD GO
ON BUT I THINK THE OFFSETS
PROGRAM IS AN EXAMPLE OF AN
AREA WHERE WE HAVE-
COLLECTIVELY. IN THE STATE
EMPHASIZED. OUR FOR CLAIMING
CLIMATE BENEFITS IN FORESTS AND
THE SO CALLED NATURAL CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE DIVERTED
ATTENTION AWAY FROM DIRECT
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. THAT IS
NOT THE ONLY WAY WE CAN PURSUE.
ACTIVITIES IN THAT SPACE BUT IT
IS THE WAY WE HAVE INVESTED
SEVERAL BILLION DOLLARS SO FAR.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES-
DOCTOR CONGER THANK YOU- FOR
YOUR FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE THE INTENSITY- IN
YOUR IN YOUR VOICE- AND I AND I
KNOW IT CAN BE INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATING- THE AS AS WE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE ALL OF THIS
OUT AFFECT IF IT'S OKAY- TO
REPEAT SOMETHING IT SENATORS
SKINNER SAID EARLIER TALKING
ABOUT THAT SHE'D BEEN WORKING
ON THIS- BEEN ALMOST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS SINCE. SHE WAS EIGHT
THAT KYOTO I KNOW IT'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO WORK ON THIS FOR A
VERY VERY LONG TIME AND EVEN
THOUGH I HEAR THE INTENSITY IN
YOUR VOICE- I DIDN'T HEAR A
WHOLE LOT OF HOPE AND SO MAYBE
I'M I'M I'M I'M WISHING THAT
YOU WOULD PROVIDE MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT OF HOPE- AND I WANT
TO COME BACK TO THAT AND HAVE
YOU ADDRESS IT. BUT WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT DIRECT EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT AS A
MEMBER BURKE WAS SAYING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EQUITY THE FOLKS
THAT LIVE IN IN MY DISTRICT IN-
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE ASSEMBLY
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND THEY
CAN AFFORD TO LIVE THERE THEY
CAN AFFORD TO BUY HOMES THERE
BUT FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD. A TO BUY HOMES THERE
THEY HAVE TO GET IN THEIR CAR-
WHICH ARE POLLUTERS A TO BE
ABLE TO DRIVE INTO SAN DIEGO
THE ORANGE COUNTY AND LA WHERE
THEY WORK THEY CAN AFFORD TO
LIVE IN THOSE COUNTIES SO THEY
LIVE IN A MY TO COUNTIES AND
THEN GET IN THEIR CAR AND THEY
DRIVE A TWO TWO AND A HALF
HOURS EVERY SINGLE DAY. A TO BE
ABLE TO WORK AND THEY'RE
POLLUTING THERE'S A COST FOR
THAT THEY'VE MOVED OUT BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE IN
THOSE IN THOSE OTHER COUNTIES
AND SO THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE
OF GETTING IN THEIR CAR AND
THEIR- PUTTING GAS IN THEIR
VEHICLES- AND THEY ARE
POLLUTING BY DRIVING INTO
THESE- IN THESE OTHER COUNTIES
THIS IS THE QUESTION OF. OF
EQUITY THAT COMES UP SO WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE DIRECT
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS A WHAT I
HEAR IN THAT IS THAT IT'S GOING
TO COST THE PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT MORE MONEY TO BE ABLE
TO SURVIVE TO BE ABLE TO LIVE.
SOME OF US HAVE SOME HOPE WHEN
WE HEAR OF FROM- THE- THERE'S
TWO COMPANIES THAT I KNOW
BECAUSE- WORKS AND CARBON
ENGINEERING- THAT ARE. I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON A DIRECT AIR
CAPTURE- THE TECHNOLOGY MAYBE
ISN'T. NECESSARILY THERE YET
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE. THEY'RE ABLE
TO SUCK STUFF OUT OF THE AREA
BE ABLE TO REDUCE- OF THE
CARBON IN IN THE ATMOSPHERE AND
I THINK TO MYSELF. WHY ARE WE
SPENDING AS MUCH MONEY AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN IN TRYING TO SUCK
THE CARBON DIRECTLY. OUT OF THE
ATMOSPHERE BUT YOU ADDRESSED
THAT A LITTLE BIT IN YOUR
OPENING. A SUGGESTING THAT
MAYBE THAT MIGHT BE OF A FAIRY
TALE IF I HEARD YOU CORRECTLY
THAT MIGHT THAT MIGHT BE. A
FAIRY TALE OF THAT WE. BE ABLE.
AND TO THINK THAT WAS. THE
ANSWER SO I GUESS THE ONE. IS
IS THE HOPE. WHAT WE DO HAVE WE
HAVE A- ECONOMY AT THE SAME
TIME. A RETREAT. THIS NEGATIVE
EXTERNALITY- AND- AND SOLVE
THIS CRISIS. I THINK THAT THE
FIRST ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IS
BY HAVING AN HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON THAT INCLUDES THE EQUITY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
GEOGRAPHIC CONSIDERATIONS THAT.
THAT I HEARD FROM BOTH YOU. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE- TWO
THINGS TO SAY. ONE I'M ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY ON THE VERY OPTIMISTIC
SIDE OF THE DIRECTOR CAPTURE
SPECTRUM. I THINK THERE'S SOME
REALLY INTERESTING STUFF GOING
ON AND IT COULD POTENTIALLY BE
A SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE WAY
WE TACKLE THESE PROBLEMS- YOU
ARE NOT. I DON'T THINK GOING TO
BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN. THE
CURRENT. STATUS AND STRUCTURE
OF HOW. WE DRIVE CARS AND THE
KINDS OF CARS WE DRIVE IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE IN THE LONG RUN- SO
DIRECTOR CAPTURES IN THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT WE
HAVE TO COME UP WITH THE FOUR
DOUBLE AN EQUITABLE SOLUTIONS
BOTH TO HOUSING AND THE
TRANSPORTATION COSTS THAT YOU
SITE. BUT IT COULD BE A BIG
PART OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO.
THE PROBLEM IS YOU HAVE LIKE
TWO DEMONSTRATION FACILITIES IN
ICELAND RIGHT NOW AND MOST OF
THE DEPLOYMENT THAT IS BEING
CONSIDERED. TO TEST THESE
SYSTEMS AT SCALE. IS ABOUT
PRODUCING MORE OIL AND GAS
RATHER THAN DIRECTLY
SEQUESTERING CO TWO AN
UNDERGROUND STORAGE RESERVOIRS
MOUNTED ON THE GAS PRODUCTION
PURPOSE. SO I COULDN'T BE MORE
OPTIMISTIC WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH COMPANIES. THAT ARE
THINKING ABOUT INVESTING IN
THESE ISSUES. AND WORKING
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE COMPANIES
YOU MENTIONED THERE'S A LOT OF
GOOD STUFF HAPPENING- THAT IS
NOT AN ANSWER. TO THE QUESTION
OF HOW WE HANDLE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR EMISSIONS. SO IN LAST
FOR OTHER ISSUES OKAY. AGAIN
THE BIG EXASPERATION HEARING IS
IF WE INDULGE IN FANTASY
THINKING WE WILL SCREW THIS UP.
BUT I HOPE SENATOR SKINNER
REMEMBER ME WHICH SHE BEGAN.
HER INNOVATIVE ADVOCACY. WELL
BEFORE HER TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE. I THINK ANYBODY
THOUGHT RENEWABLES ARE GOING TO
BE AS CHEAP AS THEY ARE. IT IS
REMARKABLE HOW QUICKLY THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR HAS STARTED
TO MOVE. ON RENEWABLE ENERGY
AND I THINK STORAGE. AND THE
PACE OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INNOVATION IS JUST OUT OF
CONTROL IN A POSITIVE WAY THAT-
MY GREAT HOPE IS THAT. IN A FEW
YEARS WE WILL BE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT. WHETHER OR
NOT THERE ARE EFFORT. YOUR COST
BARRIERS FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
LIVING FAR AWAY FROM CENTERS TO
DOCTOR. THE BE SHORT. IN OUR-
TO GET ENOUGH KERR TO PEOPLE AS
QUICKLY AS THEY WANT THEM-
THAT'S HOPE. AND I AM REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE ELECTRICITY
SYSTEM AND THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM IN THE MEDIUM TERM. WHAT
I'M WORRIED ABOUT IS. TALKING
ABOUT. THE IDEA THAT WE ARE ON
TRACK FOR CUTTING OR POLLUTION
BY 40% IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS
WITHOUT STEPPING UP THE PACE OF
MEDICATION POLICIES- AND I'M
I'M WORRIED IF WE DON'T HAVE
HONEST CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THESE THINGS. WE WON'T BE ABLE
TO BALANCE THE EQUITY AND
GEOGRAPHIC CONSIDERATIONS THAT
HAVE TO BE A PART OF THIS LONG
TERM THINKING. SO PLEASED TO
HEAR ME AS SOMEBODY WHO IS
DEEPLY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT SOME
<c.green>ASES OF THOSE. ALSO SO</c>
INCREDIBLY CONCERNED ABOUT. THE
MAGICAL THINKING THAT I SEE- IN
MANY CONVERSATIONS NOT
EXCLUSIVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
POLICY SITUATION BUT DEFINITELY
PRESENT HERE AS WELL.
GENERALITY I LOVE TO GET YOUR
PERSONAL THINGS AGAIN I I'VE
GOTTEN A CHANCE TO HEAR YOUR
THOUGHTS AS THEY'VE EVOLVED
OVER THE YEARS AND I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE YOUR CANDOR AND- AND
REAL TALK- I LOVE TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS. ON THE- EVER EVOLVING
DISCUSSION OVER THE EXTENT TO
WHICH WE REALLY- DOUBLE DOWN ON
ELECTRIFICATION VERSUS OTHER
ALTERNATIVE FUELS AND THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY A BIG BATTLE THAT
THAT TAKES PLACE HERE- YOU KNOW
MONKS AMONGST PEOPLE WHO ARE
PUSHING FOR EVERYTHING FROM
HYDROGEN TO. NATURAL GAS AND
IT'S AFTER. SENATOR ARE YOU
ASKING WITH RESPECT TO THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
ADVERTISING SECTOR I'M SORRY. I
THINK THERE ARE OTHERS WHO ARE
PROBABLY. HAVE DEEPER EXPERTISE
ON THIS ISSUE WHEN I TO WHO ARE
SERIOUS EXPERT IN THE SPACE. I
DON'T. MUCH INTO THE FOR NOW
ELECT STRATEGY IN THE DUTY ARE
AND I HEAR A ROBE DEBATE. FOR
HAVING VEHICLE BEEN TRY SPACE
AND- I AM NOT ENOUGH OF THE
EXPERT TO SAVE YOU. I'M TO PUT
MY FINGER IN THE AIR ANSWERED
GASSET THAT'S ALL GOING TO GO
THE FALLING COST OF BATTERIES
AND THE RAPID TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATIONS THAT SPACE HAS
OPENED UP POSSIBILITIES THAT
SEEMED. LESS LIKELY A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO- I'M ALSO WATCHING
CAREFULLY I THINK. YOU KNOW IF
WE WATCH CAREFULLY
CONVERSATIONS IN EUROPE AND THE
UNITED KINGDOM FOCUS MORE ON
HYDROGEN IN VARIOUS PARTS OF
THE LONG TERM DECARBONISATION
BY THAN WE HAVE THUS FAR TALKED
ABOUT IN CALIFORNIA- I TRY TO
BE AGNOSTIC ABOUT THESE THINGS
BUT- THE- MAIN MESSAGE I'M
HEARING FROM COLLEAGUES WHO.
CONCENTRATE ON THE CERES THAT
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES THE CARS
AND TRUCKS THAT REGULAR PEOPLE
DRIVE. THE ELECTRIC DRIVE TRAIN
IS WHERE THE ACTION IS GOING TO
BE THERE. AND WHEN YOU MOVE
INTO THE HAVE YOUR TUTOR DUTY
VEHICLES THERE ARE. ROBUST
DEBATES ABOUT THE EXACT PATH
FORWARD. BUT WHEN YOU SEE CRAZY
THINGS LIKE PEOPLE FIGURED OUT
HOW TO ELECTRIFY YOU KNOW. LIKE
SHIPPING BARGES LIKE SOME OF
THE BARGE BASED TRANSPORTATION
ON THE OCEANS LIKE PEOPLE ARE
ELECTRIFYING THINGS THAT. DID
NOT SEEM POSSIBLE SEVERAL YEARS
AGO AND IT'S JUST IT'S
FASCINATING TO WATCH. THE
DEGREE TO WHICH GIVE LIKE- YOU
YOU COULD TURN THAT INTO AN
ELECTRIC APPLICATIONS WELL THAT
SEEMS TO BE PLAYING OUT IN
PLACES. TEN YEARS AGO I NEVER
WOULD HAVE IMAGINED. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DR COLIN WARD. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. LAST BIGGER ON THIS
PANEL IS- DR MEREDITH VALLEY
SHE IS AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR
AT UC BERKELEY- FIRST VALLEY.
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
YES THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION I AM A UC BERKELEY
ECONOMIST HYMAN DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE RESOURCE ECONOMICS
AND FACULTY DIRECTOR OF THE
ENERGY IS CHEATED HAAS SO MY
EXPERTISE- THIS IS RELATIVELY
NARROW- LOOKING AT- THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
REGULATION OF ENERGY MARKETS.
AND GIVEN THE URGENCY OF THE
CLIMATE CHANGE PROBLEM I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT TODAY'S SESSION
IS NOT ASKING WHETHER
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ACT BUT WHAT
PATH TO TAKE WHICH POLICY
LEVERS TO PULL. AND HOW SWIFTLY
TO MOVE THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY ONTO A MORE
SUSTAINABLE PATH. IT'S LATE AND
I KNOW I'VE MY TIME IS LIMITED
SO I'M JUST GOING TO TRY AND
MAKE THREE POINTS ALL STATE
THEM UP FRONT AND THEN. EXPAND
AS TIME PERMITS SO THE FIRST
POINT IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S NET
ZERO GOAL IS A MEANS TO AN END
NOT AN END TO ITSELF AND I KNOW
WHO THE COMMITTEE APPRECIATE
FAST BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KEEP IN MIND THAT OUR
GUIDING PRINCIPLE. SHOULD BE TO
INNOVATE AND DEMONSTRATE-
TECHNOLOGY THE POLICIES THAT
CAN BE EXPORTED TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PROJECTED TO FUTURE
GREENHOUSE GASES ARE ARE
EXPECTED TO HAPPEN. MY SECOND
POINT IS THAT IT'S NOT JUST
WHAT WE DO BUT HOW WE DO IT
THAT MATTERS SO IN PARTICULAR
IF WE WANT TO ENSURE A CLEAN
ENERGY TRANSITION THAT
EQUITABLE AND AFFORDABLE. WE
NEED INNOVATION ACROSS THE
BOARDS OF COURSE WE NEED NEW
TECHNOLOGIES WE NEED
INFRASTRUCTURE MODERNIZATION
BUT IT'S ALSO GOING TO REQUIRE
REINVENTING THE INSTITUTIONAL
AND REGULATORY STRUCTURES. THAT
GUIDE WHICH INVESTMENTS WE MAKE
HOW WE PAY FOR THEM AND WHO
ULTIMATELY PAYS THE PRICE. AND
FINALLY- AND THIS IS PICKING UP
ANYTHING THAT'S COME UP ALREADY
THERE'S A TEMPTATION TO MANDATE
OUR WAY TO THE ZERO CARBON- AND
THIS COULD UNDERMINE- THE ROLE
OF CALIFORNIA'S CARBON MARKET
IN THE COST EFFECTIVENESS IT
BRINGS WE DON'T KNOW THE PATH
FROM HERE TO THERE. THAT'S
GOING TO DEPEND ON INNOVATION
AND TO BE DETERMINED ADVANCES
AND SO AN IMPORTANT ADVANTAGE
OF A CARBON MARKET IS IT
PROVIDES A WAY TO INCENTIVIZE
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE-
MEASURES WITHOUT REALLY KNOWING
WHERE OR- HOW THEY CAN THAT.
THEY. CAN MANIFEST OR CAN BE
FOUND. SO FIRST POINT. IN THE
PROJECTIONS ARE THAT GLOBAL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS ARE
GOING TO REACH SIXTY FIVE GIGA
TONNES UNDER BUSINESS AS USUAL
BY TWENTY THIRTY. OUR
CALIFORNIA INVENTORY IS
ESTIMATING TWENTY NINETEEN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AT
JUST OVER POINT FOUR GIGA TONS
SO. EVEN IF WE ZERO OUT OUR
CALIFORNIA EMISSIONS WOULD
REDUCE PROJECTED GLOBAL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY.
POINT SEVEN PERCENT. AND THIS
IS NOT TO SUGGEST THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DECARBONIZATION
EFFORTS ARE FEW TILE BUT RATHER
TO UNDERSCORE THE FACT. THAT
THE REASON WE'RE HERE TODAY IS
TO MOVE THE GLOBAL BALL
FORWARD. NEVER GOING TO MAKE A
DENT IN THE CLIMATE CHANGE
PROBLEM IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
THROUGH LEADERSHIP AND
DEMONSTRATING THE MOST
PROMISING CLIMATE SOLUTIONS. SO
THIS IS TRUE FOR TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION AND MANY FIRMS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE WELL. POSITIONED
TO CAPITALIZE ON THAT SO IN
THAT RESPECT I THINK INCENTIVES
ARE RELATIVELY WELL ALIGNED.
BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE FOR POLICY
INNOVATION. AND I THINK IN SOME
CASES THERE WILL BE TENSIONS
BETWEEN THE PURSUIT A VERY
AMBITIOUS STATE LEVEL TARGETS.
AND FOCUSED EFFORTS TO CRAFTING
DEMONSTRATE MODELS THEY CAN BE
EXPORTED ELSEWHERE AND SO WHEN
THAT WHERE THOSE TENSIONS ARISE
I HOPE WE PRIORITIZE THE
LATTER. I ALSO WANT TO PICK UP
ON AN IMPORTANT POINT THAT ROSS
BROWN MADE- IF WE WANT TO
MAXIMIZE THE GLOBAL IMPACT OF
OUR CLIMATE POLICY INNOVATION.
WE SHOULD BE DOING MORE TO
EXTRACT UNDERSTAND LESSONS THAT
WE'RE LEARNING BY DOING SO
OTHERS CAN FOLLOW- SO ROSS
BROWN MADE REALLY ARTICULATE
ARGUMENTS ALONG THOSE LINES I
WANT TO ALSO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE FACT THAT
THERE'S PRECEDENT FOR DOING
THIS DELIBERATELY AND
EFFECTIVELY. SO QUICK EXAMPLE
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE
FEDERAL RECOVERY ACT INCLUDED
BILLIONS. IN MATCHING FUNDS TO
ACCELERATES MARKET INVESTMENTS.
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS PRESENTED
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY LEARN
ABOUT WHAT INVESTMENTS WORK IN
WHICH FALL SHORT. THEY DO YOU
REQUIRED GRANT RECIPIENTS
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT PROGRAM
ABOUT AERATION PLANS THAT MET
PREDETERMINED CRITERIA. SO I
WAS FORTUNATE TO WORK WITH
SMART ON THERE FROM INTO SMART
GRID ELECT PRICE PROGRAM. AND
THAT'S ABA. TO THINK ABOUT
EVALUATION AS WE DESIGNED THE
PROGRAMS MEANT THAT ONCE THE
PROGRAMS ARE UP AND RUNNING WE
HAD WHAT WE NEEDED TO
RIGOROUSLY STUDY WHAT WAS
WORKING AND WHAT WAS FALLING
SHORT OF EXPECTATIONS. AND
FINDINGS FROM THOSE STUDIES
HAVE SINCE INFORMED AND SHAPED
CQC'S DECISIONS INCLUDING SOME
RECENT DECISIONS WHICH WILL
REDUCE THE COST OF INTEGRATING
HIGHER LEVELS OF RENEWABLE
GENERATION. SO I SOME I THINK
THAT CALIFORNIA'S POLICY
EXPERIMENTATION CAN HAVE A
GLOBAL IMPACT BUT TO REALIZE
THAT POTENTIAL WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON EXPORTABLE SOLUTIONS. AND
IDEALLY INVEST MORE IN
UNDERSTANDING HOW THIS
EXPERIMENTATION IS WORKING. THE
SECOND POINT I WANT TO MAKE I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
IF WE TAKE ONE AWAY FROM HIM
FROM THE CENTER AND THINGS COME
UP THAT I HOPE WITH THIS ONE.
IT'S ABOUT THE NEED FOR ENERGY
SECTOR REFORM SO IT'S REALLY
EXCITING TO THINK ABOUT THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES WE CAN DEPLOY. AND
THE STEPS WE CAN TAKE TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE SOMEWHAT LESS
EXCITING WESTERN ECONOMIST- BUT
NO LESS IMPORTANT IS TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE PAY FOR ALL THIS.
SO HOW WE FUND OUR CLIMATE
AMBITION IS GOING TO DETERMINE
WHAT IT COST AND WHO PAYS THE
PRICE. AND TO ELUCIDATE THIS
POINT I WANT TO DRAW FROM SOME
WORK I'M DOING WITH AND ENERGY
INSTITUTE COLLEAGUES THAT
INVESTIGATES WHY CALIFORNIA'S
REGULATED RETAIL ELECTRICITY
PRICES. SO THE PRICE WE ALL PAY
PER KILOWATT HOUR FOR
ELECTRICITY FROM THE GRID. OUR
HIGH AND INCREASINGLY ALIGNED
WITH THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
HAS THE ANSWERS HAVE IMPORTANT
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
CONVERSATION WE'RE HAVING TODAY.
SO IF ECONOMY WITH OR DOES
ELECTRO PRICES. I WOULD SET THE
PRICE PER KILOWATT HOUR TO
REFLECT THE MARGINAL SOCIAL
COST OF CONSUMING ELECTRICITY
SO WHEN I RUN MY DISHWASHER AND
CONSUME A KILOWATT HOUR OF
ELECTRICITY. THE PRICE TO
REFLECT THE COST OF THE FUEL
AND THE CLIMATE COST OF THAT
INCREMENTAL CONSUMPTION. BUT
WHAT WE'RE SHOWING IN OUR WORK
IS THAT THE MARGINAL SOCIAL
COST IS ARE EFFICIENT PRICE
BENCHMARK FOR ELECTRICITY IF
YOU WELL. HAS BEEN DECLINING IN
CALIFORNIA HAS OUR GREAT GETS
CLEANER SO WE'RE ESTIMATING
THAT IN TWENTY NINETEEN. THIS
EFFICIENT PRICES ABOUT EIGHT TO
TEN CENTS PER KILOWATT HOUR.
BUT THE RETAIL PRICES WERE
PAYING ARE MUCH HIGHER SO IN MY
TERRITORY. MOST CUSTOMERS PAY
ABOUT THREE TIMES THAT. LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS WHO QUALIFY
FOR THE CARE RATE HE TWO TIMES
THAT EFFICIENT PRICE. AND THE
REASON WE'RE PAYING AND
EFFICIENTLY HYLEK CHRISTY
PRICES. IF CALIFORNIA HAS A
PRACTICE OF. SB CONSUMPTION TO
THE REVENUES WE REALLY NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AND
GRID MODERNIZATION AND WILDFIRE
ADAPTATION. AND ROOFTOP SOLAR
SUBSIDIES THE LIST GOES ON. WE
HAVE A LOT OF THESE EXPENSES.
PARTLY PREVENT MITIGATE CLIMATE
CHANGE. PARTLY BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO ADAPT TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. THESE COSTS ARE ONLY
GOING TO ESCALATE. AND SO
HERE'S MY KEY POINT RECOVERING
THESE COSTS IN ELECTRICITY
RATES TAXING ELECTRICITY
CONSUMPTION IS PROBLEMATIC FOR
TWO REASONS. ONE AS WE'VE
DISCUSSED ELECTRIFICATION IS A
KEY TO THE DECARBONISATION. HI
ELECTRICITY PRICES ARE GONNA
SLOW PROGRESS ON
ELECTRIFICATION. SO IN CARP
SCOPES OUT THAT WE NEED X.
PERCENT OF ELECTRIC CARS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. WE NEED DRIVERS
TO CHOOSE TO GET INTO ELECTRIC
CARS AND RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
IT'S MUCH HARDER. TO PROMOTE
ELECTRIFICATION WHEN
ELECTRICITY PRICES ARE HIGH AND
RISING. AND THE SECOND REASON
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT A TAX ON
ELECTRICITY CONSUMPTION IS ONE
OF THE MOST REGRESSIVE TAXES WE
CAN THINK OF. BECAUSE LOW
INCOME. THIS IS MARCUS OF THAT
GAS TAX A SALES TAX MUCH MORE
AGGRESSIVE THAN IN INCOME TAX.
SO WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
DECARBONISING THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY IT'S CLEAR WE NEED TO
REVOLUTIONIZE HOW WE GENERATE
ELECTRICITY AND PUBLIC
TRANSPORT ELECTRICITY AND HOW
WE CONSUME ELECTRICITY. BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO RETHINK HOW WE PAY
FOR ELECTRICITY FOR BOTH EQUITY
AND EFFICIENCY REASONS. I KNOW
I'M AT A TIME LET ME MAKE MY
FINAL POINT BRIEFLY WE'VE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THIS. BUT
WITH RESPECT TO THE CARBON
MARKET CARBON PRICING IS NOT A
SILVER BULLET BUT IT'S AN
ESSENTIAL PIECE OF CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES. SO WE
HAVEN'T PLACED AN ECONOMY WIDE
CARBON MARKET WHICH ENSURES
THAT SOME PART I'D LIKE TO SEE
THE PRICE BE HIGHER BUT SOME
PART OF THE COST OF EMITTING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. IS
TRANSMITTED IN THE FORM OF A
CARBON PRICE ALMOST EVERYWHERE.
CARBON IS IMPLICITLY BOUGHT AND
SOLD SERVICE PROVIDES AN
INCENTIVE. FOR AGENTS TO
INTERNALIZE PART OF THE CLIMATE
COST. IF WE RELY PRIMARILY ON
MANDATES AND STANDARDS AND
SUBSIDIES TO ACHIEVE OUR FUTURE
TARGETS WILL DEPRESSOR DILUTE
THIS CARBON PRICING ALSO I
THINK THERE'S A BALANCE TO
STRIKE. BETWEEN RELYING ON THE
CARBON MARKET VERSUS
PRESCRIPTIVE REGULATIONS TO GET
WHERE WE NEED TO GO. SO I'VE
ONLY SCRATCHED THE SURFACE I'M
WAY OVER TIME I WILL CLOSE BY
SAYING THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
RESEARCHERS STUDENTS AND
FACULTY. AT UC BERKELEY DOING
RESEARCH RELEVANT TO THE THREE
THINGS I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
AN IMPORTANT MOTIVATION THIS
WORK IS TO INFORM HIGH STAKES
POLICY DECISIONS SO PLEASE DO
NOT HESITATE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
ME. IF ANY OF THE COMMENTS I
MADE PEAK YOUR INTEREST BECAUSE
WE'D WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE. FURTHER AND I'LL STOP
THERE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. A FELL. I'M SURE EACH OF.
TOUCHED UPON WHAT YOU NORMALLY
CALL A COVER AN ENTIRE
SEMESTER'S OUR TEXTBOOKS. ABOUT
WE APPRECIATE THE- THE
HIGHLIGHTS ANY. QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. IS YOUR ARE YOU
OR YOUR GROUP PLANNING ANY-
BASED ON YOUR RESEARCH ANY
REPORTS ON A POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND
ELECTRICITY PRICING CALIFORNIA.
YEAH SO WE- WROTE A QUICK
SURVEY- ONE REPORTER
PRELIMINARY REPORT THAT WAS
PARTLY SUPPORTED BY NEXT TEN
WHICH WE RELEASED A LAST SPRING
IN ORDER TO TRAIN INFORM THE
POLICY DISCUSSION AS IT
UNFOLDED BUT THIS WORK IS I'M
GOING SO THEY'LL BE A
SUBSEQUENT REPORT COMING OUT IN
THE FALL AND PROBABLY MORE TO
FOLLOW. BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO
SHARE THE REPORT WITH YOU- THAT
WE HAVE. THAT'S ALREADY OUT- IN
FUTURE REPORTS AS THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE. THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
SEND IT TO THE FOLKS THAT
CONTACTED YOU TO ARRANGE FOR
YEP BECAME HAPPY TO DO THAT AND
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS WE CAN.
DEFINITELY YOU YOU TALKED ABOUT
HOW YOU KNOW WE NEED TO KEEP A-
VIA THE PROPER PERSPECTIVE ON
ON CALIFORNIA'S. ROLE WHICH IS
TRYING TO MAXIMIZE THE GLOBAL
IMPACT ON ON ON CLIMATE CHANGE-
GIVEN OUR- YOU KNOW A FRACTION
OF OUR GLOBAL CONTRIBUTION TO
THE GREENHOUSE GAS GASES IT AND
I AND OUR LARGER POTENTIAL TO
BE ABLE TO INNOVATE AND EXPORT
EXPORT. TO- IN A GAME CHANGING-
TECHNOLOGY- DO YOU HAVE ANY ANY
TOPLINE RECOMMENDATIONS IN
TERMS OF HOW. THE LEGISLATURE
CAN BEST INCENTIVIZE THOSE TYPE
OF- INNOVATIONS. YEAH I MEAN
GENERALLY SPEAKING- I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT SOMETHING
MORE CONCRETE I CAN OPERATE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A REALLY
GOOD QUESTION- I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT PUSHING TOO
QUICKLY TOWARDS GOALS THAT WE
NEED TO REACH AT SOME POINT MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE COST OF
THAT LAST 23% REDUCTIONS ARE
GOING TO BE QUITE HIGH GIVEN
THE TECHNOLOGIES WE ALREADY
HAVE IN HAND TODAY BUT THAT
THOSE COSTS COULD FALL AS
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION PROCEED
TO PAY SO- I GUESS STRIKING A
BALANCE BETWEEN DOING IT BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AT GRAPHIC
OFTEN POTENTIALLY. IMPACTED
PARTICULARLY TO LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS OF VERSES US ARE
MORE MEASURED APPROACH OF
THINKS ABOUT ALL THE
INNOVATIONS IN THE CHILLING
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO MAKE FROM
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FROM THE
TECHNOLOGY TO THE INSTITUTIONS
AND REGULATIONS SO WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE A SYSTEMIC OUT SET
OF POLICY INTERVENTIONS AND AN
INCENTIVE THAT WE NEED TO GET
THERE SO I THINK IT'S JUST
THINKING ABOUT WHY WE'RE DOING
IT AND WHETHER- PUSHING HARD AT
GREAT COST TO HIT A TARGET I'M
IN CALIFORNIA WHAT THAT
DEMONSTRATES THE WORLD CLASS
VERSUS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
VARIOUS CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO MAKE TO MAKE SURE
THE EFFORT OF THAT THE
TRANSITION. IS EQUITABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE AND AFFORDABLE.
ASSEMBLY ONE BURKE YEAH ON THE
CHAIRS QUESTION ABOUT OUR ROLE
AS A LEADER AND- I APPRECIATE
THE LAST THING YOU JUST SAID
BECAUSEYOU DID MENTION THAT.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE THINGS
ARE AGGRESSIVE A LOT OF.
OPPORTUNITIES WE'RE TAKING OUR
OUR REGRESSIVE AND- I AM
CURIOUS WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE
ON WHAT OUR RESPONSIBILITY. IS
AS A LEADER TO SHOW THAT ALL
COMMUNITIES COME ALONG ON THIS
JOURNEY- TWO OF OUR NINE
PANELISTS ARE. PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND SO I AM CURIOUS WHAT WHAT
YOU THINK OUR ROLE AS LEADERS
IS. IS IN NOT ANY OF OUR IN THE
SPACE- NOT OBVIOUSLY JUST TO
EACH OTHER BUT TO THE WORLD. I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
QUESTION- SO I GUESS ONE THING
THAT I DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO
GET INTO DO AS I THINK I WANNA-
MAKE CLEAR THAT. THE WHAT I SEE
IS THE PROMISE SPECIALLY IN THE
ELECTRICITY IN THE CASE OF
ELECTRICITY IS NOT NOT
NECESSARILY INVESTMENTS WERE
MAKING BUT HOW WE'RE PAYING FOR
THEM. SO FOR EXAMPLE IN OUR
REPORT WE TALK ABOUT HOW AND
INCREASED INCOME TAX WOULD BE
FAR LESS REGRESSIVE YOU WOULD
WRITE RECOVER THE REVENUES WE
NEED TO COVER THESE COSTS BUT
IN A FAR LESS AGGRESSIVE WAY.
AND IN A MORE EFFICIENT WAY TO
THE EXTENT THAT ALLOWS US TO
REDUCE ELECTRICITY PRICES
CLOSER TO WHERE EFFICIENT PRICE
WOULD BE. I SEE AND WE HAVE
BEEN ARGUING AS PART OF THE
PROJECT I MENTIONED THAT WE DO
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
DEMONSTRATE LEADERSHIP NOT ONLY
IN TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION AND
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT. BUT
ALSO IN DEMONSTRATING HOW YOU
DEPLOY THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THIS
TRANSITION IN AN EQUITABLE AND
AFFORDABLE WAY SO I DO SEE. AND
I'D BE HAPPY TO TALK FURTHER WE
TALKED ABOUT INCOME BASED FIXED
CHARGES THERE ARE NUMBER OF
DEGREES OF FREEDOM WE HAVE AND
WE'RE TRYING TO RAISE THE
REVENUES TO COVER THESE
INVESTMENTS IN COSTS. THAT
STRIKES A BETTER BALANCE
BETWEEN CLIMATE CHANGE ACTION
WE NEED TO MAKE. ANY EQUITY.
EQUITY AND AFFORDABILITY
CONCERNS. THAT SHOULD BE TOP OF
MIND IN MY OPINION. I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU JUST REAL
QUICK I THINK YOU YOU SAID THIS
BUT DO YOU BELIEVE. A CURRENT
CAPTURE MARKET PRICES ARE
PLANNING A STRONG ENOUGH. PRICE
SIGNAL RELATIVE TO THE PACE OF
CHANGE WE NEED. NOW YEAH. I
THINK THEY NEED TO BE HIGHER
AND I THINK ONE THING TO. TO AT
RUNS AND BROWN AND HIS
COLLEAGUES HAVE DONE EXCELLENT
WORK AND IF HE ARTICULATED IT
CAN BE HARD TO UNDERSTAND THE
MARGINAL. IMPLICIT COSTS WERE
PAYING FOR OTHER MEASURES BUT I
THINK THE BULK OF THE EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THAT. YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE PAYING PER TON OF CARBON
REDUCE BY SOME OF OUR MANDATES
MORE PRESCRIPTIVE REGULATIONS
AS WELL ABOVE THE PRICE WE'RE
SEEING. IN THE MARKET WHICH
SUGGESTS THAT THERE COULD BE.
RELATIVELY COST EFFECTIVE
CARBON REDUCTION OPTIONS AND
MEASURES THAT WE'RE NOT
DEPLOYING THAT COULD BE
DEPLOYED BEFORE HIGHER STRONGER
CARBON PRICE SIGNAL. THANK ALL
RIGHT SAYING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JEFF VALLEY. THANK YOU. THIS
CONCLUDES OUR OUR SECOND PANEL
AREN'T AREN'T EARLY NEXT AND
FINAL PANEL IS GOING TO BE A-
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM A
WIDE RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS
WHERE WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE A
THE QUESTIONS WE'RE GOING TO
RESERVE THE QUESTIONS FOR THE
NEXT PASS A PANEL- AS AS A
GROUP AFTER ALL. FIVE HAVE HAD
A CHANCE TO PRESENT AND SO- WE
ARE WANT TO WELCOME- PAULINA
TORRANCE STAFF ATTORNEY FOR THE
SENATE RACE POVERTY AND
ENVIRONMENT- THEN FOLLOWING HER
ANDREW MEREDITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL- THIRD LANCE
HASTINGS PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OF
FOURTH CATHARINE REES BOYD
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION- AND LAST BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LEAST K. CAITLYN
ROAD NEAR SADR SENIOR MANAGER-
U. S. CLIMATE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
LIKE START OFF AND- WELCOME-
PAULINA TORRES. GOOD AFTERNOON
MURATSUCHI AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I THANK YOU FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PERSPECTIVE ON THESE BURYING
BRING CRIME ISSUES HI MY NAME
IS TELLING A TORRANCE AND THE
MEMBER AND THE EIGHTY THIRTY
TWO ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE CENTER ON
RACE POVERTY NEED VITAMINS.
SYRUPY IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDES
LEGAL AND TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO
COMMUNICATE COMMUNITY GROUPS.
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTHERN SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY ON AN ARRAY OF
POLLUTION ISSUES THEY
DISPROPORTIONATELY ACE. MANY IF
NOT ALL OF WHICH ARE RELEVANT
TO TODAY'S DISCUSSION. THERAPY
ALSO WORKS IN CORRELATION WITH
VARIOUS STATE BY GROUPS
INCLUDING PRICES IN SOLITARY
SOLIDARITY AGAINST WHEN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH KNOWLEDGE ON
THE COMPANY BY MR JUSTICE
ALLIANCE CENTRAL VALLEY AIR
QUALITY COALITION AMONG MANY
OTHERS. THE TOPICS DISCUSSED
TODAY ARE ISSUES THAT YOU
GROUPS STATEWIDE HAVE CONCERNS
QUESTIONS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
EXPERTISE INCLUDING LIVED
EXPERIENCES AREN'T. SO I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO HOLD A SEPARATE
EASY FOCUS HEARING. THE
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SHARE MANY
CONCERNS ABOUT TOPICS DISCUSSED
DURING THE COMMITTEE THUS FAR.
BUT I'LL FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON
REMIND MAIN POINTS IN THE
INTEREST OF TRYING. ON THE
FIRST SEASON SHARING MEANINGFUL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
INTEGRATION AND PROCESS. AND
ADDRESSING CLIMATE ISSUES. WE
HAVE THIS TIME ARM THAT'S
SIMPLY JACK. HAVE QUITE AS ARE
MY- IT AN BY JOHN FROM IDEATION
TO IMPLEMENTATION. AND THIS
MEANS THAT COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND WORKING WITH DJ COMMUNITIES
WITH COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED.
ISN'T JUST A PHASE IN AND
AGENCIES- ARE CARDS OVER. IT
HIGHLIGHTS THAT ENGAGEMENT IS A
CONTINUOUS TASK IN EVERY PHASE
OF THE PROJECT. AND WHILE WE
RECOGNIZE THE URGENCY OF
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
I'M CARD NEEDS TO LISTEN TO THE
JACK WHEN WE SAY WE NEED THE
TIME I WE NEED THE RESOURCES TO
DO THIS RIGHT HI TO ENSURE THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES DON'T GET LEFT
BEHIND AS THE STATE DEVELOPS
ITS CLINIC POLICIES. I'LL JUST
GIVE ONE EXAMPLE AT THE LAST
YOU JACK MEETING I'M MEMBERS OF
THE EXACT EXPRESSED CONCERN
ABOUT THE PROCESS MOVING TOO
QUICKLY. I THAT WE NEED MORE
TIME TO UNDERSTAND THE MATERIAL
SHARED BY CARP BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THAT WE NEED AT THE
TIME AND RESOURCES TO SHARE
THESE COMPLICATED MATERIALS ARE
THERE PARTICULARLY ON- MODELING
SCENARIO. I'M WITH OUR
COMMUNITY. AND IN RESPONSE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CARVE ICE
HE STATED I'M AND INCLUDING IF
WE DON'T HEAR FROM YOU ALL
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM IS THE
INDUSTRY SIDE BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALL READY TO GO. AND AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE THIS WAS DEEPLY
CONCERNING AND MAINLY BECAUSE
THE ONLY ADVISORY GROUP
REQUIRED BY LAW FOR CARDS A
CONSOLE. FEEDBACK IS ASKING FOR
MORE TRYING TO MANY
MEANINGFULLY ENGAGE WITH
COMMUNITIES AND CARVE. IT'S
TELLING US THAT WE RISK GETTING
LEFT BEHIND. AND SO I'M KERN IT
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT IT
WILL IT'S A LIVE. PROGRESS AT
THE FROM CAR WHICH THAT THAT
PROGRESS IS AN EXTRA LINKED TO
THE EFFORTS. WE AND SOLUTION
MADE BY AND ON SIDE E. G.
COMMUNITY. AND I FURTHER URGES
COMMITTEE TO ASK CARBON EACH TO
CALL OUTLINED AN EASY PROCESS
FOR THE SCOPING PLAN. THAT
ENSURES EASY INTEGRATION
THROUGHOUT. I THE SECOND
CONCERN I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS IS
CARDS RELIANCE ON ALL SOLUTIONS
TO CLIMATE CHANGE THEY'RE BEING
PUSHED FORWARD WITHOUT REGARD
TO THEIR POTENTIALLY AND FOR
SOME. UNKNOWN CONTINUE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS EACH
YEAR COMMUNITIES. IN THAT AND I
JUST OF TIME OFF OKAY CENTER
HIGHLIGHTS CONCERNS REGARDING
THESE ALSO LUCIEN'S. AT THE
EXPENSE OF PRIORITIZING DIRECT
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS. AND FOR
EXAMPLE WE SHARE MANY CONCERNS-
DISCUSSED SO FAR SOME ITERATED
BY GERMANY CG ABOUT THAT.
BERMAN CAPTAINCY SEQUESTRATION
TECHNOLOGIES THAT PERPETUATE
THE USE OF FOSSIL FUELS AS PART
OF THE CLIMATE SOLUTIONS ARE.
GENEROUSLY I. B. STEP
KNOWLEDGE'S FUNDAMENTALLY
PROLONG THE LIFE OF EXISTING
FOSSIL FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHICH MEANS ALSO PROLONGS ITS
HARMFUL IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES.
IT'S EVIDENT THAT CARBON IS
RELYING ON CCS TECHNOLOGIES TO
SOME DEGREE BUT THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AFFECTIVELY ALLOW
POLLUTERS TO POLLUTER ABSENT AS
WELL WITH CARDS FRAMEWORK- OF
SOURCES EQUAL SEATS. INSIDE ONE
OF REEMPHASIZE THAT
INCORPORATING CCS TECHNOLOGIES
WAS PROPOSE AND DEVELOP WITHOUT
THE INPUT. OF THE E. JACK OR
EAT EAT A COMMUNITIES. AND ALSO
UNDERLYING OUR CONCERN
REGARDING FUNDS CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS IS THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM INSIDE LIKE THEY JUST.
THANK BY SHARE BACKER FOR THE
LETTER SUBMITTED ALONGSIDE
SENATORS HERTZBERG IN MY CASKET
SECURE RANDOLPH. THIS LETTER
CAPTURED OUR CONCERNS ABOUT AB
ONE NINETY SEVEN UNEQUIVOCAL
MANDATE THAT CAR PRIORITIZE
DIRECT EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IN
THAT THERE IS NO AMBIGUITY
ABOUT AB ONE NINETY SEVENS IN
CHINA. THAT IT WAS DESIGNED. TO
FOCUS ATTENTION ON POLICIES
OTHER THAN HAPPENED. IT'S WHITE
THE COMMITTEE TO OVERSEE CUTS
TO BUY BUY THEIR OF WHEN I
SEVEN. BY ENSURING THAT PRIOR.
OF DRUG WITH. AND FRANKLY ABOUT
HAPPENED HE DOES NOT. EMISSIONS
REDUCTION MEASURE. AND WE HOPE
THAT THIS FOR. UNDER
LEGISLATIVE OVER WITH CARD TO.
THE FAILURE FAILURES ON THE
CAPTAIN PROGRAM AND I KNOW I'M
RUNNING OUT OF TIME SO FIND THE
WANT TO MAKE- I LAUGHED WHEN-
THAT CLARK MUST PRAYER. A G. B.
ACHIEVING THAT THIRTY TWO TWO
THIRTY TWO. AND I UNDER THAT
PART HAS INTERPRETED ITS
REQUIREMENT. TIED TO THE TWENTY
THIRTY STATUTORY TARGETS TO
ENCOMPASS OTHER REQUIREMENTS
SUCH AS LIKE CARBON AND
NEUTRALITY EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
WHAT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE ON THE
NEED TO REFOCUS CRACKED THE
TENSION TO ARE REQUIRED IN MORE
IMMINENT SB THIRTY TWO GOAL OF
REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS. 40%
BELOW AT THE NINETEEN NINETY
LEVELS BY TWENTY THIRTY- I
WOULD APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S TIME AND GET AGAIN
ENCOURAGES SEPARATE COMMITTEE
HEARING EXCLUSIVELY FOCUSED ON
ENVIRONMENTAL. JUSTICE ISSUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I WANT TO. THAT TO YOU
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT I MEAN SO MANY
OF THESE ISSUES THIS SURVEY. A
HEARING AID AND- AND OF A SELF
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT
YOU'RE RAISING AND SO. I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. NEXT
WE HAVE A ANDREW MEREDITH-
REPRESENTING THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN TODAY.
WE HAD. THIS CONVERSATION TO
SOME DEGREE LAST WEEK WITH THE
SECRETARY OF LABOR OUR BROTHER
MARTY WALSH. WE'RE HAPPY TO
SHARE SOME OF THESE TALKING
POINTS TODAY AS WELL. THE PHONE
CONFIRMING YES IT HAS BEEN
TESTED. SO AGAIN ON THE
INTERNET WITH THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. AS MOST OF YOU
KNOW WE REPRESENT ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE. INCLUDING OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND REGISTERED STATE
APPRENTICES. WE HAVE BUILT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE COMMERCIAL
SCALE RENEWABLE ENERGY PROJECTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF SOLAR
ALONE. I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT FIRST ABOUT THE THINGS THAT
WE BELIEVE THAT WORKS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM WE THINK HAS
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IT'S HELPS
PROTECT MANUFACTURING JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IT'S PROTECTED
OUR ABILITY TO BE A
MANUFACTURING POWERHOUSE IN
THIS COUNTRY. WE ALSO BELIEVE
PUBLIC INVESTMENTS IN RENEWABLE
ENERGY HAVE HAVE BEEN
MEANINGFUL. AND THEY HAVE
DRIVEN THE MARKET TO THE POINT
WHERE THE ENERGY IS CHEAP AND
IT'S AFFORDABLE TO DEPLOY WE
ALSO BELIEVE THE INITIAL
PHASING OF THE EEVEE CHARGING
APPARATUS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN MAJOR METROPOLITAN PARTS OF
THE STATE. RURAL PARTS OF THE
STATE THOUGH HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND IT WILL NEED TO BE
EXPANDED AS WE FURTHER DEPLOY
EVEY VEHICLES. SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WANT THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER MOVING
FORWARD. WE BELIEVE THAT
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC INVESTMENT
IS GOING TO BE REQUIRED IN THE
FIRST CARBON REDUCTION AND
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIOS. CARBON
CAPTURE GREEN HYDROGEN PUMP
STORAGE OFFSHORE WIND. BIOMASS
SOLAR ALL OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES
ARE VIABLE THEY ALL DESERVE
ATTENTION THEY SHOULD BE
MODELED AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE SCOPING PLAN. AND THEY
THEY'RE DEFINITELY SIGNIFICANT
ENOUGH THAT PUBLIC INVESTMENT
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED. WE ALSO
BELIEVE STRICT LABOR STANDARDS
SHOULD BE A PART OF ANY PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS IN THESE
TECHNOLOGIES. INCLUDING THE
INTERNALIZATION OF PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS COMMUNITY
WORKFORCE TRAINING AGREEMENTS.
AND SKILLED AND TRAINED
LANGUAGE BEING INSERTED
ACTUALLY INTO FUTURE
LEGISLATION. LASTLY WE BELIEVE
INCLUDING WORKERS IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS SHOULD BE
PARAMOUNT AT ALL TIMES WE HAVE
BEEN ENGAGED IN THE SCOPING
PLAN PROCESS WITH CARD WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY. BUT FRANKLY WE FEEL
OUR VOICE HAS BEEN MARGINALIZED
IN THESE DISCUSSIONS. TO THE
POINT THAT WE'VE LITERALLY HAD
TO DEMAND THAT CARVE INCLUDE A
LEVER VOICE ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE
WE DON'T THINK THINGS SHOULD
GET TO THIS POINT. WE BELIEVE
LABOUR'S VOICE SHOULD BE
PARAMOUNT WE BELIEVE IT IT'S
IMPORTANT IN THIS DISCUSSION
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
BE LISTEN TO. THE OVER OVER
OVER ARCHING MESSAGE OF OUR
ORGANIZATION IS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN A GOOD STRONG PARTNER IN
DEPLOYING RENEWABLE ENERGY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOUR
VOICES CONSISTENT CONSISTENTLY
BEEN MARGINALIZED IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS AS I JUST
EXPLAINED. EXTREMIST VIEWS ON
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE SEEM
TO RULE THE DAY. BUMPER STICKER
TALKING POINTS LIKE SHUT OFF
EVERYTHING NOW WILL BE IN
FOSSIL FUELS TOMORROW SEEM TO
RESONATE WITH TOO MANY MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE TOO MANY
FOLKS THAT CARB. THESE TALKING
POINTS SIGNAL OR SCIENCE BIG
NOR DATA AND IGNORE THE FACTS
ON THE GROUND. CALIFORNIA IS
FRANKLY NOT READY TO SHUT
EVERYTHING OFF IN THE FOSSIL
FUEL SECTOR. OUR POWER GRID IS
ALREADY STRUGGLING. IN FACT THE
STRUGGLING TO THE POINT THAT
STARTING TOMORROW HUNDREDS OF
OUR WORKERS AROUND THE STATE.
ARE WORKING UNDER A EMERGENCY
AGREEMENTS. TO DEPLOY GAS
TURBINE GENERATION- TECHNOLOGY
IN VARIOUS PARTS OF THE STATE
TO DEAL WITH WHAT IS EXPECTED
TO BE UNPRECEDENTED POWER
SHORTAGES IN THE NEXT THIRTY
DAYS. THERE IS A PUSH TO IGNORE
STRATEGIES LIKE CARBON CAPTURE
BECAUSE SOME WOULD RATHER SEE
WHOLE INDUSTRIES CRUMBLE. BEEN
SEE IF CARBON REDUCTION
MEASURES CAN KEEP THEM VIABLE
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME. WE ARE
CONSTANTLY FIGHTING ON THE
FRONT LINES TO DEPLOY RENEWABLE
PROJECTS LIKE WIND ENERGY ONES
WENT VIRAL MENTAL GROUPS
FREQUENTLY RISE TO OPPOSE THEM.
WHEN OFFSHORE WIND BEGINS TO
MATERIALIZE IN THE STATE WE
WILL BE BATTLING THE SAME
GROUPS IN THE SAME BOTTLES.
JUST IN DIFFERENT AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA. INDUSTRY IS
RESPONDING FOR THE CLIMATE
CRISIS PROJECTS LIKE RODEO
RENEWED IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
WHERE PHILLIPS SIXTY SIX WILL
INVEST IN TRANSITIONING THEIR
EXISTING PLANT. TO BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION GALLONS OF RENEWABLE
DIESEL OR AN EXAMPLE OF THAT.
WELL THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY EMBRACE IT.
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES ARE
RESPONDING AS WELL IN OTHER
SECTORS. BLUE PLANET FOR
EXAMPLE BASED OUT OF LOS GATOS.
IS UTILIZING CO TWO TO REPLACE
TRADITIONAL BUILDING MATERIALS
INCLUDING IN CONCRETE. THERE
CONCRETE WAS ACTUALLY DEPLOYED
IN AN EXPANSION PROJECT AT THE
SAN FRANCISCO INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT. NONE OF THESE EFFORTS
WILL CONTINUE AND THERE WON'T
BE ANY OTHER EFFORTS LIKE THEM
IF MESSAGING FROM THE
LEGISLATURE OR MESSAGING FROM
CARP CALLS THESE TECHNOLOGIES
INTO QUESTION. WE NEED STRONG
MESSAGING IN STRONG SUPPORT
FROM ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THAT THESE
TYPES OF TECHNOLOGIES ARE
IMPORTANT. AND SHOULD BE PART
OF OUR PLAN TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA. HE BY
DID ADMINISTRATION IS LEADING
THIS DIALOGUE NOW THEY'RE
CALLING FOR SUPPORT OF CARBON
CAPTURE THEIR INVESTING TIME
EFFORT AND MONEY INTO OFFSHORE
WIND. WE NEED TO REGAIN OUR
PLACE AT THE HEAD OF THAT
DISCUSSION. AS THIS RELATES TO
OUR MEMBERS WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT IN SOME POINT IN EVERY
CALENDAR YEAR. OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
WALKING THROUGH GATES TO
PERFORM WORK IN THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY. THESE JOBS ARE LIKE A
LOT OF THE LIKE ALL OF THE
OTHER JOBS IN THE BUILDING
TRADES THAT BARRIER FREE.
THERE'S NO CONSIDERATION GIVEN
TO AN INDIVIDUAL'S RACE
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS. YOUR
INCARCERATION IN FOSTER CARE
STATUS THEIR BARRIER FREE THESE
MEMBERS ARE HIGHLY SKILLED THE
HIGHLY PRODUCTIVE AND THEY'RE
FULLY CAPABLE OF TRANSITIONING
THEIR SKILLS INTO OTHER
MEANINGFUL TECHNOLOGIES. AS THE
INDUSTRY TRANSITIONS THESE
WORKERS HAVE NOTHING TO WORRY
ABOUT IF WE EMBRACE TECHNOLOGY
LIKE CARBON CAPTURE IF WE
EMBRACE CARBON SEQUESTRATION.
AND IF WE IGNORE THE BUMPER
STICKER TALKING POINTS THAT
WE'RE CONSTANTLY BOMBARDED
WITH. THE WAY WE PHASE OUT
FOSSIL FUELS IN THE STATE WILL
BE PARAMOUNT IN DETERMINING
WHETHER OR NOT WE WILL HAVE A
BLUE COLLAR WORKING MIDDLE
CLASS IN THE STATE IN THE
FUTURE. TO THAT END IF THE LAST
DROP OF OIL. IN CALIFORNIA
ISN'T EXTRACTED AND REFINED IN
THE STATE WE FAILED NOT ONLY
THE ENVIRONMENTS. AS OUR LABOR
STANDARDS ARE STRICTER HERE
THAN THEY ARE IN ANY OTHER PART
OF THE COUNTRY AND OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS ARE
JUST DISTRICTS. BUT WE ALSO
FEEL THESE WORKERS. THE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE ARE MASSIVE
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE RECOGNIZE
THAT. OUR RESERVOIRS ARE
RUNNING DRY OR FORESTS ARE
CONSTANTLY BURNING AND THINGS
ARE GETTING BETTER. BY THE TIME
I GET HOME TONIGHT FROM MY HOME
AND TO HIM A COUNTY BY POWER
WILL BE SHUT OFF AS PART OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
PROGRAM. WE CANNOT. HOWEVER
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE STRATEGY
THAT BELIEVES WE CAN SHUT OFF
ALSO FUELS TOMORROW. DROPPING
EVEY VEHICLE AND EVERYONE'S
DRIVEWAY TOMORROW NIGHT. AND
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO. GOOD
FAITH OUR WAY THROUGH THE
CLIMATE CHANGE CRISIS WE MUST
EMBRACE ALL TECHNOLOGIES WE
MUST DEPLOY THESE TECHNOLOGIES
WE MUST INVEST IN THEM WE MUST
EMBRACE THINGS LIKE THE
SOLEMNIZATION AN OFF STREAM
STORAGE TO DIVERSIFY OUR WATER
PORTFOLIO. WE MUST HARD AND
DIVERSIFY OUR ELECTRICAL GRID.
BOOKS OF THE SUBSIDIZATION WILL
BE PARAMOUNT TO MAKING THIS
HAPPEN. LASTLY WE GET ASKED
THIS QUITE A BIT ABOUT THE TERM
JUST TRANSITION I DON'T WANT TO
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT OUR
ORGANIZATION BELIEVES ABOUT THE
TERM UST TRANSITION. OR
MEMBERS JUST WANT TO HAVE A
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS OUR MEMBERS
JUST WANT TO HAVE A DIGNIFIED
RETIREMENTS OR MEMBERS JUST
WANT TO KEEP THEIR MEDICAL
DENTAL VISION BENEFITS MOVING
INTO THE FUTURE. OUR MEMBERS
JUST WANT TO HAVE A VOICE IN
MAKING SURE THAT THAT CONTINUES
TO HAPPEN INTO THE FUTURE. AND
OUR MEMBERS JUST ARE LOOKING TO
YOU FOR SOLUTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR MEREDITH
AND I. I HAD FORGOTTEN THAT YOU
WERE AND I BELIEVE THE ONLY
SPEAKER THAT'S HERE IN PERSON
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
AND FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT WE
HAVE A LANCE HASTINGS A
PRESIDENCY OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I WILL TAKE HIS
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR INVITATION.
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE STATE'S
CLIMATE POLICIES AND THE
HEARING TODAY. I THINK MANY OF
YOU KNOW THE TNC REPRESENTS
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
MANUFACTURERS. THEY WERE
INDUSTRY THAT EMPLOYS MORE THAN
ONE POINT TWO MILLION AMERICAN
WORKERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA. OUR
AVERAGE WAGES EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR WHICH
IS FANTASTIC AND REALLY
SUPPORTS THE MIDDLE CLASS. AND
IT DOES PROVIDE AN EXCITED
UPWARDLY MOBILE CAREER TO A
DIVERSE MIDDLE CLASS WORKFORCE.
MANY FACTORS SECTOR ALSO
CREATES FOR THE LARGEST
POSITIVE IMPACTS ON OUR
ECONOMY. WITH EACH OF OUR JOBS
ACCORDING AT LEAST TO HELP
OTHERS IN THE STATE. AS WELL AS
THE MASSIVE SUPPLY CHAINS. BUT
FOR MANY REASONS THEREFORE
MANUFACTURING DISCIPLINE THE
BACKBONE CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
ALL OF THAT CALIFORNIA'S GHG
POLICY DISCUSSIONS AND
REGULATIONS REALLY MUST ANSWER
TO THRESHOLD QUESTIONS FOR THE
FIRST. IS A COST EFFECTIVE AND
IT'S SECONDARILY IT WAS
DEPARTMENT BASED ON THE OTHER
COMMENTS TODAY IS A
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE.
PRESERVATION AND BEST ANIMATION
OPTIONALITY. TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
POLICY WILL ALLOW CAPITAL
ENVIRONMENTAL MARKETS IDENTIFY
THE MOST EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS.
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
OBLIGATED PARTIES ARE COVERED
ENTITIES AND HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY TO REDUCE THEIR
EMISSIONS IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE STATE'S CLIMATE POLICY
REQUIREMENTS. MOST IF NOT ALL
HAVE SPENT A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES AND GHG REDUCTIONS
ALREADY FOR THE FIRST TWO
ROUNDS OF CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
REQUIREMENTS IT IS VERY
EFFICIENCIES OR THE CAP AND
TRADE SYSTEM. MANY FACTORS ARE
ENERGY INTENSIVE TRADE EXPOSED
BUSINESSES. THIS IS THE PASSAGE
OF AB THIRTY TWO IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX. THE LEGISLATURE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT OUR STATE'S
CLIMATE POLICIES SHOULD NOT
RESULT IN EMISSIONS LEAKAGE AND
SIFTING. MANY FACTORS OUTSIDE
OF OUR BORDERS AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER TODAY AS WELL. ACT WE
NEED TO KEEP THAT MANUFACTURING
SECTOR HERE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
THE JOBS TO SUPPORT STATE LOCAL
FINANCES. TELL MEDICAID AGAINST
THE POSSIBILITY BACKING- CARPET
WOMEN OF THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM CERTAIN DESIGN ELEMENTS
TO PROTECT AGAINST THAT LEAKAGE
AND AS RECENTLY AS LAST YEAR
SEE HIM TO DATE. STOOD
RESOLUTELY TO PROTECT- THAT THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AS IT
EXISTS. OUR COMMITMENT CLIMATE
POLICIES TO BE SUCCESSFUL FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BE A MODEL FOR
THE REST OF THE WORLD. OUR
MEMBERS NEED TO HAVE TOOLS TO
COMPLY. WITH THE PROGRAM AND
HELP CONTAIN COSTS. I THINK
YOU'LL BE HERE IN A MOMENT
ABOUT. MORE OF THE CCS PROGRAM
FROM MY OTHER- PANELS AND
COLLEAGUES SO I'M GONNA FOCUS
MY EFFORTS HERE ON COST
CONTAINMENT. IT'S NO QUESTION
THAT THE DEPARTMENT. POPCORN SB
THIRTY TWO ESPECIALLY IN YOUR
PENDING AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
MISTER CHAIRMAN. WILL BE
EXPENSIVE TO CONSUMERS AND
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S NO SCENARIO THAT I'M
AWARE OF. WHERE WE CAN ACHIEVE
THIS DRAMATIC EMISSION
REDUCTIONS WITHOUT THE COST OF
CONVENTIONAL ENERGY SOURCES
INCREASING. VERY SIGNIFICANTLY
IN FACT THERE ARE TWO STUDIES
COMMISSIONED BY THE LEGISLATURE
ANDRE BE SEVENTY FOUR IN SB ONE
HUNDRED THE STATE CLEARLY THAT
ACHIEVING THESE CARBON
TROPICALES IN THE ELECTRICITY
AND TRANSPORTATION SECTORS WILL
BE EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. IT FOR BUSINESSES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. FOR THAT
REASON COST CONTAINMENT POLICY
DESIGNED THAT A MANAGED DECLINE
IS CRITICAL FOR CMG MEMBERS AND
CONSUMERS. THE LEGISLATURE DID
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR COST
CONTAINMENT WHEN THEY PASSED AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. AS MANY OF YOU
RECALL AT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED MR GARCIA'S AB THREE
NINETY EIGHT. I TO SUPPORT IN A
TWO THIRDS. THAT LEVEL OF
STAKEHOLDER BOTHER COOPERATION
CAME TOGETHER THEN CHECKS DOWN
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM OUT
TO TWENTY THIRTY WAS INCREDIBLY
SIGNIFICANT SHOULD BE THE GOAL
FOR YOU TODAY. STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING CMC MEMBERS LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS ALSO
PORTED AB THREE NINETY EIGHT.
WE AGREED THAT WELL DESIGNED
CLIMATE CLIMATE POLICY ALSO HAD
TO PROTECT JOBS. CORRECT
COMPANIES WITHIN THE STATE. AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT CLEARLY
DIRECTED YOUR RESOURCES BOARD
TO CONTAIN COSTS WE KNOW THAT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE NOT ZERO
COST WE MUST DESIGN AND TO
BALANCE THE NEED FOR PROGRESS
TOWARD. OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND
PROTECTING YOUR CONSTITUENTS
FROM ALREADY RISING COSTS. FOR
THE REGULATORS THE LEGISLATURE
LOOK TOWARD IMPLEMENTING THE
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS
INVESTIGATING PATHWAYS TO
CARBON NEUTRALITY. WE MUST BE
MINDFUL TO TAKE AN ECONOMY WIDE
APPROACH AND AVOID
OVERBURDENING SPECIFIC SECTORS.
YEAH PEOPLE I CLIMATE CHANGE
WITHOUT ALSO PROTECTING OUR
JOBS AND THE ECONOMY. AS THE
BACKBONE OF OUR STATE'S ECONOMY
MANUFACTURED AS IMPORT ROLEPLAY
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
EACH EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
TECHNOLOGIES THEY WANT TO WORK
WITH YOU AND THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD DIPLOMAT CRITICAL POLICY
DESIGNS THAT WILL ACHIEVE OUR
STATE'S EMISSION REDUCTION
GOALS FOR THE SAME TIME.
PROTECT OUR MANUFACTURING JOBS
AND OUR ECONOMY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AND
REPORTS ANY QUESTIONS THE MAKE
UP AFTER THE PANEL CONCLUDED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER HASTINGS I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE ALSO. I AND
NEXT WE HAVE A KATHY READ HIS
BOYD- PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MURATSUCHI CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES WE CAN. OKAY
WONDERFUL- GOOD AFTERNOON AND
TO YOU AND TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M CATHERINE HIGHS
BUOYED AND I'M PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION I WANT TO
THANK YOU. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. ARE THE TOPICS
THAT ARE PRESENTED TO YOU TODAY
ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THEIR
PORTENT FOR DETERMINING THE
PATHWAY FORWARD TO MEETING OUR
STATE'S COMICAL AND A GOAL THAT
WE ALL SHARE. BUT I THINK EVEN
EVIDENCE TODAY AS ALWAYS THE
DETAILS OF HOW WE GET THERE
ACTUALLY DO MATTER. AND WE
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT AT ALL
OF THE ABOVE APPROACH FIRST
ANIMAL ENERGY FUTURE IS OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE. JUST FOUR
YEARS AGO THIS BODY PASSED
SIGNIFICANT CLIMATE LEGISLATION
THAT DIRECTED THE STATE TO MEET
OUR TWENTY THIRTY GOALS IN A
MANNER THAT MINIMIZE COSTS TO
YOUR CONSTITUENTS. AND PROTECTS
CALIFORNIA JOBS AND BUSINESSES.
YOUR EXTENDED THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM OUT TO TWENTY THIRTY
WHICH WE SUPPORTED. AND YOU
DIRECTED CARP TO PRIORITIZE
COST CONTAINMENT IN THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE STATE'S
CLIMATE POLICIES. WE ARE ONLY
EIGHT MONTHS INTO CARDS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SB THIRTY
TO TARGET. AS OUTLINED IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER WHICH BY THE
WAY I THOUGHT WAS VERY WELL
DONE. YOUR RESOURCES BOARD IS
CURRENTLY EVALUATING THE
PATHWAYS TO MEET OUR TWENTY
THIRTY GOALS AS WELL AS CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
COOL. THIS EVALUATION INCLUDES
A VERY ROBUST AND LINK THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. AND WILL
ULTIMATELY YIELD A SET OF
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
AIR B. THIS WORK IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. ESPECIALLY AS THE
LEGISLATURE IS CONSIDERING NEW.
AND DRAMATICALLY MORE
AGGRESSIVE TARGETS IN AB AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. A
PROPOSAL FOR NEW CAR TARGETS
FAR INTO THE FUTURE BEYOND
TWENTY THIRTY. IS INCOMPLETE
WITHOUT CERTAINTY ON THE
POLICIES ARE TOOLS THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR COMPLIANCE AND WE
KNOW WHAT TOOLS WE HAVE THROUGH
TWENTY THIRTY BECAUSE OF THE
DIRECTION THIS LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED IN AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. SO
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE KNOW
WHICH TOOLS AND PATHWAYS WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO TREAT THE NEW
GOALS THAT REACH BEYOND TWENTY
THIRTY. WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION WE YOU CAN'T BEGIN
TO HAVE AN INFORMED DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT FUTURE TARGETS WILL
MEAN. TO YOUR CONSTITUENTS INTO
THE STATE'S ECONOMY. THE PATH
BOTH THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
AND THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD PROGRAM HAVE DRIVEN
TREMENDOUS INNOVATION AND
CERTAINLY IN OUR INDUSTRY AND
OTHERS. AND WE MUST CONSIDER
HOW THESE POLICIES CONTINUE TO
EFFECTUATE THE PORTENT
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS AND
INNOVATIONS GOING FORWARD
FORWARD. AND I BELIEVE RATHER
THAN SETTING A NEW GOAL TWENTY
FOUR YEARS OUT. AS PROPOSED IN
AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE MUCH
MORE SIGNIFICANT CLIMATE
PROGRESS THIS YEAR. BY
DEMONSTRATING THE POLITICAL
WILL NECESSARY TO DEPLOY CARBON
CAPTURE AND SEQUESTRATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND ENSURING THAT
THE STATE IS ON TRACK TO MEET
OUR CLIMATE GOALS. AND I HAVE
BEEN IN THAT CONVERSATION FOR
QUITE SOME TIME WHEN I WAS
APPOINTED. BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO SIT
ON A PANEL WHEN WE MAPPED OUT
C. C. U. S. QUITE SOMETIME AGO
FOR HOW TO REACH THAT IN
CALIFORNIA. AN EXPERT INCLUDING
THE IPCC AND FRANKLY. THE
ENTIRE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
AGREED THAT CCS TECHNOLOGY WILL
BE KEY IN ADVANCING OUR CLIMATE
GOALS. AND SENATOR SKINNER
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW THE
OPPORTUNITIES HERE AND I KNOW
THAT THEY ARE BROUGHT
OPPORTUNITIES AND WE- ARE
INTERESTED IN ALL OF THEM- IT
CERTAINLY EVEN ONCE ON THE
NATURAL WORKING LANDS. SO WHY
OTHER STATES AND COUNTRIES ARE
PERMITTING AND BUILDING THESE
PROJECTS AND THERE ARE MANY
WHICH I COULD ARTICULATED BUT
THAT PART TIME. CALIFORNIA IS
IN MY OPINION FALLING WOEFULLY
BEHIND DESPITE HAVING SOME OF
FRANKLY THE BEST SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE. THE WORLD'S
LEADING UNIVERSITIES AND
LABORATORIES A HIGHLY MOTIVATED
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR AND SOME OF
FRANKLY THE BEST GEOLOGY IN THE
WORLD TO STORE CARBON. SO NOW
IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO FRANKLY
MAKE UP FOR LOST TIME ENSURE
THAT WE CAN LEAD OUR
TECHNOLOGIES AND SOLUTIONS AND
OUR INDUSTRY. LET ME REPEAT OUR
INDUSTRY IS HERE TO HELP YOU
THAT AND WE HAVE MANY PROJECTS
TO TALK ABOUT BEING CONSIDERED
IN THIS ROUND. SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE THE
LEGISLATURE CARBON OTHER STATE
AGENCIES. TO REALLY ENSURE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN MEETING OUR
CURRENT CLIMATE GOALS AND
LEADING THE WORLD. IN WHAT WE
BELIEVE ARE TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- AS REYES BOYD- I WHITFORD
AND CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION
OUR QUESTION AND ANSWER AND
LAST IN TERMS OF OUR OUR PANEL
SPEAKERS BUT CERTAINLY NOT
LEAST WE HAVE CAITLYN RODNER
SUTTER WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND. THANK YOU SO MUCH
TERROR AT CG CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
YES WE CAN THANK YOU. EXCELLENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY I'M
CAITLIN REDNER CENTER WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND- AND
I'D LIKE TO START BY ADDRESSING
THE TWENTY THIRTY GOAL THAT
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING- EDS
PERSPECTIVE ON ON SOME NEEDED
POLICY ADJUSTMENTS TO MEET THAT
GOAL. THEN DISCUSS THE IMPROPER
IMPORTANCE OF EIGHT NO LATER
THAN TWENTY FORTY FIVE NET ZERO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION GOAL.
AND I'M ALSO GOING TO BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON SOME AIR QUALITY
CONSIDERATIONS AND IN MEETING
BOTH OF THOSE GOALS. SO SB
THIRTY TO CONTINUE CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE LEGACY OF CLIMATE
LEADERSHIP AND CODIFIED- TWENTY
THIRTY GOAL. IN MEETING THIS
GOAL IS ESSENTIAL FOR LIMITING
CALIFORNIA'S IMPACT ON THE
CLIMATE. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS THE
SWEET OF POLICIES IT NEEDS TO
MEET THIS GOAL INCLUDING THE
ECONOMY WIDE DECLINING LIMIT ON
GREENHOUSE GASES. WHEN WELL
DESIGNED TO THIS LIMIT OR CAP
PROVIDES THE GREATEST POSSIBLE
CERTAINTY OF MEETING THE WRIT
BEATING REDUCTION GOALS AND IT
IS V. ESSENTIAL FEATURE OF THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. IT'S
SECTOR SPECIFIC POLICIES
ACHIEVE GREATER REDUCTIONS THAN
EXPECTED THEN THERE IS LESS
PRESSURE ON THE CAP AND THAT'S
FINE. BUT IF OTHER PROGRAMS
DELIVER FEWER REDUCTIONS IN THE
CAP HAS TO REMAIN THE BACKSTOPS
TO ENSURE EMISSIONS CONTINUE TO
DECLINE AT THE PEACE REQUIRED
TO MEET OUR GOALS. HOWEVER IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE PLAYING THE
ROLE OF BACKSTOPS EMISSIONS CAP
HAS TO BE CALIBRATED TO
ACTUALLY MEET THE TWENTY THIRTY
PEOPLE. IN CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
INCREASE THE AMBITION OF THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM THAT IS
TIGHTEN THE CAP. TO ENSURE
REQUIRED REDUCTIONS BY TWENTY
THIRTY. A TIGHTER CAP MEANS THE
EMISSIONS BUDGET IS SMALLER
FEWER ALLOWANCES ARE ISSUED AND
THE LEVEL OF EMISSIONS IS LOWER.
AND WE HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE THIS STATE CELEBRATED
AND JUSTIFIABLY SO A GREAT
ACHIEVEMENT WHEN IT MET ITS
TWENTY TWENTY GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOAL OF RETURNING TO
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS FOUR
YEARS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE. AND
THAT'S SUCCESS MEANS THAT WE
HAVE THE CHANCE TO INCREASE THE
STRINGENCY OF THE CAP BY
SETTING IT BASED ON ACTUAL
EMISSIONS WHICH ARE BELOW THE
TWENTY TWENTY TARGET. A LOWER
EMISSIONS CAP ESSENTIALLY MAKES
THOSE REDUCTIONS PERMANENT.
ADDITIONALLY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ESTIMATED THAT
THERE ARE BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED
AND THREE HUNDRED MILLION
BANKED ALLOWANCES IN THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM. THAT IS
ALLOWANCES THAT HAVE BEEN SAVED
FOR FUTURE COMPLIANCE USE. NOT
WILL BANKING IS NOT INHERENTLY
PROBLEMATIC THE BANK HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTED FOR IN SETTING THE
ADMISSIONS CAP. SO TAKEN
TOGETHER THERE IS A NEED TO RE
CALIBRATE THE EMISSIONS CAP TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS ON
TRACK TO MEET ITS TWENTY THIRTY
GOAL. IS NOT THE ONLY THING THE
STATE NEEDS TO DO BUT IT ISN'T
NECESSARY. THE STATE HAS TO
AGGRESSIVELY INCREASE THE
AMBITION OF ITS POLICY
ESPECIALLY CAP AND TRADE AND IT
MUST HAPPEN AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS STILL
TIME TO GET ON TRACK TO TWENTY
THIRTY. AT THE SAME TIME
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ALSO SEEK
ADDITIONAL MEASURES TO ENSURE
THE STATE IS ACHIEVING
REDUCTIONS IN LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION. ALONGSIDE GLOBAL
CLIMATE POLLUTION. WELL
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
PROGRESS IN IMPROVING AIR
QUALITY IS CHAIR RANDOLPH
EXPLAINED EARLIER TODAY. MUCH
OF THE STATE STILL SUFFERS FROM
DANGEROUS AIR POLLUTION AND
THIS PROBLEM IS ESPECIALLY
ACUTE IN COMMUNITIES WITH LOWER
WEALTH IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WASHINGTON
STATE ADOPTED THEIR CLIMATE
COMMITMENTS ACT WHICH INCLUDES
AIR QUALITY PROVISIONS THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD CONSIDER
INCLUDING. PERCENT DISABILITY
SPECIFIC LIMITATIONS ON OFFSET
MEANS ENFORCEABLE CRITERIA
POLLUTANT TARGETS THE
COMMUNITIES HISTORICALLY
OVERBURDENED BY POLLUTION. AND
REGULAR PROGRAM REVIEWS TO
ENSURE PROGRESS IN REDUCING
BOTH CLIMATE AND CONVENTIONAL
POLLUTION. WASHINGTON HAS BUILT
ON CALIFORNIA'S EXCEPTIONAL
CLIMATE LEADERSHIP AND IS NOW
EXPLORING ADDITIONAL WAYS TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE AND LOCAL
POLLUTION IN THE SAME POLICY
FRAMEWORK. NOW NEEDING THE
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL ALSO HAS
SIGNIFICANT IMPLICATIONS FOR
MEETING A NO LATER THAN TWENTY
FORTY FIVE NET ZERO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION GOAL WHICH CARD IS
ALREADY PLANNING FOR IN IN THE
SCOPING PLAN IN WHICH YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT TODAY.
ACHIEVING THE TWENTY THIRTY
GOAL PUTS US ON TRACK TO
ACHIEVE NET ZERO EMISSIONS. AND
IS CARB IS DOING WE HAVE TO
START PLANNING FOR NET ZERO
TODAY. DECISIONS MADE NOW WITH
OUR I AM TWENTY THIRTY HAVE TO
BE CONSISTENT WITH THE NEED TO
ACHIEVE NET ZERO AS SWIFTLY AS
POSSIBLE. WE ALSO HAVE TO
ENSURE STRATEGIES TO MEET BOTH
GOALS PRESERVE ENVIRONMENTAL
INTEGRITY. AND GOOD AT AN
ABSOLUTE MINIMUM STRATEGIES DO
NOT CREATE OR EXACERBATE AIR
POLLUTION HOT SPOTS. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS A LONG TERM VISION OUT TO
TWENTY FORTY FIVE ALONGSIDE AN
AMBITIOUS PLAN TO MEET THE
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL. AT A TIME
WHEN THE STATE IS ON FIRE
AROUND US AND THE I. P. C. C.
IS ISSUING A CODE RED ALERT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
ENSURE IT IS MAXIMIZING ITS
CLIMATE AMBITION AND THE
GREATEST POSSIBLE AMOUNT OF
EMISSION REDUCTIONS FROM
POLLUTING SOURCES. OUR STATE
HAS A LONG BEEN A CLIMATE
LEADER STATES AND NOW EVEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE
FOLLOWING OUR EXAMPLE BUT WE
MUST ENSURE WE HAVE POLICY IN
PLACE TO ACTUALLY MEET THE
COMMITMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE.
AND THAT WE CONTINUE TO
AGGRESSIVELY LEAD ON CLIMATE
AMBITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY- AND WITH
THAT I WILL I WILL CLOSE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AS A
RUNNER- WE REALLY- PRACTICE- SO
MANY- GREAT SPEAKERS- THIS DID
NOT ALL IN THIS PANEL BUT BUT
THROUGHOUT THE AFTERNOON AND SO
WE REALLY THANK A- ALL OF YOU.
WE HAVE A QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SURVISCOR
SURE JUST YET THANKS WE COVERED
A LOT THERE AS YOU AS YOU SAID-
PROFESSIONAL JUSTICE TO
CONCERNS ON JOBS TO A NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AROUND A CARBON
CAPTURE TO- A TO A YEAR COMING
BACK TO CAP AND TRADE UP AGAIN.
AS A- AS A AS A MECHANISM IN
STRENGTHENING CAPTURE WHICH I
THINK IS ONE OF THE THEMES THAT
WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE SEEN HERE
TODAY. SO I'M JUST TRYING TO
TRY TO THINK WITH MY- TIME HERE-
AT. FIRST PAULINA TORRES WHAT
WAS THAT PHRASE YOU HAD ID FROM
THE REMOTE JUSTICE FROM
IDEATION TO. LIKE THAT PHRASE
SERVICES CENTER WILL BE TRAPPED
CAPTURE THAT. AND HE'S ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THAT. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES YES- OKAY I'M IT'S
THE FROM ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
FROM IDEATION TO IMPLEMENTATION.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S A GOOD FREE
MARKET FOR US TO KEEP IN MIND
AND I WILL KEEP THAT IN MIND I
APPRECIATE THAT- S. R. MENTION
A COUPLE THINGS FROM OUR
FRIENDS. WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF DOUBLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD WHICH IS WE'VE HEARD
IS ONE OF THE MAJOR. SOURCES OF
REDUCTIONS- TODAY AND FOR THE
BUILDING TRADE SUPPORT THERE
AND- UP OF MY ATTEMPTS TO
EXPAND THAT WITH SB SIXTY
SEVEN. WHICH WILL BRING BACK IN
SOME FORM- NEXT YEAR'S I
APPRECIATE. THAT AND- I GUESS
FOR CATHERINE APPRECIATE YOU.
THAT TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW
SOLUTIONS AND BEING SOLUTION.
FOCUSED AND- I GUESS THAT THE
QUESTION IS YOU KNOW. WITH WITH
YOUR MARKETING DO YOU DO YOU
ARE YOU SUPPORT OF A TARGET OF
NET ZERO EMISSIONS BY. BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE IN PHILIP
THAT'S ACHIEVABLE. YES THANK
YOU SENATOR AND YOU KNOW I'M
I'M A COMBINATION OF A PRACTICE
MEDICINE AND OPTIMISTIC- I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE IN THE
SCOPING PLAN AND I THINK THE
FOCUS- THIS HEARING ON THE
SCOPING PLAN IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE ALL OF THOSE
SCENARIOS THAT EVERYONE REFERS
TO. THAT WE WILL BE LOOKING AT
ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS
YOU'RE BALANCING. BE GOALS WITH
THE IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY AND I
SAY THAT. BECAUSE AS WE ALL
KNOW AND I DON'T SAY THIS THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT BE A
LEADER IN THE SPACE OF COURSE
WE SHORT. BUT CALIFORNIA'S LESS
THAN 1% OF THE GLOBAL EMISSIONS
IN THIS WORLD AND SO WE DO HAVE
TO DEMONSTRATE LEADERSHIP
THROUGH PROGRAMS THAT WORK AND
THAT BALANCE THE ECONOMY AND
THE ENVIRONMENT AND OUR SOCIAL
JUSTICE NEEDS ARE OF OUR MIDDLE
JUSTICE NEEDS. THAT'S GOING TO
BE IMPERATIVE. BUT THE ECONOMIC
SIDE OF THIS IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS WE LOOK AT
THESE SCENARIOS AND WE LOOK AT
THE TARGET DATES AND WE LOOK AT
THE SCOPING PLAN. THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ONES THAT CAN THAT IS
THAT HAVE OF MUCH HIGHER COSTS
THAN OTHERS AND YOU CAN STILL
ACHIEVE THE GOALS. IN THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE WAY SO IT'S A
LONG WAY TO SAY THAT I THINK
WHAT CARP HAS OUTLINED GIVES US
MULTIPLE OPPORTUNITY. TO
EXPLORE THE RIGHT COMBINATION
OF WHAT'S GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE
TO MEET THESE GOALS BECAUSE
THEY ARE AGGRESSIVE THEY DO
SHOW LEADERSHIP. BUT WE CAN'T
BRING SO MUCH ECONOMIC CARD ON
THE CONSTITUENTS AND CITIZENS
OF THE STATE. THAT WE CAN'T
HAVE A PROGRAM THAT WILL
SURVIVE AND SO I AM OPTIMISTIC
ARC OUR MEMBERS ARE ALL OVER
INNOVATION IT'S AN EXCITING
TIME- I DIDN'T MENTION ALL OF
THE CCS ACTIVITY WE HAVE IN THE
STATE THAT'S EITHER ON THE
BOOKS ARE BEING DISCUSSED. I
THINK IT'S VERY EXCITING
OPPORTUNITIES AND MANY OF THOSE
ARE ARE NOT IN THE FOSSIL FUEL
SECTOR THEY ARE AND THEY ARE IN
OTHER SECTORS AS WELL SO. WHERE
THERE WERE YOU KNOW INNOVATION
IS AN R. D. AS I'VE SAID BEFORE
OF MANY MANY YEARS AND BEING
OUT THIS FOR FORTY YEARS I CAN
SAY THAT- BUT I DO THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A BALANCE OF ALL OF
IT. AND I DON'T THINK IT'LL BE
A SINGLE ANSWER AND I THINK WE
WILL BE ABLE TO FIND THE RIGHT
PATH. TO GET US THERE IN THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY-
POSSIBLE. YEAH THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND I GUESS YOU SEE. THE
ISSUE IN THE FUTURE WITH PARK
IF WE FAR FEWER- GAS OR DIESEL
POWERED. VEHICLES ON THE ROAD I
THINK YOU AND SHE'S A STRONG
ROLE TO PLAY HE SAID IN
HYDROGEN OR- CCS FIVE FUELS IN
THE FUTURE. BUT HOW HOW DO YOU
THINK THE- INDUSTRY LOOKS LIKE
IN THAT IN THAT RESPECT AND-
YOU KNOW HOW CAN WE WORK
TOGETHER ON SOLUTIONS AND TO.
TO MOVE TO THE FUTURE. YEAH
THANK YOU CENTER AND I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS I LOOK TO IS
A LOT OF THE SCENARIOS THAT
SOME OF THE COMPANIES PUT
TOGETHER WHETHER IT'S SHALL OR-
OR B. P. OR OTHERS. AND THE ONE
THAT A PARTICULAR INTEREST TO
ME IS THE SHELLS AND ARTICLE
THE SKY SCENARIO IS YOU LOOK
FORWARD. KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW
TODAY WE CAN ACTUALLY LOOK INTO
THE FUTURE AND AT LEAST MAP OUT
WHAT WE THINK WILL HAPPEN WHEN
WILL THESE TECHNOLOGIES REALLY
TAKE OFF WHEN WILL THEY
INTERSECT WHEN WILL NATURAL GAS
DECLINED AND HYDROGEN
INCREASED- RENEWABLE DIESEL YOU
HEARD RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AND
RUN. AND HYDROGEN OUR BIG BOB
POTENTIALS IN IN THE WORLD OF
TRANSPORTATION FUELS IN THE
WORLD OF ELECTRICITY SO I THINK
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT TO SAY IT'S
AN EXCITING TIME WE HAVE SO
MUCH INNOVATION GOING ON. I
THINK OUR INDUSTRY IS JUST
ANXIOUS WILLING COMMITTED TO
STEP TO THE PLATE AND TO ENGAGE
IN ALL OF THAT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WITH KERR- WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO FIGURE
OUT. HOW DO WE GET WHERE WE
WANT TO GO IN A WAY THAT KEEPS
THE ECONOMY MOVING. AND ALLOWS
PEOPLE AS I ALWAYS SAY IF AND
PEOPLE GET TIRED OF HEARING IT.
ALLOWS US TO WAKE UP EVERY DAY
AND DRIVE TO BE. TURN OUR
LIGHTS ON AND HEAT AND COOL OUR
HOMES AFFORDABLY AND RELIABLY
IT CLEANLY AND I THINK WE'RE
CAPABLE OF DOING THAT. BUT
WE'VE GOT TO BE PRAGMATIC AND
WE GOT A LOOK AT THE FACT THAT
WE GOT TO SEE WHERE WE ARE AND
WHERE WE NEED TO GO I THINK GOD
CHAIRWOMAN- FROM CAR MADE MADE
THOSE POINTS VERY CLEAR I THINK
WORK WEEK WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
WORK TO DO BUT- THE SCOPING
PLAN IS AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ONE. AND WERE EXTREMELY ENGAGED
AT. FEDERATE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR- SALOON MAYES- THE
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR- THE
QUESTION FOR- KATHY AND I
APOLOGIZE IF YOU ADDRESSED
THIS- DURING YOUR BRIEFING I
WAS ACTUALLY RUNNING BACK UP
FROM- FROM ANOTHER MEETING- BUT
I KNOW THAT EARLIER- IN THE
HEARING TODAY BOTH THE SUMMER
BURKE AND I WERE TALKING ABOUT
THE QUESTION OF EQUITY- KNOWING
THAT FOLKS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
WHERE I REPRESENT RIVERSIDE SAN
BENITO COUNTY DRIVE A LOT- THEY
DRIVE. ME TO THE ANYWHERE FROM
FROM A COUPLE MILES A DAY BUT
MOST FOLKS WILL DRIVE- AN HOUR
HALF AN HOUR AND A HALF TO TWO
AND A HALF HOURS EVERY SINGLE
DAY TO BE ABLE TO GET TO GET TO
WORK AND JUST WANTED TO FIND
OUT IN REGARDS TO OIL- AND
GASOLINE- AND TALK ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION- AND THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR- WHERE
WHERE IS THE INDUSTRY AT- TODAY
WHERE WE AT WITH TRANSPORTATION
AND WHAT IT WHAT ARE YOU GUYS
THINKING. THAT'S GOING TO LOOK
LIKE- OVER THE NEXT- YOU COULD
COUPLE OF YEARS- AND EVEN EVEN
DECADES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE FOR THE QUESTION A FAMILY
MAN AND- YOU CAN REALLY GETTING
INTO THE TRANSPORTATIONS THE
DEMAND SIDE OF THE SENATE IT'S
OUR JOB. FRED IT'S OUR JOB TO
PROVIDE THE ENERGY CONSUMERS
DEMAND. BECAUSE THEY DO THAT
EVERY DAY RIGHT WE'VE GOT.
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE THAT DRIVE
THIRTY SIX MILLION CARS AND
TRUCKS- AND EVEN THOUGH THE
GOVERNOR PLANS TO BAN THE SALE
OF INTERNAL COMBUSTION TO
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. WE'RE STILL
GOING TO HAVE CLOSE TO THAT
AMOUNT. FOR SOMETIME TO COME
THAT HAVE TO BE FUELED. AND I
KNOW THIS LEGISLATURE IS GOING
TO DEMAND THAT WE DO THAT. WE
ARE GOING TO AND WHAT WORK AND
WILL HAVE TO DO IT IS YOU KNOW
CLEAN AND BEST AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ECONOMY CONTINUES TO MOVE. IT
IS A FACT THAT THIS STATE IS
THE THIRD LARGEST CONSUMER OF
TRANSPORTATION FUELS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S ALL OF US.
YOU KNOW THAT EVERYBODY IN THE
STATE WE ARE THE THIRD LARGEST
CONSUMER. AND THE ONLY ONE WHO
IS ABOVE US IS THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND CHINA. SO
WE WILL IT'S A IT'S A BIG ISSUE
AND- YES WE'RE MAKING GREAT
STRIDES IN ELECT AND IN
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. BUT WE STILL
ONLY HAVE LESS THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THEM AND SO. THE
TIMING OF THIS IS VERY VERY
CRITICAL WE ARE TOTALLY
INVESTED IN MAKING LIQUID
FUELS. AS CLEAN AS POSSIBLE.
WE'RE TOTALLY INVESTED IN
THINGS LIKE RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS RENEWABLE DIESEL HYDROGEN.
WE ALSO ARE VERY INVESTED. IN
AND FIVE THOUSAND THIS
COMMITTEE AS PART OF MY
COMMENTS. WRITEN COMMENTS AS
THE GERMAN SUGGESTED. THE
INNOVATIONS INITIATIVE WE PUT
TOGETHER THAT CATALOGS WHAT
THIS INDUSTRY IS DOING IN WIND
AND SOLAR AND INVESTING IN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE. RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT AND ELECTRIC
VEHICLE. CHARGING STATIONS. ALL
OF THAT IS WONDERFUL OPTIMISTIC
AND INNOVATIVE WHILE WE STILL
HAVE TO KEEP ORDER FIRST AND
FOREMOST. WE'VE GOT FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
WAKE UP TOMORROW AND DRIVE
SOMEWHERE AND SO. IT IS YOU
KNOW GASOLINE DIESEL JET FUEL
ARE GOING TO BE WITH US TO YOUR
POINT. FOR QUITE A WHILE AS
WE'RE DOING THIS. AS FAST AS
FAR. AND YOU'RE SEEING IT THE
CAP AND TRADE. LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD THEY ARE DELIVERING
THE INNOVATIONS. YOU HAVE TO
REFINERS- JUST CONVERTED A
HYDROCARBON. BASED OUR
REFINERIES IN THE BAY AREA TWO
WERE LOCALS COMPLETELY
RENEWABLES SO. THE INNOVATION
IS STARTING IT IS IT IS
HAPPENING YOU'VE GOT WONDERFUL
INNOVATION HAPPENING WITH OUR
OUR INDUSTRY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY YOU'VE GOT CHEVRON AND
SHELL. YOU KNOW AND NEW ENERGY
AND MICROSOFT AND CLEAN ENERGY
WHO JUST ANNOUNCED PLANS ON A
BIOENERGY CCS PROJECT. TO GIVE
CARBON NEGATIVE POWER TO
MENDOTA. THAT'S EXCITING.
YOU'VE GOT DODD C. R. C. WHO IS
ANNOUNCED A SUSTAINABILITY GOAL
TO CAPTURE THEIR CARBON FROM A
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY MEGAWATT
POWER PLANT NOW KILLS SO. ALL
OF THESE GET AT THE METRIC TONS
THAT WE HAVE TO GET. IN A
COMBINATION. OF EVERYTHING IN
EVERY SECTOR SO. I HOPE THAT
BEGINS TO ANSWERED I SEE GREAT
INNOVATION FOR THE FUTURE I SEE
OUR COMPANIES ALL OVER IT. AND
IT'S EXCITING BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO REMEMBER WE GOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE HERE. THAT WE ARE
REQUIRED TO SUPPLY FUEL. IN ALL
OF THESE SECTORS AND- YOU KNOW
I THINK SOUTHWEST JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT A GREAT THING
FOR RENEWABLE JET FUEL SO
AGAIN. SO MUCH GOING ON I'M
VERY OPTIMISTIC BUT WE MUST
KEEP A REALISTIC CONVERSATION
GOING REAL TALK I THINK AS
SOMEONE SAID EARLIER. ABOUT
WHAT THE FACTS ARE OF WHERE WE
ARE AND WHERE WE NEED TO GO.
AGAIN IN THE FUTURE IF I CAN-
KATHY THANK YOU FOR THAT- I
KNOW- YOU KNOW FOR ME BECAUSE A
LOT OF FOLKS IN MY- DISTRICT IN
MY REGION THE DRIVE GAS POWERED
VEHICLES I DO BOTH OF MY
VEHICLES ARE BOTH GAS. A GAS
POWERED. I'M SO EVERY TIME I GO
TO THE GAS TANK AND I AND I
PHILIP. IT'S THE MISSIONS THAT
ARE COMING OUT OF MY TAIL PIPE
THAT I AM I'M ACTUALLY PUTTING.
CARBON INTO THE ATMOSPHERE
THAT'S THAT'S ON. A FOR- FOR
DOING I THINK WE ALL HAVE TO.
HAVE TO RELY BUT I DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER OPTION BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE. AN ELECTRIC POWERED
POWERED VEHICLE- AND IF I CAN
ASK MAYBE DIFFICULT QUESTION-
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW I WAS- IN
CONSERVATIVE POLITICS- BACK IN.
THE NINETEEN NINETIES- AND I
REMEMBER BACK IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES. I THAT THERE WAS AN
AWFUL LOT OF TALK IN FACT HAD
SEVERAL FRIENDS. THAT WORKED
FOR DIFFERENT GROUPS- THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SKEW. OF THE
PUBLIC RELATIONS IN REGARDS TO-
THE QUESTION OF CLIMATE CHANGE-
I KNOW THAT- THE OIL ALMOND BIG
OIL BIG OIL'S REALLY BAD I
GUESS BIG WHEELS REALLY BAD
ALTHOUGH I USED A PRODUCT BIG
WHEELS REALLY BAD- BUT IN THAT.
IT IN THE NINETIES- A BIG OIL
WAS FUNDING- SOME OF THAT WE
KNOW THAT WE KNOW THAT THAT IS
THAT IS TRUE. I MYSELF- IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES DID NOT
BELIEVE THAT CLIMATE CHANGE.
WAS WAS REAL THE IN THE TWO
THOUSANDS I DIDN'T BELIEVE THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE. I WAS REAL OF
COURSE IS A MANY ARE AWARE- I
ENDED UP HAVING SORT OF A
RECKONING AFTER I WENT LOOKED
AT THE SCIENCE MYSELF AND SAID
NO ACTUALLY. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY REAL WE HAVE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THAT
ARE INCREASING IT'S MY BEHAVIOR
THAT IS CAUSING- THAT- AND-
I'VE COME TO THE REALIZATION-
OR EVOLUTION YOU MIGHT SAY.
THAT I HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. I'VE ALSO
SEEN THAT- WITH. WITH BIG OIL
AS WELL. IN FACT A COUPLE YEARS
AGO I REMEMBER BEING- IN- IN
THE NETHERLANDS. ACT THAT DOES
SHOW FOR THE RESEARCH FACILITY
AND I WAS SHOCKED TO SEE. THAT
A COMPANY LIKE SHELL WAS SAYING
THAT THERE'S GOT TO BE THAT WE
ARE PART OF THE PROBLEM- AND
WE'VE GOT ALSO GOT TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION IN FACT WE'RE
TALK TALKING ABOUT AN
INTERNATIONAL GLOBAL PRICE ON
CARBON. IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY
IS LIKE FIFTY DOLLARS SO IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT BIG OIL'S COME
AROUND TO THIS IDEA. THAT
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE AND SO
IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE MAYBE A FOR
US AS POLICYMAKERS. INSTEAD OF
THINKING OF BIG WELL THE
PROBLEM MAYBE WE- ALL. THINK OF
BIG OIL AS MAYBE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. AS WELL TO HELPS
MITIGATE- THIS THIS EXISTENTIAL
CRISIS THAT'S FACING US GIVE
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT. I YES
THANK YOU. YOU ARTICULATED THAT
QUITE WELL AND WE ARE VERY
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THIS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE. IT'S
WHY I PERSONALLY WITH MY
COLLEAGUE WENT TO COP TWENTY
FIVE- IN MADRID IT'S. BECAUSE
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
PART OF THE SOLUTION- WE WANT
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION WE
CANNOT KEEP TALKING PAST EACH
OTHER WE MUST TALK WITH EACH
OTHER. BECAUSE IT IS ONLY OUR
COLLECTIVE THINKING ON THIS IN
MY OPINION THAT WILL SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AND THAT'S ALL OF US IN
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL PART OF IT
WE'RE ALL PART OF THOSE ISSUES
A PART OF THE PROBLEM AS YOU
SAID- AND WE HAVE TO ENGAGE. IN
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION ON HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DEAL WITH THIS.
MY ONLY PLEASE IS THAT WE DO
HAVE A PRAGMATIC SIDE OF THAT
CONVERSATION THAT ALSO LOOKS AT
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT AND I'M NOT
SAYING ECONOMICS ABOVE
ENVIRONMENTAL I'M SAYING
ECONOMICS IN IN BALLOTS WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND WITH THE
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES THAT WEEK
WE HAVE TO COME TO TERMS WITH
BECAUSE IT'S- IT'S- ALL OF
THEM. AND IT IN THAT AND I
TRULY BELIEVE WE ALMOST HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ALL HEARD WE ALL USE OUR
COLLECTIVE THINKING. THAT WE
DON'T ALL NOBODY HAS THE CORNER
WAS DUMB I CERTAINLY DON'T OUR
INDUSTRY CERTAINLY DOESN'T AND
BUT WE DO BRING TO THE TABLE IN
MY OPINION. JUST AMAZING
INNOVATION AND AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR HOW WE CAN ADDRESS THIS
TOGETHER SO I'M- THAT'S MY
OPTIMISTIC SIDE AND THEN MY
PRAGMATIC SIDE IS TO JUST MAKE
SURE WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
FACTS OF THE SITUATION WHERE WE
ARE WHERE WE NEED TO GO
BECAUSE- IT ISN'T EASY. WE JUST
CANNOT SWITCH OFF YOU KNOW FLIP
A SWITCH AND HAVE THIS ALL
HAPPEN TOMORROW WHEN YOU'VE GOT
SUCH A WIDE RANGE OF. OF WHERE
WE ARE AND WHERE WE NEED TO GO
BUT THAT'S WHY I THINK THE PART
SCOPING PLAN IS A GOOD ONE IT
IS TO LOOK AT ALL THOSE DETAILS
BUT THAT ON THE TABLE AND FIND
A PATH WE CAN ALL AGREE WITH.
AND NOBODY'S GONNA BE HAPPY
IT'S GONNA BE A PATH THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S COMPROMISE ON ALL
SIDES AND I THINK WHEN WE DO%
THAT. WE WILL- IF WE BALANCE
ECONOMY AND ENVIRONMENT AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND EQUITY WE
WILL HAVE THE PROGRAM. IT'S
ONLY ONE WAY DON'T TAKE THE
BALANCED APPROACH THAT WE END
UP HAVING TOPIC. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF HIS CHAIR. THANK YOU-
EVERYONE HI I AM. I MEAN I HAVE
I I'VE JOTTED DOWN SO MANY
NOTES FROM EACH ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS AND I COULD TO YOU
KNOW CONTINUE THIS OF THIS
CONVERSATION FOR HOURS BUT THAT
WE ARE LIMITED IN TIME AND SO I
JUST WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK ALL ALL OF
OUR OF OUR OUR SPEAKERS ON ON
ON THE THIRD PANEL AND- LIKE A-
IS REYES VOID- JUST. STATED
THIS IS A CONVERSATION THIS TO
TAKE ALL OF US TO. TO CONTINUE
TO PRESENT PARTICIPATE RIGHT
WERE. WERE ARE NOT GONNA HAVE
ANY EASY SOLUTIONS- TODAY BUT
THE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOU FOR- DISSIPATING AND
TODAY'S CONVERSATION- SO I'D
LIKE TO MOVE ON THEN- TO-
PUBLIC COMMENT. AGAIN EACH.
PERSON WHO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT- IS LIMITED TO A
MINUTE- AND- WE WILL START WITH
THOSE- OF YOU HERE AND THE
HEARING ROOM IN PERSON THEN
WILL GO TO THOSE APPEARING
REMOTELY ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL- IF ANY. AND
FINALLY TO THOSE A CALLING AND
BY PHONE SO I LIKE TO START TO-
WITH THEM- IT DOESN'T PERSON.
SIR OF PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JASON
LINDSAY ON THE OF PRESIDENT
BUSINESS AGENT OF IRONWORKERS
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT. MY
QUESTION IS WHY ARE WE NOT
TRIPLING DOWN ON RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT AND GREEN HYDROGEN-
RENEWABLES NATURAL GAS AND YES
DARE I SAY IT NUCLEAR AND FOR
HIM- WE NEED A SOLID PLAN IN
PLACE TO TRANSITION FROM ONE
ENERGY SOURCE TO ANOTHER-
OTHERWISE IT'S ONLY HAVE BACON
DOOMED TO FEEL DUE TO FAIL.
THERE ARE FIVE REFINERIES IN MY
JURISDICTION- ALWAYS HERE
LOCALLY IS ONE SIDE SAYING SHUT
IT DOWN AND US SAYING SAVE OUR
JOBS- EVERY PART OF OUR SOCIETY
IS EMBEDDED WITH PRODUCTS MADE
FROM FOSSIL FUELS FROM THE
CLOTHES WE WEAR. TO THE CHAIRS
YOU ARE SITTING IN- IF WE FLIP
THE SWITCH OR MAKE IT SO HARD
FOR THIS INDUSTRY TO OPERATE IT
WOULD BE THE EQUIVALENT OF
QUITTING A JOB BEFORE WE HAVE
ANOTHER ONE IN PLACE. THE OIL
USAGE WON'T STOP IT WILL ONLY
COME FROM DIRTY OR SOURCES AND
COST A LOT MORE MONEY. FURTHER
DRIVING A WEDGE BETWEEN THE
HAVES AND THE HAVE NOTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. EXPECT A
PLACE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MIKE
WESTON I REPRESENT THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES I APPRECIATE
DR FAMILIES- CLASSIFICATION AS
CLIMATE CHANGE BEING A
WORLDWIDE- CRISIS- THE FOR
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTIONS IN OUR
WORLD HISTORY CAME FROM COAL
AND THE STEAM ENGINE FROM
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SO THE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTIES. FOSSIL FUEL
EXTRACTION THE CONDUCT INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE FOLLOWED UP
WITH A BY MANUFACTURING
INCREASES AND IN THE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTIES TO THE NINETEEN
FORTIES THE THIRD ONE BEING
ELECTRONICS AND NUCLEAR-
INNOVATIONS FROM THE NINETEEN
FORTIES TO THE NINETEEN
NINETIES AND THE NE THAT WERE
IN CURRENTLY IS CALLED THE
INTERNET AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION THE
INTERNET LAUNCHED ON APRIL
THIRTIETH NINETEEN NINETY THREE
AND IS JUST TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
OLD. I HAVE CHILDREN THAT ARE
OLDER THAN THAT- THEN THE-
INNER INCEPTION OF THE INTERNET
WE DIDN'T THROW OUT ALL OF OUR
ENCYCLOPEDIAS BEFORE WE GOT THE
INTERNET AND SO BOTH THE
SCIENTIFIC AND COMMON SENSE
PLAN TO ACHIEVE CARBON
REDUCTION GOALS WILL BE THE
BEST SOLUTION FOR OUR STATE OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR JOBS UNTIL FARM
EQUIPMENT HEAVY HIGHWAY
EQUIPMENT CONSTRUCTION
EQUIPMENT AND INTERSTATE
TRUCKING OR ELECTRIFIED AND THE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
SUPPORTED BY OUR ALREADY
FRAGILE POWER GRID. WE CANNOT
JUST SIMPLY SHUT DOWN THE
FOSSIL FUEL EXTRACTION AND
REFINING HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE
COST TO INCREASE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BY INCREASED FUEL COSTS
WILL CONTINUE TO DRIVE THOSE
HOME PRICES OUT OF REACH FOR
MOST PEOPLE INCLUDING THOSE
WERE IN THE BUILDING TRADES
MANY OF WHICH COMMUTE TWO PLUS
HOURSEACH WAY TO THE JOB SITE
THEY WORK ON IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE AN AFFORDABLE HOUSE FOR
THEIR FAMILY THANK YOU. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THANKS SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON KEVIN
FERRER THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SACRAMENTAL SEARS
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES. AND WE'RE
ASKING THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER THAT. BALIK
ELECTRIFICATION OF OUR
BUILDINGS AND CARS WILL
COLLAPSE THE POWER GRID
BLACKOUTS AND BROWNOUTS ARE
BECOMING THE NEW NORM FOR FEAR
OF OVER STRESSING OUR POWER
GRIDS. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR CO CHAIR OF ROB STOKER
REPRESENTING SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR AND
ALSO PRESIDENT OF THE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALAMEDA COUNTY. SO CARBON
NEUTRALITY SHOULD BE OF THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY BUT HOW AND
WHEN WE GET THERE IS EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED AND SIX METRIC TONS OF
CARBON WAS EMITTED INTO THE AIR
NOT FROM PLANES TRAINS AND
AUTOMOBILES BUT FROM WILDFIRES.
WE MUST NOT CREATE POLICY AND
TIME LINES THAT WILL HAVE
DEVASTATING UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR BLUE COLLAR
WORKING WOMEN AND MEN. I
LEARNED AS EARLY AS A SHEET
METAL APPRENTICE THAT YOU USE
EVERY TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX THAT
MEANS CARBON CAPTURE RENEWABLE
POWERS AND FUELS AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES. WE NEED TO BE
THOUGHTFUL AND STRATEGIC ON OUR
PATH TO CARBON NEUTRALITY SO
THAT WORKING FAMILIES ARE
DEVASTATED AND LEFT BEHIND
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON THERE'S A MUG REALLY
IN WITH PAIR'S NOW TRACED HER
COUNSEL SIXTEEN. SOLIDARY WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES I
THINK IS IMPORTANT WHEN WE DO
OR DON'T CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES THOUGH KEEP IN MIND
THE FINANCIAL BURDEN THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA WHAT THE BEARS
RESOLVE THESE POLICIES.
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY ONE OF THE
MOST EXPENSIVE STATES TO RESIDE
IN OUR HOMES POPULATION
SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL MOST
WORKING FAMILIES CANNOT AFFORD
THE BILLS THAT THEY CURRENTLY
HAVE LET ALONE THE COST OF AN
ELECTRIC CAR. OR TO HAVE THEIR
LECTURED BUILDING THEIR COMMUTE
COSTS CONTINUE TO INCREASE WE
NEED TO BE CAREFUL NOT TO MAKE
IT MORE EXPENSIVE FOR THE
WORKING FAMILIES THEY'RE BARELY
HANGING ON WHILE MANY MIGHT BE
ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM BEING
HOMELESS THEMSELVES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS RESTING
JOHNSON I'M SPEAKING HERE TODAY
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. THE LARGEST
COALITION TRADE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE THE ONLY PATHWAY TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND SOME
CALIFORNIA'S MOST REAL
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING SOME OF
THOSE HIT BY THE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES MADE WORSE BY THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. AS
WE LOOK TOWARDS THE FUTURE MARY
NEEDS THE FOLLOWING INVESTMENTS
ELECTRICAL GRID HARDENING.
EXPANSION EVEY CHARGING
NETWORKS INVESTMENTS IN WIND
ENERGY CARBON CAPTURE PUBLIC
STORAGE INC RETIRED GEN. WITH
ALL THESE INVESTMENTS WE NEED
THE LEGISLATURE TO REQUIRE
STRICT LABOR STANDARDS OF MOST
PERFORMING THE WORK.
REQUIREMENTS THAT GO BEYOND
PREVAILINGWAGE DEMAND SKILLED
AND TRAINED LANGUAGE DEMANDING
GATES SPENT WITH WORKERS
THROUGH PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS COMMITTEE WORKFORCE
IMPROVEMENTS AN ECCENTRIC.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SLOVAK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MITCHELL BECHTEL I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF THE IRON WORKERS
LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN AND TO STAND
IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES. IT'S MY HOPE
THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL
CONSIDER INVESTING IN
INCENTIVIZING MORE RESEARCH
INTO CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
FOR INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
FOUNDATIONAL IN NATURE. HI A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THE
CONCRETE INDUSTRY THIS IS THE
THIRD LARGEST PRODUCER OF CO
TWO IN THE WORLD. RIGHT THE
NEED FOR SUSTAINABLE RESOURCES
IS GREATER THAN EVER AND WE
SHOULD BE FINDING WAYS TO
UPCYCLE AND INCORPORATE-
CAPTURED CARBON INTO CONCRETE
AND OTHER BUILDING TRADES
MATERIALS. CURRENT MODELS
ESTIMATE THAT NEARLY 70% OF THE
AGGREGATE USING CONCRETE AS
LIMESTONE. BUT THERE ARE
COMPANIES TODAY IN CALIFORNIA
THAT CREATE SYNTHETIC FIND
STOLEN THROUGH CAPTURED CARBON
RIGHT THIS IS A PERFECT
MARRIAGE. HI YOU KNOW THIS
TECHNOLOGY HAS ALREADY BEEN
ANALYZED TESTED AND IMPLEMENTED
ON HUGE MAJOR PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- WHAT
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FOR IS FOR
YOU GUYS TO PUSH THAT PUBLIC
INVESTMENT. TO INCENTIVIZE
COMPANIES TO USE THIS STUFF
THANK YOU GUYS THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY MORE SPEAKERS IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SAYING NONE OF
LIKE TO TURN IT- TO ANY.
SPEAKERS APPEARING REMOTELY ON
THE NORTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL.
I DON'T SEE. ANYONE STEPPING
FORWARD FOR SHOWING ON THE
SCREEN. LAST BUT NOT LEAST ANY.
PUBLIC COMMENTS FROM THOSE
CALLING IN BY PHONE AGAIN THE
PHONE NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957
ACCESS CODE. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. SERRET
OPERATOR. YES MICHAEL LINE
NUMBER OF SEVENTY TWO AGAIN
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS IS BILL MCGOVERN WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
AND I THINK THAT IT'S EALLY
TRUE THAT WE ARE AT THIS POINT
NOT ON TRACK TO REACH THE SB
THIRTY TO TARGET SO LET ME
FOCUS ON A FEW THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. SHOULD DO TO
ADDRESS THAT- ONE I THINK IS
YOU COULD PAST CHAIRMAN BIRDS
TO CHOOSE BILL AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. AT THE BROAD LEVEL
AND THEN LOOKING AT THE SECTORS
WHERE WE NEED THE MOST HELP.
BUT TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS
HAVE BEEN GROWING AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE COULD HELP. BY
TAKING ACTION TO HELP PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS TO
REDUCE THE MILES TRAVELED BY
OUR VEHICLES CAN ALSO BY
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE INCENTIVE
FUNDING. FOR THE TURNOVER OF
OLDER DIRTIER VEHICLES TO QUEEN
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION- THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET PROVIDED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THAT FUNDING INCLUDING
BY RE AUTHORIZING THE AB EIGHT
PROGRAM. THE INDUSTRIAL SECTOR
ALSO NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
BY DIRECT EMISSION REDUCTIONS
RATHER THAN OUTSOURCING INITIAL
REDUCTIONS TO OTHER STATES AND
OTHER COUNTRIES DIRECT
PRODUCTIONS ARE MORE EFFECTIVE
AND MORE EQUITABLE AND THEY ARE
NOT ABOUT. RAISING COSTS FOR
LONG DISTANCE COMMUTERS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. X.
COLUMN LINE NUMBER OF EIGHTY
ONE CANALI NUMBER EIGHTY ONE
YEAR LATER OPEN. HI THIS IS
JASON VARGAS WITH THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS THANKS FOR
THE HEARING TODAY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT- YOU GOT
SOME MEMBERS THAT KNOWLEDGE
THERE LATER IN THE HEARING- YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA'S LONG BEEN A
LEADER IN ADDRESSING THE THREAT
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. BUT THE
TRUTH IS THAT OUR OUR CLUB
CURRENT AMBITION IS AN
INSUFFICIENT RESPONSE TO THE
CASCADING EMERGENCY OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. IN FACT MANY OTHER
STATES AND COUNTRIES ARE NOW
MORE AMBITIOUS AND A GLOBAL
WARMING EMISSIONS REDUCTION
TARGETS CALIFORNIA. EVEN THE BY
THE MINISTRATIONS TARGET FOR
TWENTY THIRTY IT'S MORE
AMBITIOUS THE. CALIFORNIA SB
THIRTY TWO AND- CALIFORNIA
AGREE WITH MANY OF THE SPEAKER
THAT- I THANK YOU SEE AT THE
TWENTY THE SPEAKERS TODAY THAT.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ON TRACK TO
MEET THE STATE'S EXISTING
TWENTY THIRTY ONE. I AFFECT WE
BELIEVE THAT ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT OBJECTIVES THAT THAT
THE OPEN PLAN UPDATE. IT A
GREAT AMBITIOUS AND DETAILED
PLANS. TO MEET EMISSION
REDUCTION LIMITS BY TWENTY
THIRTY- WE WILL- ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE AND I'M GONNA GO
BACK ON THE GATHERED THAT THE
MOST IMPORTANT STEP- OVER THE
LEGISLATURE BLACK MONTH. IT'S
PAST EIGHTY THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE TO CODIFY THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO ACHIEVE NET ZERO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS NO
LATER THAN TWENTY POINT FIVE.
CONTRIBUTE. TO GLOBAL EFFORTS
TO KEEP WARMING BELOW TWO
DEGREES CELSIUS. CALIFORNIA
REALLY MARKET AGGRESSIVELY
ACCELERATED COMMITMENT TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS. I CAN CREATE
THE OPPORTUNITY. I AM NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY NOT JUST FOCUSED
SOLELY A TECHNOLOGICAL SHIFT
BUT ALSO THE SYSTEMIC CHANGES
THAT ONE MIGHT GREATER CLIMATE
AMBITION AND- THEIR OUTCOMES
FOR ALL. THANK YOU AGAIN THANK
YOU. LOCALI NUMBER EIGHTY THREE
ARE DEADLINE NUMBER EIGHT THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY AND- I KEEP FINDING IN
THE NEWLY RELEASED AUDI T
REPORTED THAT METHANE EMISSIONS
AMID HUGE CONTRIBUTION TO
CURRENT FORMING. 3250% OF THE
CURRENT RISE IN TEMPERATURES OF
COD BY THIS POWERFUL THE SHORE
THE GAS. AND AS YOU WELL KNOW
ANIMAL AGRICULTURE PARTICULARLY
CONFINED ANIMAL FEEDING
OPERATIONS ARE CAPABLE ARE
MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO METHANE
EMISSIONS AND THEIR LOCATIONS
CREATES SERIOUS COMMUNITY
HEALTH HAZARDS WHICH EQUITABLY
HARM BONOBO CALIFORNIANS. TODAY
CALIFORNIA'S PRIMARY
INVESTMENT- BAG METHANE
EMISSIONS HAVE BEEN BURIED I
JESTERS FACILITIES THAT CREATE
BIOGAS FROM THE NEWER EMISSIONS
AT LARGE PAPERS. AND WE JOINT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COLLEAGUES IN COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE IN OPPOSING
FURTHER TAXPAYER AND RATEPAYER
INVESTMENT BECAUSE BIO GAS IS
NOT CLEAN. DIGEST OR DO NOT
ADDRESS ENTERIC EMISSIONS FROM
CALIBER OTHER GHG EMISSIONS
FROM DERRY AND ONLY VERY LARGE
DAIRIES CAN PROVIDE ENOUGH
MINORITY GIVE DIED AFTER
TECHNOLOGY ANY PRAYER PENCILING
OUT ECONOMICALLY. SO THAT MEANS
THAT DIGEST CERTAIN CENTER BY
JERRY TO GET BIGGER AND MORE
CONCENTRATED IN ADDING MORE AND
MORE ENTERIC METHANE CAUSING
SERIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
PARTICULARLY IN NEARBY
COMMUNITIES. CONTAMINATING
GROUNDWATER EMITTING AIR
CONTAMINANTS BEYOND METHANE
ATTRACTING HEAVY DUTY TRUCK
TRAFFIC AND PRODUCING ODORS ALL
OF THESE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
TO PRODUCE A GAS THAT EMITS
CARBON. DIOXIDE UPON COMBUSTION.
HELLO HAS BEEN ON THE ADMIT
THEY RELAX STRATEGY AND WE
SHOULD OUR LOS. WE URGE YOU ALL
IN THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION TO RESIST THE
MAN'S FOR FURTHER INVESTMENT IN
DIRTY DEAL FROM DIED YESTERDAY
AT THE FINALIZED THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OUR MY NUMBER NINETY
FOUR RB SEVENTY FOUR LINE
NUMBER SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MARK
FENSTER MAKE ON BEHALF OF THE
JUSTICE.
FOR FAMOUS DURING THE
ELECTRIC SECTORWITH THE PUG
CONTINUES TO USE SCIENTIFICALLY
INDEFENSIBLE EMISSION TARGETS.
ARE A NEW SENATE APPLICATION OF
BACHELOR TELERIK THOSE TARGETS.
IN CHAIR INSERTED BLUMENFELD
HAS NOTED THAT THE GOVERNMENT
INTERESTED IN SEEING. 90% CLEAN
ELECTRICITY BY TWENTY THIRD.
ACTUALLY IN THIS PLAN AND THAT
CARD IN THE PROCESS OF.
CALIFORNIA MUST USUALLY THREE
ZERO CARBON STEREO WHICH
ENSURES THAT AGGRESSIVE DIRECT
EMISSION REDUCTION ARE
PRIORITIZED. THE BASIC
PRINCIPLES OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE REQUIRE CALIFORNIA TO
ELIMINATE THE HARMS THAT COME
COMBUSTION FIRST AND FOREMOST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
NOT GONNA LIE NUMBER NINETY ONE
AGAIN LINE NUMBER NINE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU- MY
NAME'S TOM BUT I'M WITH THE SAN
DIEGO BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL- I'M ALL LIFE
LONG- CAREER AS BEST AS WORKER
AND- I JUST WANT TO BRING YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE FACT THAT
BAMBAM FADES OUT PROCESS THIS
WAS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE-
IT WAS A SLOW METHODICAL-
REPLACEMENT OF THE SPECIFIED
BRING CONSTRUCTION. AND IT MADE
SENSE AND- AND THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD. THAT BEING SAID.
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE BANNING
FOSSIL FUELS WITHOUT A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN WILL HAVE A
DEVASTATING EFFECT ON
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN THE
FUTURE- THERE ARE TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE COMING TO THE NEED TO
FULLY DEVELOP BUT- AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT YOU TAKE YOUR VERY
SLOW AND METHODICAL STOOD UP TO
MAKE SURE THAT WORKERS ARE PART
OF THE EQUATION- MANY OF US
HAVE BEEN IN THE- ISRAEL LONG
TIME. AND- WE REALLY NEED YOU
TO MAKE SURE THE WERE PROTECTED
SO THAT WE CAN GET TO THE
FINISH LINE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I'M NOT GONNA LIE NUMBER
SEVENTY SEVEN AGAIN LINE NUMBER
SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS IS JAMES
COLLECTOR AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
WAIVERS. UNCONJUGATED ECHO THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY ANGIE
MEREDITH IN THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES. WE DO SUPPORT A
PRAGMATIC AND INCLUSIVE
APPROACH TO ACHIEVING OUR STATE
CRIME MAKING GHG REJECT WE GOT
TEN GOALS. WILL BE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER A GREAT BURST ENERGY
PORTFOLIO. INCLUDES GREEN
HYDROGEN SOLAR ENERGY CARBON
CAPTURE. AND ANOTHER EFFECTIVE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WERE
MENTIONED- ABOUT TODAY'S
HEARING. IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
CONSIDER THE IMPLICATIONS ANY
TRANSITION WHAT HAPPENED
WORKING CLASS FAMILIES. TO
REITERATE THESE MEN AND WOMEN
JUST WANT TO KEEP THE GOOD
PAYING UNION JOBS WE WANT TO
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE A STRONG
FUTURE IN CALIFORNIA AND
FINALLY. THIS ONE ARE ELECTED
LEADERS TO CONSIDER THEM WHEN
THEY CRAFTING A DOCTOR'S NEW
CLIMATE POLICY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NOW GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY TWO AGAIN
LINE NUMBER NINE TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MORNING
COME ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY.
IT'S CLEAR THE CALIFORNIA NEEDS
MORE AGGRESSIVE EMISSION
REDUCTION POLICIES TO ACHIEVE
OUR CLIMATE TARGETS FONG AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE POLICY SHOULD
PRIORITIZE DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS BUT THEY SHOULD ALSO
PRIORITIZE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR ONLINE
COMMUNITIES. I WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS AND CONCERNS
RAISED BY PUTTING A CARD WITH
THE THERAPY WE ALSO HAVE
CONCERNS OVER THE POTENTIAL
EVIDENCE THAT COULD BE QUITE
OFTEN COULD NOT DUE TO CHECK ON
THE TARGET AND URGES
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE. SUCH
TECHNOLOGIES WILL NOT RESULT IN
A SCENARIO WHERE YOU. THREE THE
FINANCIAL GIVEN A LIFE. OVER
THE- IT'S ACTUALLY CONSIDERING.
CURRENT ARCHITECT. THE BILL.
WHICH DON'T ACTUALLY REMOVE THE
MISSION ECONOMY THE FINANCE
CARE AND HAVE IN FACT LEAD TO
MORE POLLUTION. IN THE CHAIR
LOT OF THE- TO CONDUCT.
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS AND CARBON
INTENSIVE METHODS TO EXTRACT
OIL. THE REASON I KEEP THE
REQUIREMENT TO CLEAR THEM UP
RAPIDLY STOP. NEW ADDITIONAL
PEER TO MOTIONS AND ENTERING
THE ATMOSPHERE. HELLO NINETY
LIKE TECHNOLOGY TO REMOVE
EXISTING AVE. UNANSWERED
TEACHER WE CANNOT ALLOW THE
PROSPECT OF SUCH TECHNOLOGY TO
BECOME EXCUSE TO CONTINUE
CREATING POLLUTION. AND WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT ANY TECHNOLOGIES
WILL NOT CREATE ADDITIONAL. AIR
POLLUTANTS IN THE- RT OVER BY
BY POOR AIR. AND IMPACTS. URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ON HOW THAT
HAVE IMPISH GOALS REDUCE THE
PROJECT YOU WHICH YEAR MISSION
REDUCTION. PEOPLE FIVE O'CLOCK
POLICY THE OPEN WITH THE OF
CLEAN ENERGY IN STATE NOT A LOT
OF TOP OF. THE TOP LEGAL
GUARANTEE TO RESULT IN
REDUCTIONS IN CARBON. AIR
COULDN'T AND OTHER IMPACT IN
THE PARK YEAH TO BE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOT GONNA LIE NUMBER
ONE. I GET LINE NUMBER. ONE
YEAR LATER OPEN. THANK YOU THIS
IS WILL BEAR WITH THE LUNG IS-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PANEL'S TODAY VERY INSIGHTFUL-
WANTED TO START BY JUST BAY
FIND CLIMATE CHANGE THE CLEAR
AND PRESENT PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. CRISIS IS DRIVEN BY THE
COMBUSTION OF FOSSIL FUELS
TRANSPORTATION IS THE DOMINANT
SOURCE OF THIS CRISIS. THE
DOMINANT SORT OF OUR WORST IN
THE NATION AIR POLLUTION
CHALLENGES CLIMATE CHANGE
MAKING CLEANING OUR AIR MORE
DIFFICULT AMPS UP. MULTIPLE
THREATS TO PUBLIC HEALTH THE
LEGISLATURE MUST CONTINUE
STRONG POLICIES AND INVESTMENTS
IN ZERO EMISSION TRANSPORTATION
BUS DRIVE GREATER DEPLOYMENT OF
NON COMBUSTION RENEWABLE
ENERGY. AND ENSURE THAT WE GET
ON TRACK FOR HELP YOUR
COMMUNITIES MORE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES THROUGH VMT
REDUCTIONS. AND IMPLEMENTING
CALIFORNIA AT B. THREE SEVENTY
FIVE HI PROTECTION. AND STABLE
COMMUNITIES POLICY. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND CARPET FOCUS
FIRST AND FOREMOST OUR NEAR
TERM DIRECTION GRATITUDE TO
PROTECT. THE HEALTH OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND ESPECIALLY THE
COMMUNITIES MOST OVERBURDENED
BY AIR POLLUTION TODAY AND MOST
AT RISK AND OUR CLIMATE
CHANGES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. I'M NOT GONNA LIE
NUMBER FORTY NINE AGAIN LINE
ABOUT FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NUMBER FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HELLO OKAY ROBERT SMITH
THE PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX IN
LOS ANGELES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE POSITION OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES YOU KNOW YOU GUYS CAN.
LOOK AT THE SERVER IN THE
MULTIPLE WAYS ONE SIDE CAN'T
WIN OVER THE OTHER IT HAS TO BE
OUR JOBS AND M. AT THE SAME
TIME WE NEED TO GRADUALLY GET
TO- HELPING GREEN AND GREEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO
GOOD LINE NUMBER FIFTY AGAIN
LINE NUMBER FIVE IBM LABOR
NINETY IT'S NINE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SELECTED ONE
OF THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUM. ALONG WITH ONE HUNDRED
MUSEUMS WE RESCUE LAST WEEK TO
CONTINUE URGING STATE
INVESTMENT IN THE PROTECTION OF
CULTURAL ASSETS AND CLIMATE
CHANGE EDUCATION IN MUSEUMS AND
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS. WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO YOU SENATOR ALLEN
FOR JOINING MUSEUM LEADERS LAST
WEEK AT THE GRANT PARK IT
HIGHLIGHTS OUR REQUEST FOR A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR COMPETITIVE GRANTS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL HISTORICAL IN DOWN
THERE AT THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY. MANY ORGANIZATIONS LACK
LONG TERM PROTECTION STRATEGIES
FOR THE COLLECTIONS AND
HISTORIC STRUCTURE WHEN
PARADISE WAS DESTROYED BY FIRE
THE GOLD NUGGET MUSEUM O'CLOCK.
JUST LAST WEEK PASSED BY ALL
THE MORRELL MUSEUM WAS
DESTROYED BY THE DIXIE FIRE
MANY OTHER MUSEUMS HAVE BEEN A
WILDFIRE EVACUATIONS DOWN. ON
AN INVESTMENT FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND CLIMATE CHANGE
EDUCATION AND MEDICATION AND
MUSEUM WILL BOOST OUR FIELDS
ABILITY TO PROMOTE LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS AND RESILIENCY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THANK. YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT THANK
YOU. WITHOUT WATER LINE NUMBER
SIX LAMBERT NINE SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MELISSA
ROMERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS-
SO I WANT TO SAY FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. WE MUST
ACT SWIFTLY AND DECISIVELY TO
DRASTICALLY REDUCE EMISSIONS IT
WILL BE COSTLY IT WILL REQUIRE
A GREAT DEAL OF COLLABORATION
ACROSS INDUSTRIES ACROSS IN
YOUR INTEREST BUT THE
ALTERNATIVE OF INSTALLING SHORT
IS MUCH MORE COSTLY AND THAT
INCLUDES A LOSS OF HUMAN LIFE.
WHICH WE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD NOT
ACCEPT WE CAN WE CAN BUILD A
BETTER FUTURE AND WE MUST NOT
LET CORPORATE POLLUTERS
CONVINCED THAT THIS IS NOT A
WORTHWHILE EFFORT. WE HAVE TO
BE HONEST WITH OURSELVES ABOUT
THE SCALE OF EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS THAT WILL BE
REQUIRED TO ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY AND THE STATE
CLIMATE GOALS THAT ARE ALREADY
IN PLACE. THE REALITY IS THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THE WORK TO
ACHIEVING CARBON NEUTRALITY
MUST BE CARBON EMISSIONS WE ARE
TO ACHIEVE THE TARGET. AND WHEN
CONSIDERING TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTIONS FOR CARBON REMOVAL IN
ADDITION TO MAJOR BANKS
CARNAVAL WHICH HAVE HUGE
POTENTIAL NOT ONLY REMOVING
CARBON EMISSIONS BUT ALSO A
MULTITUDE OF COMPANIES THAT IT
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WAY THEN TO ENSURE
THAT THE USE OF TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTIONS THAT'S NOT CONTINUE
OUR RELIANCE ON FOSSIL FUELS.
AND DOES NOT INCREASE TOXIC AIR
POLLUTION WE CANNOT CONTINUE
BUSINESS AS USUAL AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE TESTIFIED THE DIRECTION
TO ENSURE THAT. HìNH IS NOT
THE CASE. TIME COMING.
CALIFORNIA PROVEN. ARGUE AGAIN
CLIMATE BY. AND WHEN IT COMES
DOWN TO IT I'M ACTUALLY LARGELY
QUICKLY ACCOUNT OF THE NATION'S
LARGEST CORPORATION BETTER
RIGHT NOW PUTTING SMALL
BUSINESSES OUT OF BUSINESS.
BETTER UNDERPAYMENTS READING
WORKERS ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
MOST RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
MAJORITY OF CARBON EMISSIONS.
WHICH HAVE CAUSED THE CLIMATE
CRISIS PLEASE PLEASE. CONTINUE
OKAY. WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF TIME
MAKING DECISIONS WHICH WILL
IMPACT NOT TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS BUT RIGHT NOW
CURRENT GENERATION- AND WE
REJECT THE NOTION THAT
ADDRESSING CLIMATE SCALE AND
TAKE NECESSARY. FEATURE IS NOT
COMPATIBLE JOB CREATION WRITING
ECONOMY TELEPORT ECONOMIC
RACIAL AND CLIMATE JUSTICE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NUMBER NINETEEN
AGAIN ONE LINE NUMBER ONE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE GLENN LOVE
ALL POLITICAL COORDINATOR OF
IRONWORKERS UNION LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT- STANDING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
BIAFRA FALLS. COULD BOARD
REITERATED EARLIER IT IS
IMPERATIVE ON THIS MATTER THAT
WE'VE CATEGORICALLY STEP HIGH
LABOR STANDARDS- FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PRESENTLY END OF
THE FUTURE ACROSS OF COURSE
UNTIL THE RENEWABLE ENERGY
CARBON CAPTURE AND OF COURSE
MODERNIZATION OF EXISTING
DOMESTIC ENERGY PRODUCTION.
AVOIDING A SEQUENCE OF POLICIES
THAT WOULD PRODUCE OUT WINDOWS
LEAGUE. LEAKAGE OR INFIGHTING
HIGHER GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
FROM OUT OF THE REGION AND
UNINTENTIONALLY REDISTRIBUTING
ENERGY TO. SUPPLY OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA IT IS CRITICAL THAT
WE FOCUS ON DEMAND AND BUILD UP
OUR DOMESTIC. ENERGY OUR
CAPACITY IN THE OTHER FIRST
STEP HERE IN THE END- BUT OUR
QUEST FOR NET ZERO. POINT
EVENTUALLY WE ALSO NEED
CONSISTENT STRONG
REPRESENTATION OF LABOUR ACROSS
ALL PLANNING POLICY AND
IMPLEMENTATION IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE AS PRETTY WELL ARTICULATED
BY EARLIER SPEAKERS. THAT WERE
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT BIRO OPTED
MAKING IT WITH WORKERS HALL AND
WORKERS. WORKING THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HELLO NOW BOTTOM
LINE SIX SIX AGAIN TO BURST SIX
ONE OF THE- YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIRMAN- MY NAME IS TIGHTLY
BAGLEY AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STEEL WORKERS LOCAL
THREE TWENTY SIX. AND I
REPRESENT YOU ARE EIGHTY NINE
OPERATIONS MANAGER LABORATORY
EMPLOYEES AT THE PHILLIPS SIXTY
SIX REFINERY WOOD DALE KABIN
PORTABILITY FOR EIGHT YEARS NOW
I'M VERY PROUD TO BE A
REPRESENTATIVE BALLFIELD SIXTY
SIX. AND UNITED STEELWORKERS.
USW LOCAL THREE TWENTY SIX
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE BILL
SIXTY SIX WILL DEBUT NEW
PROJECTS WHICH CONTINUES A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE YEAR
HERITAGE OF PROVIDINGHIGH WAGE
LOCAL CAREERS FOR GENERATIONS
OF STEEL WORKERS AND STATE
TREATMENT AGAIN. WHICH WILL BE
AWARDED FOR GOING TO CONVERT TO
RESPOND WHICH FOR THE FOR THE
LOCAL FUELS FROM FATS OILS AND
GREASES THIS INNOVATIVE PROJECT
WILL MAKE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
ALISTAIR CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE
WORLD LEADERS YOU CLEANER G.
AND HELP YOU ACHIEVE THE
STATE'S GOLD CARD YOUR CHILD.
IT WILL REDUCE OUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT HELPS IMPROVE AIR
QUALITY TRANSPORT LESS CRUDE
OIL INTO THE BAY AND PROVIDE
CLEAN RENEWABLE FUEL SUPPORTING
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED.
UNION LED CONSTRUCTION JOBS BUT
WHEN APPROXIMATELY FOUR MILLION
WORK HOURS AND APPOINT ROUGHLY
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY WOULD NOBLE
ENERGY JOBS FOR MY US W. LOCAL
AS WELL AS MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN STATE BUILDING
TRADES. ON BEHALF OF THE U. S.
W. LOCAL TWENTY SIX THREE
TWENTY SIX WE ASK YOU TO ENSURE
WE HAVE REGULATORY CERTAINTY TO
ALLOW PROJECTS SUCH AS WILL BE
A NEW TRUE CURRENT CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME ALLOW.
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY THANK YOU. NOT
GONNA LIE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
LINE TWO. ZERO IS OPEN. SHOULD
I GET OUT MR CHAIRMAN. MY NAME
IS AN THIS SO I'M BUSINESS DAY
BUT HE PROCESS LATER SPOKE
SIXTEEN. WE STAND SOLIDARITY
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
ON THIS S. I'D LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE THE BOARD TO MAKE
SURE THE CONSTRUCTION MEMBERS
FROM ORGANIZED LABOR HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE DURING THESE
DISCUSSIONS. ONE ONLY
ENVIRONMENTALISTS ARE ALLOWED
TO PROVIDE INPUT NOTHING GETS
BUILT. WINDFARM PROJECTS HAVE
BEEN CANCELLED BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN LABELED AS BIRD BINDERS
HYDRO PROJECTS HAVE BEEN SHOT
DOWN BECAUSE THEY'RE LABELED AS
FISHMONGERS. CARBON CAPTURE
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN SCRAPPED
BECAUSE THEY WILL PROLONG LIFE
REFINERIES. I POINT IS THIS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS DON'T WANT TO
BUILD ANYTHING. YOU WANNA SHUT
EVERYTHING DOWN WITHOUT A WAY
TO REPLACE THE LOSS OF ENERGY
USAGE ANY POLICY ON CLIMATE IS
ALSO POLICY ON ENERGY AND
THEREFORE ORGANIZED LABOR
SHOULD HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE
TO HELP PROMOTE THE MOST.
REALISTIC WAY TO REMAIN ENERGY
EFFICIENT. WE WANT TO BUILD AND
CLIMATE IN. BUT WE NEED A SEAT
AT THE TABLE TO HELP INSURE DAY
ACTUALLY GET BUILT THANK YOU
AND I DID HAVE ONE QUESTION I
DIDN'T HEAR ANYBODY ADDRESS
WITH ALL THE ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
THAT'S THE FUTURE POLICY. HOW
ARE WE GOING TO PAY FOR ROAD
REPAIRS WHEN THERE'S LESS
GASOLINE TAX. THAT PAYS FOR
THAT JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THANK YOU. I'M NOT GONNA LIE
NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR AGAIN LINE
NUMBER EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DAVID BEANIE AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
SANTA CLARA AND SAN BENITO
COUNTY BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
REPRESENTING OVER THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND LOCAL MEMBERS WHO
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THEIR
SISTERS AND BROTHERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA UNDER THE BANNER OF
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL. MANY OF OUR CLIMATE
POLICY TO DATE OKAY SON BANDS
OF OIL AND GAS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND SUCH POLICY
FAILS TO RECOGNIZE THAT
RESTRICT RESTRICTING
PRODUCTION. WILL NOT RESTRICT
USE INSTEAD WHAT BANDS DO IT
WHAT ARE LOCAL RESIDENTS OUT OF
WAR. BIG DEVASTATE FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. PRODUCTION AND
DISTRIBUTION ARE NOT DECREASED
PERRANCE IT MOVED OUTSIDE THE
INFLUENCE OF LOCAL REGULATION
LOCAL PRODUCERS AND SUPPLIERS
TO PUT OUT OF BUSINESS WELL
OFFSHORE SOURCES ARE ALLOWED TO
THRIVE AT OUR EXPENSE. BUT
HUMAN IMPACT OF THE IMPERIALIST
POLICIES IT'S A GOOD PLAN LAKE
SUPPORTING JOB THEY'RE
DESTROYED. AND THE WORK IS
TRANSFERRED TO COUNTRIES THAT
DON'T EVEN HAVE THE SAME LABOR
STANDARDS THAT WE DO. THE
CLIMATE IMPACT IS CONTRARY TO
THE GOAL AS WELL AS OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE LESSER
PRODUCTION AND EMISSIONS
STANDARDS. AND THAT WILL
INCLUDE THE ADDITIONAL
TRANSPORTATION OUR MARKETS. WE
HAVE TO BE MORE THOUGHTFUL ON
HOW WE ADDRESS CLIMATE. CHANGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO NOW
GOOD LIE NUMBER NINETY EIGHT
AGAIN LINE NUMBER NINE EIGHT
LINE IS A- THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS JOBS FALL
IN ON THE EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
OF THE KERN INYO AND MONO
COUNTIES BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
LOCATED IN BAKERSFIELD.
REPRESENTING OVER TEN THOUSAND
BUILDING TRADESMEN AND WOMEN.
WE ARE REALLY THE BOOKS ON THE
GROUND. KERN COUNTY WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PRODUCE CLEAN FOSSIL
FUELS TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
WILL NOT BE DEPENDED ON FOREIGN
COUNTRIES TO PUT UP TO POWER
OUR STATE AS WE SEEM TO BE
BECOMING. IN KERN COUNTY WE ARE
PREPARING TO CONSTRUCT A CARBON
CAPTURE FACILITY THAT WILL
REMOVE ONE MILLION METRIC TONS
OF EMISSIONS CARBON DIOXIDE.
PER YEAR. KERN COUNTY IS THE
LEADING SOLAR AND WIND ENERGY
PRODUCER IN THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE ONE RENEWABLE DIESEL
FACILITY UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
WITH ANOTHER TO START SOON.
WHAT KERN COUNTY BE A PART OF
THE SOLUTION FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I'M NOT
GONNA LIE NUMBER EIGHTY TWO
AGAIN LONGTIME NUMBER EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU-
THE COUNSELOR OF THE GAWKER
GROUP CURRENTLY OUT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CONFIRMED MY
ACCOUNT BALANCE THE BUSINESS
LABOR ORGANIZATION. AND AGAIN
ONE TO- SINCERE COMMENTS WITH
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
AND SUPPORTER MATHIS SAID.
ABOUT ONE EMPHASIZED THE- IN
ORDER TO COVER THE TRIAL YOU
NEED A PORTFOLIO. APPROACH THAT
AND EVERYTHING AND- WE CAN'T
SPLIT ONE TECHNO OTHERS. TO
EARLY IN THEIR DEVELOPMENT. OF
THE DAY SO TECHNOLOGY IS NOT
WHICH ONES AWAY. WE SHOULD PUT
AN EMPHASIS ON BUILDING TE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO
SUPPORTERS YOUR APARTMENT
KANEMI. THAT IS TO BUILD WHAT
IS NEEDED IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
THIS WE BASICALLY KNOW THAT THE
SYSTEM CAN BE RETROFITTED OR
UPGRADED OR HARDENED IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS WITH
ELECTRICAL WORK. YOUR CARBON
MOLECULES ARE LOW COVERED BALL
KILLED IN ORDER TO MITIGATE THE
CHARLOTTE I HAVE CLIENTS THAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE. ALSO VP
FOCUSED POLICIES IMPACT-
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. AND
WORKFORCE IS THE MOST- SERVICE
INDUSTRY CONSTRUCTION DO NOT
HAVE A CHOICE OF WHETHER OR NOT
TO WORK FROM HOME. THEREFORE
REDUCING THEIR B. AND T. WILL
BURN YOU HAVE TO FOCUS POLICIES
WILL BE A DIRECT IMPACT TO THE-
THEIR BOTTOM LINE AS HOUSEHOLD
BUDGETS. ALSO AS WE DISCUSSED A
REVENUES AT MERCY THE
MECHANISMS TO GENERATE THOSE
REVENUES BEING CAPTURED OR
CARBON TAX. HE'S A STRONG-SUPPORTER AND CAP AND TRADE AT
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
MECHANISM TO REDUCING EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. ALSO MEANING WE'RE
TRYING TO MINIMIZE THE COST. TO
THE GENERAL PUBLIC- WHEN COMES
COMMUTER PROBABLY IT. YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT. AND WHO PAYS FOR IT
IS BIG GOAL. THE BIGGEST
QUESTION THE LEAD. HAS TO
WRESTLE WITH. AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE HAVE. YOU KNOW THERE'S
MEDICAL DOCTORS COOLEY TALK
ABOUT THE COST OF THE
ELECTRICAL- BILL IS. MUCH
HIGHER THAN THE REST OF OUR-
THE COUNTRY INTO WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON THAT AND ASK- RAPPER
PLEASE BOOK THE MATHEMATICIAN
COMMENTING THAT WILL HOLD. IT
THANKS FOR THE HEARING- WHAT
THE- COMMISSION COMMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR. WAGA LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX SECOND LINE
NUMBER TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY GOOD AFTERNOON- THIS
IS CHRIS MATTER WITH THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
YEAH I GOT TO HEAR ME OKAY. YES
WE CAN- WHY DID I NOBODY ON THE
PANEL- AND I WANT TO SPEAK TO.
THE LEGISLATORS- THAT MADE MY
FRIEND THE LEGISLATURE AND MY
FRIENDS AND BARBARA MOVEMENT.
I'M HERE SUPPORT YEAH THE- IN
THE STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. AND I ARE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
MEMBERS WITH OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE. NOBODY
DEBATES THE FACT THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS HAPPENING OUR MEMBERS
HAVE DONE. THE CLEAN UP ON THE
WILDFIRE DISASTERS ARE MEMBERS
OF DON. OF CLIMATE MITIGATION
ON THIRTY SEVEN WENT DOWN UNDER
WATER- AND WE YOU KNOW WE ALL
TALK ABOUT JUST TRANSITION BUT-
WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
THAT WORD. TRANSITION TO. AND
IT'S GOING TO TAKE TIME- IT
BECAUSE OUR OUR MEMBERS THESE
ARE GOOD JOBS- THINGS LIKE THE
RENEWABLE FUELS PROJECT THAT I
READ NOW. LIKE OUR FRIENDS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT TO HELP
US- GET THE OFFSHORE WIND
PROJECTS UP AND UP AND DOWN THE
COASTLINE. HIGH SPEED RAIL
ANOTHER GREAT GREEN JOBS GREEN
JOBS GET OUT OF MEDICAID. OUR
NATION'S. THIRTY PROJECTS OF
THE GUYS THAT ARE WAITING TO
GET OFF. I WOULD ENCOURAGE- ALL
OF US TO WORK TOGETHER ON THIS
ARE. IN AND IT IS GOING TO TAKE
A TRANSITION WEATHER'S CARBON
CAPTURE AND EVENTUAL
ELECTRIFICATION WAY DOWN THE
ROAD BUT- IT IS IT OKAY TO TAKE
A GROUP EFFORT AND I JUST
APPRECIATE. YOUR TIME TODAY-
WE'RE HERE TO WORK WITH ALL OF.
OUR BROTHERS SISTER THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND- WE WANT USERS BE
PREVAILING WAGE. AND. SKILLED
AND TWENTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
VALGA LINED UP EIGHTY. CAROLINA
EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HIDING MUCH FOR SIGNAL
LEADERSHIP FOR IN A OF. I WANT
TO BUILD ON COMMENTS THAT
SEVERAL SPEAKERS WHO SPOKE TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING THAT
OUR POLICY. IS NOT FURTHER HARM
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES. INCLUDING POINTS
MADE BY PAULINA TODD IS
JENNIFER FEARING LAUREN COLUMN.
ANALYSTS ARE MARYLAND
SPECIFICALLY ENTREVISTAS
FRESHLY REJECT THE ASSUMPTION
THAT EMISSIONS REDUCTION
SOMEWHERE ARE GOOD FOR PEOPLE
EVERYWHERE. CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUED RELIANCE ON OFFICE
SCHEMES SO I'VE BEEN FACING
THIS ASSUMPTION. IN OUR ON
GOING AND PER FIRST
SENSITIZATION OF DERRY DIED
YESTERDAY NOT ONLY RESULT IN
INCREASED NOTHING PRODUCTION IN
THE FORM OF INCREASED THE
NEWER. BUT ALSO INCREASE
METHANE FROM ENTERIC EMISSIONS
INCREASED AIR POLLUTION
INCREASE GROUNDWATER POLLUTION
FROM EXPANDED JERRY.
CALIFORNIANS PLANNER POLICIES
MUST BE BETTER THAN MOST IN
ACTUALITY BE GOOD FOR PEOPLE
EVERYWHERE. THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU. GLOBALEYE NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX AGAIN LINE NUMBER
SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
COMMITTEE CHAIRS- THIS IS CHRIS
HAMMOND WITH THE LOS ANGELES
NORTH COUNTIES BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES. ON BEHALF
OF A HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
OF THE BEST TRAINED MEN AND
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION
REPRESENTED BY FORTY EIGHT
BILLION THE- LAW ORGANIZATIONS.
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL CALIFORNIA IN
ASKING- CALIFORNIA LEADERS TO
DELIVER A DIVERSE ENERGY
PORTFOLIO. THAT IS. PURDUE'S
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. BY GUILT
TRAINED WORKERS- WITH FAMILY
SUSTAINING WAGES HEALTH CARE-
THE CHANCE TO EARN A SECURE
RETIREMENT SO WE COULD STAY IN
THE STATE WHEN WE RETIRE-
SOCIETY DOESN'T HAVE A GOOD
TRACK RECORD. OF TAKING CARE OF
THE VULNERABLE AND OUR MEMBERS
ARE NOT ABOUT TO BECOME PART OF
THE VULNERABLE. WE WILL WANT TO
WORK TOGETHER WITH THE STATE
THE WHAT THE LEADERS OF THE
STATE AND- BE THE BEST POSSIBLE
PARTICIPANTS FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT- BUT THESE JOBS
HAVE TO BE LOCAL AND UP UNTIL
THE LAST DAY THAT WE USE
GASOLINE IT SHOULD BE PRODUCED
IN CALIFORNIA. BY UNION HI K.
HIGH SKILLED CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYEES WE HOULD BE
IMPORTING- ANY FORM OF ENERGY
WHETHER IT BE ELECTRICITY
WHETHER IT BE- GASOLINE OR
OTHER AND OUR GOALS MUST BE-
MUST BE BROUGHT IN THE MUST
INCLUDE CARBON CAPTURE THAT
MUST INCLUDE TECHNOLOGIES LIKE
HYDROGEN AND- AS ONE SPEAKER
STATED BEFORE WE SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN OUR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS DEVELOPED THE NEXT
TECHNOLOGIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND- AGAIN. THANKS FOR ARE.
PROBABLY NOT ON THE CALL TODAY
AND WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES OUT GOOD FOR
LOCAL JOBS THAT WORST JOBS IN A
DIVERSE ENERGY PORTFOLIO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I'M NOT GONNA
LIE NUMBER ONE OH FIVE AGAIN
LINE ONE ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS OR A LARGER WITH
THE CLIMATE CENTER THAT
SPECIFIC THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING THE ZIPPER
INFORMATIVE. KNOW WHAT THE END
OF THE DAY I COMMON SHORT ABOUT
THE REFLECTIVITY REPORT MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO INCREASE
OUR CLIMB EDITION. TO THAT AND
WE'RE URGING LEGISLATORS TO
ADOPT THE TARGET OF THE
SHOOTING THAT NIGHT OF THE
NATION'S FIVE TWENTY THIRTY.
SEVEN THAT'S NOT THAT TARGET
WILL SEND THE TOP MARKET SIGNAL
THAT SO MANY OF THE SPEAKERS
HAVE REFERENCED IN SO THAT WE
CAN GET THE TECHNOLOGY. NEEDED
TO ACTUALLY ACHIEVE OUR GOALS
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE TOP WAYS THE TICKET IN THE
CALL IS TO UTILIZE EDUCATE THE
CONSTRUCTION WITH JUST UNDER
SKINNER NOTED HAD SPECIAL.
SIGNIFICANCE THANK WHAT'S MEANT
MORE COMMENTS TO BUY WRITTEN.
LETTERS THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. NOW GO TO LINE NUMBER NINE
NINE LINE NUMBER NINE NINE.
DIVIDED UP INTO DIFFERENT. HI
THIS IS RACHEL SHUMAKER- ON
BEHALF OF THE IBEW LOCAL THREE
OF TWO IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
REPRESENTING OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED ELECTRICAL WORKERS. IN
IN THE COUNTY- I'M CALLING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES. AND THE DOCTOR
VALLEY STATED EARLIER HOW WE DO
IT MATTERS. WE CAN'T MANDATE
OUR PATH FORWARD. WE NEED
INNOVATION ACROSS THE BOARD.
HAVING CAPTURE THEM IMPERATIVES
CAN MEET THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND
WE NEED TO FULLY CONSIDER
INNOVATION THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO MEET THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND
CREATE JOBS. GOOD UNION JOBS
THAT HAVE BENEFITS- LIKE CARBON
CAPTURE NO AND LOW EMISSION
FUEL AND WATER RESILIENCY- YOUR
TIME AND ON THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THIS MATTER. THANK
YOU. NOT GONNA LIE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN OF MY NUMBER ONE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS KEN MILLER
VISITATION ORGANIZER FOR
IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT. I'M CALLING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING CHAINS AND I THINK YOU
SHOULD- IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER ONE OF
THE FOLLOWING ISSUES SUCH AS-
FULLER TOOK THE CATION OF OUR
BUILDINGS ARE CARS WOULD
COLLAPSE CALIFORNIANS.
ELECTRICAL GRID. I LIVE IN NAPA
COUNTY AND EVERY TIME IT GETS
HOT WE GET MESSAGES ABOUT THE
POSSIBLE- BROWNOUTS EVERY TIME
THE WIND BLOWS WE GET MESSAGES
OF THE PS PS PROBLEM. THAT PG&E-
BIOLOGICAL GET NEEDS TO BE
REPLACED IT NEEDS TO BE
MODERNIZED AND NEED TO BE
BEEFED UP AND WE NEED TO EXPAND
IT FOR FUTURE USE AND FUTURE
EXPANSION. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. AND THAT WAS
THE LAST COUPLE OF A LOT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU TO ALL
THAT- ON THAT ARE STILL HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM- WE HAD A VERY
INFORMATIVE HEARING AND- WE
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU WITH THAT THIS.
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.